Wolfgang raucht nicht mehr. Er bleibt tapfer, taff. Ein wahrer Mann.
Ja.
Wir gratulieren.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob man schon gratulieren kann. Jedenfalls ist es so,
dass es interessant ist, wenn man ja ein festes Ritual hat.
Ich mache den Sticker.
Dann ist das gar nicht so leicht, ein Ritual loszuwerden. Denn bei mir ist es
ja nicht eine Nikotinsucht. Dafür habe ich zu wenig geraucht.
Es waren zwei, drei Zigaretten. Aber immer abends und immer nach 22 Uhr.
Das heißt, es fehlt jetzt etwas nach 22 Uhr. das neue Ritual zu finden,
ist noch nicht gelungen. Es ist also nicht der Sport nach 22 Uhr.
Oh, sollen dir die Leute Vorschläge schicken?
Nein.
Doch, doch, doch.
Allein, weil ich interessiert bin.
Was die Leute für Ideen haben, was Wolfgang nach 22 Uhr machen könnte.
Jedenfalls gehe ich jetzt auch zweimal die Woche ins Fitnessstudio.
Hört, hört! Warum?
Nun, ich habe mir gedacht, es kann nicht schaden. Es hält fit.
Die Anzüge sitzen noch ein bisschen besser. Ich meine, für Onlyfans reicht es
noch nicht, aber ich sehe schon jetzt, nachdem ich einige Wochen es schon mache,
oder Monate sind es jetzt schon, drei, vier Monate, sehe ich wirklich Erfolge
und ich höre währenddessen Podcasts, höre währenddessen auch Podcasts,
die ich sonst nicht hören würde,
aber während man da so an diesen Geräten zieht und drückt und presst,
ist das doch eigentlich ganz angenehm.
Machst du auch Cardio im Fitnessstudio?
Ein bisschen Crosstrainer. Aber ich will es da nicht übertreiben.
Kann man nicht zu Fuß hingehen ins Fitnessstudio? Zur Not zwei Kilometer weit weg parken?
Ich mache es natürlich ganz klassisch. Fahre mit dem Auto hin,
Tiefgarage rauf und dann rein.
Ich sage mal so, Schritt für Schritt.
Ja, ich will es ja jetzt nicht übertreiben. Also ich will ja jetzt nicht bald
den Berlin-Marathon bestreiten, sondern ich möchte einfach nur dort mich ein bisschen ertüchtigen.
Vor allem, damit die Anzüge besser sitzen. Das ist das eigentliche.
Eigentlich, mir geht es ja gar nicht darum, jetzt zum Gesundheitsapostel zu werden.
Aber ich habe noch etwas beherzigt aus unseren vielen Salons,
in denen du uns immer aufgeklärt hast, was man alles gesundheitlich machen sollte.
Pass auf, du hattest einmal ein Porträt vorgestellt über Shahin,
unseren Impfstofferfinder, was er für einen Tee trinkt.
Der O-Long-Tee.
Der O-Long-Tee. Den habe ich mir bestellt und der schmeckt gut.
Also geschmacklich soll er ja eigentlich nicht so überzeugen.
Sondern die Leute trinken ihn aus. Also er ist nicht so lecker wie jetzt ein
guter schwarzer Teer, aber doch, ich bin ganz begeistert.
Die Frankfurter Paulskirche, sie steht an diesem Sonntag.
Die Paulskirche kommt gleich. Da geht es schon gleich los.
Ja.
Okay, das ist sehr gut. Wir finden das alle, ich möchte stellvertretend für
alle Hörerinnen und Hörer hier sagen.
Also wir wollen davon nichts ableiten, wir wollen einfach nur das feststellen, dass es so ist.
Ich werde heute, nachdem wir das Schnitzel bestellt haben,
Sagen, ich gehe mal auf Toilette, dabei gehe ich gar nicht auf Toilette,
sondern ich gehe kurz in die Küche und sage, wir haben vergessen,
auf beiden Tellern soll Gemüse liegen.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, bloß nicht. Ich werde jetzt nicht zum Gesundheitsapostel.
Das ist ja das Schlimmste. Man darf jetzt nicht so ein Konvertit werden.
Ja, nur wenn man mit dem Rauchen aufgehört hat, will man dann auch anderen Leuten das Rauchen verbieten.
Wie du weißt, erfolgt nächstes Jahr eine Buchveröffentlichung von mir zum Thema,
man sagt gemeinhin Familie, aber gemeint ist die unmittelbare Lebenswelt,
das nahe, vor Ort, raumgebunden, Körperlichkeit und so.
Es gibt eine, wie ich mir jetzt überraschend festgestellt habe,
doch sehr große Kluft zwischen der politischen Sphäre und dem eigenen,
privaten, kleinen, Intimsphäre-Leben.
Die Brücke dazwischen ist nicht die Mission, sondern man kann einfach seine
Lebenswelt gestalten, wie sie richtig ist,
ohne dass man konvertieren, ja, ist ein politischer Begriff,
der hat da nichts zu suchen, wo du dich gerade aufhältst. Von daher, Feuer frei.
Ich sage nochmal, gratulieren hier, das ist sehr gut.
Prima.
Wir sind sehr stolz auf dich, Wolfgang M. Schmidt.
Ich danke dir.
Jetzt zur Politik.
Jetzt zur Politik oder zur Literatur oder zur Politik und Literatur.
Es war die Frankfurter Buchmeister, wir haben schon herzlich gelacht,
wie merkwürdig, dass da alles so ist.
Du warst kurz da, ich war wieder nicht da, habe auch eigentlich gar keine Lust dahin zu gehen.
Ja, so richtig.
Jedenfalls ist auch der Kriegsverzeihung Friedenspreis des deutschen Buchhandels
verliehen wurden, dieses Jahr an Anne Eppelbaum.
Jetzt werden manche Anne Eppelbaum gar nicht kennen, Glück gehabt,
aber das wird sich jetzt ändern.
Viele werden aber wissen, ja, Anne Eppelbaum, da war doch was,
die ist doch publizistisch seit 20 Jahren und länger unterwegs.
Wer ist sie eigentlich? Sie ist eine Historikerin, hat sich viel mit der Geschichte
Russlands, der Geschichte...
Der Sowjetunion beschäftigt, durchaus umstritten dort auch ihre Ergebnisse und
nicht nur jetzt von Leuten,
die eine andere Sicht auf den Krieg in der Ukraine haben, sondern zum Beispiel
auch von jemandem wie Franziska Davies,
die auch eine Osteuropa-Expertin ist und die dieses Buch von Anne Applebaum
über die Sowjetunion sehr verrissen hat in der Süddeutschen Zeitung.
Also es ist keineswegs so, dass man einhellig sie lobt, aber wir wollen uns
jetzt gar nicht mit ihrer historischen Expertise auseinandersetzen,
sondern eher mit dem, was sie sonst so politisch an sich geht.
Genau, bevor du da groß einsteigst. Beide Namen, die du jetzt genannt hattest,
sind mir bekannt. Ich habe sie beide aussortiert.
Und mit aussortiert meine ich auf Twitter geblockt und auch ansonsten,
ich will das gar nicht sehen, eigentlich, was da passiert.
So, bei Applebaum, das wirst du uns ja gleich sagen, Franziska Davies habe ich
aussortiert, nachdem sie ein, hier muss man aber mal was klarstellen,
Text geschrieben hat, über die Logonachrichten für Kinder,
weil nämlich sich das CDF dort erdreistete, einen Text für Kinder zu schreiben,
in dem der Ukraine-Krieg erklärt wird und in der Überschrift stand so der Ukraine-Krieg.
Und sie hat dann drei Absätze aufgewandelt, um zu erklären, das geht so nicht,
man darf die Kinder mit dieser Propaganda nicht behelligen,
denn schon in der Überschrift muss es heißen, der Angriffskrieg,
also der völkerrechtswidrige Angriffskrieg von Wladimir Putin.
Wo ich mir dachte, nein, wir haben irgendwann Text erfunden.
Texte haben auch eine Überschrift, aber es ist vor allem der Text.
Und das darf auch ruhig in Satz 1 stehen, des Textes, das muss nicht in der Überschrift stehen.
Und diese Art von, finde ich, völlig unangebrachter Pingeligkeit,
die Diskursräume absolut zerstört.
Also gerade für Kinder. Die wollen wissen, warum ist der Krieg?
Die wissen nicht. Die haben Putin noch nie namentlich gehört.
Die sind sechs Jahre alt.
Die wissen nicht, was ein Angriffskrieg von einem Krieg oder Verteidigungskrieg
unterscheidet. Das muss man den Kindern erklären.
Stattdessen, nein, das muss alles in die Überschrift. Und ich mir dachte,
nein, manchmal geben sich Erwachsene Mühe und sagen, also stellen sich diese
Aufgabe, wie erkläre ich es meinem Kind und meinen das auch genau so.
Denn Kinder haben auch ein Anrecht darauf, etwas zu erfahren.
Es sind nicht alles, die FAZ hat auch eine Rubrik, wie erkläre ich es meinem
Kind und da wissen wir, das ist eigentlich für Erwachsene gemacht.
Aber Erwachsene geben ungerne zu, dass sie etwas nicht wissen,
möchten es nochmal etwas leichter erklärt haben.
Also gilt das dann als, das ist eigentlich für die Kinder aber und wir wissen, das lesen Erwachsene.
Nein, Kinder haben auch ein Anrecht darauf und als Franziska Davies meinte,
sie muss uns jetzt den völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg von Wladimir Putin
erklären und ich las da aber nur eine Kriegserklärung gegen das kindliche Gemüt,
was sich einfach eine Frage stellt, was ist da los?
Da habe ich es aussortiert. Also wir sind jetzt ein Metier, wenn du sagst,
du spielst das Applebaum Clips, bei denen ich grundsätzlich schon mal Vorbehalte habe.
Ja, es ist ganz furchtbar. Ich verspreche, es wird ganz entsetzlich werden.
Wir müssen es sehr genau jetzt uns anhören.
Jedenfalls noch eine Anmerkung dazu, du hast mitbekommen, die Zeit und auch
der Spiegel dann direkt im Anschluss haben sich jetzt entschieden,
Kiew nicht mehr mit K-I-E-W zu schreiben, sondern mit einer Schreibweise,
die mehrere Ys beinhaltet.
Und da glaubt man also sehr viel mit zu bewegen,
woraufhin Claudius Seidel geschrieben hat, 1939 lebten in Kiew 200.000 Juden
und in Jiddisch hieß das Kiew K-I-E-W.
Was ist mit denen, löscht man jetzt deren Erinnerungen auch aus? Sehr gute Frage.
Ja, beim Thema, wie verwenden wir Worte, ist mir ehrlich gesagt ganz egal.
Ich will einfach nur erkennen, worum es geht. Von mir aus lutherisch den Leuten
aufs Maul schauen und einfach fabulieren.
Denn ich habe die Woche erlebt in einem privaten Gespräch, dass ich sagte,
ich bin ja älter, also im Singular.
Mhm.
Ich habe natürlich jetzt nicht so meine eigene Situation im Hinterkopf,
sondern den Referentenentwurf des Familienministeriums oder Justizministeriums
zum Thema, es gibt jetzt Solo-Mütter.
Also man kann jetzt Mutter sein, ohne jemals irgendwo rechtfertigen zu müssen,
was ist denn mit dem Vater?
Man kann ja aus dem Ausland gekommen sein, da wurde eine Zeugung,
wie auch immer. Es gibt jetzt Solo-Mütter.
Das heißt, und das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat ja das Elternprinzip ausgerufen,
also wir haben jetzt Elternschaft zu dritt und alleine.
Was bedeutet, wir haben ein Wort, das wir eigentlich gar nicht kennen, älter.
Wir sprechen von Eltern und sagen dann ein Elternteil.
Älter kennt man jetzt zum Beispiel in der Biologie.
Spricht man davon. Ja, aber auch Eltern kommt aus der Biologie.
Nur das eine haben wir halt logistiziert. Genau, aber man sagt ein Älter.
Genau, das Wort ein Älter ist nicht ungewöhnlich. Dann habe ich allerdings sofort
ein Facepalm gekriegt, weil diese Gendersprache und so weiter.
Und ich habe dann gesagt, nee, das ist keine Gendersprache.
Hier will sich mal niemand, hier sagt einfach nur jemand älter statt älter.
Einfach singular von einem, wir sind nur an dem Plural gewöhnt.
Von daher, ich rege mich gar nie wieder über Sprache auf.
Also wenn die Kiew schreiben wollen, dann denke ich, okay, Hauptsache ich erkenne es.
Wenn da plötzlich Mogadischu steht, würde ich sagen, nee, das geht dann nicht.
Aber mir ist auch egal. Ich will keine Erklärung hören. Das von Claudio Seidel finde ich dann amüsant.
Aber finde ich auch im Journalismus nichts zu suchen. Kann man auf der Comedy-Bühne bringen. Von daher,
Kiew.
Ja, ja, nur ich werde mir jetzt nicht laufend irgendwelche neuen Schreibweisen mir angehören.
Leute sagen Kaffee und ich denke mir, okay, ich weiß ja, was du meinst,
kein Tee, du willst einen Kaffee.
Ja, okay. Anne Applebaum also bekommt den Friedenspreis des deutschen Buchhandels,
der wird in aller Regel oder immer erreicht in der Frankfurter Paulskirche.
Wir hören rein, oder ich sage zuerst, es gab auch eine ausführliche Kulturzeitberichterstattung
dazu, zwölf Minuten lang. In diesen zwölf Minuten hat man es geschafft,
nicht ein einziges kritisches Wort zu dieser Entscheidung unterzubringen.
Es ist doch so, dass ich so mittlerweile sage, vielleicht ist es gut,
wenn die Rundfunkreform kommt und wir dieses Elend auch los sind.
Na doch, komm.
Jetzt jedenfalls Anmoderation Dreisat überträgt oder Phoenix überträgt.
Mehrere sind jedenfalls da.
Hier Cécile Schortmann macht die Anmoderation Anne Eppelbaum.
Vormittag, am letzten Tag der Buchmesse, ganz im Zeichen des Friedens.
Wünschen wir uns alle. Doch er scheint momentan an einigen Ecken der Welt weit weg.
Und das beunruhigt uns natürlich auch hier zutiefst in der Mitte Europas.
Ich begrüße Sie ganz herzlich zu unserer Live-Übertragung der Verleihung des
Friedenspreises des Deutschen Buchhandels an die polnisch-amerikanische Historikerin
und Publizistin Anne Eppelbaum.
Ihr Verdienst ist es, dass sie die autoritären Systeme dieser Welt offenlegt
und uns damit zeigt, wie wichtig es ist, unsere Demokratien gerade zu verteidigen
gegen die Autokraten dieser Welt.
Denn bei aller Verschiedenheit ist Ines eines gemeinsam, sagt sie,
sie haben uns, sie sehen in uns ihren Feind.
Ja, das ist die Zusammenfassung im Prinzip auch schon der ganzen Rede,
aber wir gehen jetzt gleich näher rein.
Wir hören jetzt erst noch ganz kurz die Vorsitzende des Vereins,
die darüber entscheidet, wer den Preis bekommt.
Es gibt eine Jury, darin sitzen nicht so bedeutende Leute, wenig Bekannte.
Da ist eine Professorin, die das schlechteste Buch über Operette geschrieben
hat, das man je verfasst hat.
Oder auch Jagoda Marienitsch, die überall ja sitzt, wo ein Mikrofon sich anbietet.
Jedenfalls jetzt Karin Schmidt sagt Folgendes.
Gemeinsam haben wir im Verlauf unserer diesjährigen Jury-Tätigkeit ihre Artikel und Bücher gelesen.
Wir haben diskutiert, uns tief und tiefer in ihr Werk eingearbeitet.
Mit bestechender Klarheit beziehen Sie, liebe Anne Appelbaum,
Position zur aktuellen Politik.
Und so, wie ihr Werk den Stiftungsrat überzeugt hat, soll unsere Entscheidung,
sie mit dem Friedenspreis zu ehren, viel positive Resonanz ausgelöst.
Karin Schmidt wird dann noch weitere 15 Minuten etwa reden und ihre große Konversion beschreiben,
denn sie hat einst auch gegen die US-Raketen auf deutschem Boden Wiederbewaffnung
in den 80er Jahren demonstriert.
Auch sie hatte einst geglaubt, dass der Pazifismus etwas sei,
aber dies habe sich ja nun angesichts des völkerrechtswidrigen,
genozidalen Angriffskrieges der Russen und so weiter.
Also du weißt einfach, Chachibiti, bitte schreib so eine Konversionsrede,
jeder hat die jetzt schon mal von sich gegeben im Kulturbetrieb,
ich würde es auch nochmal gern machen. bitte auf, und ich glaube,
das kann man auch dann Chachibiti sagen, bitte auf Paulskirchen-Niveau.
Dass man dann gleich so einen hohen Ton anschlägt. Ja, das findet statt.
Ich will, bevor wir jetzt die Applebaum-Clips spielen, wirklich nochmal sie einordnen.
Denn das finde ich doch sehr skandalös, dass diese Person ausgezeichnet wurde.
Man kann ja, Gott sei Dank, auf ihrer Seite, auf ihrer Homepage alle Artikel
finden, die sie so verfasst hat in den vergangenen 20 Jahren.
Und da ist auch sehr interessant, ihre Haltung zu Roman Polanski,
als der den Prozess gemacht bekommen sollte, hat sie sich dagegen gewehrt und
hat da auch einen Artikel geschrieben, der.
Fahrlässig war, weil sie sagte, er hätte ja schon einen Prozess bekommen,
obwohl es gar keinen Prozess gegeben hatte.
Sie sagte, Polanski habe doch auf vielerlei Arten schon bezahlt für das,
was er getan hat, deswegen müsste er nicht weiter verfolgt werden.
Und dann stellt sich heraus, dass als sie diesen Artikel schrieb,
gleichzeitig ihr Der Ehemann, das ist der polnische Außenminister,
auch dafür lobbyierte, dass Polanski freigelassen würde, als man ihn da in der
Schweiz festgehalten hatte.
Das ist übrigens der polnische Außenminister jetzt wieder aktuell,
der ja geschrieben hat, thank you USA,
als die Pipeline in die Luft gesprengt wurde und der offenbar jetzt auch daran mitgearbeitet hat,
dass der Generalbundesanwalt mit seinem Haftbefehl nicht weiterkam und der eine
Sprengmeister der Pipeline fliehen konnte.
Also in dieser Gemengelage sind wir.
Occupy-Proteste fand sie richtig scheiße, die unterminieren eigentlich die Demokratie,
wir haben doch schließlich Institutionen, warum braucht man außerparlamentarischen Protest,
wo man doch Parlamente hat und eigentlich würden sie dann nur die autoritären
Regime mit unterstützen und es sei doch so, dass die Institutionen dann die
Verantwortlichen zur Rechenschaft ziehen.
Wir wissen ja, dass nach der Finanzkrise 2008, glaube ich, eine einzige Person
zur Rechenschaft juristisch gezogen wurde. Man kann das sehr gut nochmal in
The Big Short nachvollziehen.
Und die anderen haben vier Billionen Dollar geschenkt gekriegt.
Genau, die Institutionen haben also prima funktioniert. Dann gehörte Applebaum
zum Editorial damals von der Washington Post und hat 2000,
also das war jetzt als man den Irakkrieg legitimieren wollte,
gehörte sie diesem Editorial Board an und dieses Editorial Board hat seinerzeit
folgendes veröffentlicht.
Nach der gestrigen Präsentation von Colin Powell,
dem ehemaligen US-Außenminister vor dem Sicherheitsrat der Vereinten Nationen,
ist es schwer vorstellbar, dass noch irgendjemand daran zweifelt,
dass der Irak Massenvernichtungswaffen besitzt.
Herr Paul ließ keinen Raum für ernsthafte Argumente, dass der Irak das Angebot
des Sicherheitsrats einer letzten Gelegenheit zur Abrüstung angenommen hat.
Und er liefert ein schlagkräftiges neues Argument dafür und so weiter.
Also sie gehört mit zu denen, die sagten, der Irak hat Massenvernichtungswaffen,
deswegen muss man da ran. Mehr noch, am 4.
Februar 2003 schreibt Anne Appelbaum einen Meinungsbeitrag zum Thema,
wie sich Europa und vor allem Deutschland verhält in Bezug auf den Irak.
Sie sagt, wir müssen nach Deutschland schauen.
Sie sagt, in den letzten Monaten hat Bundeskanzler Gerhard Schröder 50 Jahre
dieser Tradition umgekehrt. Nämlich die Tradition war ….
Selbst die wütenden Demonstrationen der deutschen Friedensbewegung gegen den
amerikanischen Imperialismus und die amerikanischen Raketen konnten die politische
Klasse Deutschlands nicht von ihrer Unterstützung für die amerikanische Außenpolitik abbringen.
Deutsche Politiker akzeptierten die amerikanische Führung in der Welt und die
Führung der Europäischen Union in Europa.
Jetzt nochmal, in den letzten Monaten hat Bundeskanzler Gerhard Schröder 50
Jahre dieser Tradition umgekehrt. Anstatt die anti-amerikanischen Stimmen in
seinem Land zu unterdrücken, wie es seine Vorgänger taten, hat er sie ermutigt.
Zum ersten Mal sagte mir ein Mitglied des Deutschen Bundestages,
wir haben eine Regierung, die diese Gefühle nicht unterdrückt,
sondern sie vielmehr schürt und ausnutzt.
Und dann geht sie weiter darauf ein und sagt, wer jetzt pro Frieden ist,
der unterstütze eigentlich den Irak mit seinen Massenvernichtungswaffen,
ist anti-amerikanisch.
Wer also sich weigert, am Irakkrieg mitzumachen, wie das Gerhard Schröder mit
der Regierung damals getan hat, agiert eigentlich anti-amerikanisch und hilft
dem Diktator. Das war die Haltung damals und die hat sie auch nie widerrufen.
Sie hat sogar noch in späteren Artikeln Obama immer wieder ermahnt,
nicht so schnell Truppen abzuziehen, an Afghanistan lange festzuhalten.
Sie war es also immer gewesen, die eigentlich stets auf das falsche Ticket gesetzt
hat und die jetzt mit einem Friedenspreis ausgezeichnet wird.
Ja, also der Preis heißt Friedenspreis. Ja.
Das sag ich brutal. Ich meine die ganze Buchmesse, es ist jetzt nicht die Buchmesse,
aber es ist im Rahmen der Buchmesse.
Die Buchmesse, also gibt es da eigentlich nochmal eine Aufarbeitung zum Thema
Gastland Italien und Meloni greift da ein, wie die Delegation zusammengestellt wird.
Nee, nichts.
Das ist ja wirklich erstaunlich.
Wie das einfach weggeschwiegen wird. Vor etwa zwei Jahren war das doch.
Als Götz Kubitschek mit seinem Verlag dort stand und es unglaublich viel Presse
gab, wie das denn sein könne, dass man Rechte auf der Buchmesse duldet und die
seien ja eine Gefahr und, und, und.
Und dann dachte ich, naja, vielleicht sehr, sehr übertrieben,
wenn man sich diesen kleinen Stand da ansieht inmitten dieser Großverlage.
Dann dachte ich, übertreibt man nicht, vielleicht hält die Buchmesse das aus.
Ist nicht schön, aber vielleicht hält sie das aus. Jetzt haben wir ein Gastland
Italien mit einer Ministerpräsidentin,
die einfach Autoren ausschließt, die dafür sorgt,
dass nur eine bestimmte Meinung dort eigentlich stattfindet,
sodass sich italienische Autoren
versuchen zu bündeln, um dort nochmal ein eigenes Programm zu machen.
Und die Offiziellen schweigen dazu völlig, ja moderieren noch mit den anderen
Autoren, die Meloni genehm sind, lustige Panels und alles ist gut.
Ja, also bevor deine neue Freundin Elke Heidenreich mit Marinitsch auf der Bühne
saß, gab es, ich habe es ja auch schon zitiert,
da sitzt einfach eine deutsche Moderatorin mit einer italienischen Schriftstellerin
und redet darüber, dass sich ja die Romane nicht in die Politik einmischen sollen,
weil man ja auch nicht will, dass sich die Politiker die Romane einmischen.
Das ist Tenor der Buchmesse gewesen. Das ist schlimm.
Und dann schwingt man große Reden auf die liberale Demokratie.
Was macht Anne Eppelbaum?
Sie redet sehr lang und sie hat sich...
Wie lange hat sie denn geredet?
So 25 Minuten etwa. Sie gibt sich keinerlei Mühe, auch rhetorisch.
Und vor allem hat sie in den ersten 10, 15 Minuten nur noch mal erklärt,
was so alles passiert ist.
2014, Putin kommt da mit seinen Truppen, die sehen noch gar nicht so aus.
Also diese ganze Geschichte erzählt sie uns nochmal, als hätten wir zehn Jahre
unter einem Stein gelebt.
Das lassen wir jetzt mal weg. Wir versuchen jetzt mal diese Punkte heraus zu
kristallisieren, worum es ihr eigentlich geht.
In den ersten aufgewühlten Tagen des Krieges stimmten viele in den Chor der Unterstützung ein.
Im Fernsehen sahen die Menschen in Europas Szenen, die sie nur aus Geschichtsführern kannten.
Auf Bahnhöfen kauernde Frauen und Kinder, über Felder rollende Panzer bombardierte Städte.
Und damals schien vieles klar.
Worte wurden rasch zu Taten. Mehr als 50 Nationen bildeten eine Koalition,
um die Ukraine militärisch und wirtschaftlich zu unterstützen.
Das Bündnis entstand mit beispielloser Geschwindigkeit. In Kiew,
Odessa und Kherson sah ich mit eigenen Augen die Wirkung der Lebensmittellieferung,
der Militärhilfe und der europäischen Unterstützung. Es schien wie ein Wunder.
Doch mit der Fortdauer des Krieges schlichen sich Zweifel ein.
Das ist auch nicht verwunderlich. Seit 2014 ist das Vertrauen in demokratische
Institutionen und Bündnisse dramatisch geschwunden, sowohl in Europa als auch
in den Vereinigten Staaten.
Vielleicht spielte unsere Gleichgültigkeit gegenüber der Besetzung der Ukraine
hierbei eine größere Rolle, als wir glaubten.
Sie berichtet, dass erst eine große Unterstützung da war.
Diese Unterstützung ist immer noch da, aber viele haben Zweifel und sagt dann,
das hat mit Desinformation und all dem zu tun.
Nee, das ist doch aufgrund der Tatsache, dass es da kein Vorankommen gibt in
der Ukraine. Es gibt keine großen Siege mehr zu verzeichnen auf ukrainischer Seite.
Man versucht dann mit ein paar anderen Strategien wie Kursk oder so noch ein
bisschen Land zu gewinnen, wo man es aber eigentlich gar nicht braucht.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass man sagen kann, der Krieg läuft super,
wären nur die Unterstützungen besser, sondern der Krieg läuft ja sehr schlecht.
Na gut, da kann sie natürlich sagen, weil wir zu wenig unterstützen,
Waffen liefern wir auch immer.
Ja, aber die Skepsis resultiert ja nicht aus irgendwelchen Fehlkampagnen oder
Desinformationen oder irgendetwas.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass im Kanzleramt die Leute desinformiert sind,
sondern man schätzt die Lage jetzt anders an.
Jetzt hören wir mal, worum es eigentlich geht.
Heute stehen wir vor der größten Herausforderung für unsere Werte und Interessen
zu unseren Lebzeiten und die demokratische Welt schwankt.
Viele wünschen sich, der Krieg möge auf magische Weise zu Ende gehen.
Andere sprechen lieber über den Nahen Osten, einen weiteren schrecklichen und
tragischen Konflikt, auf den wir Europäer jedoch weit weniger Einfluss haben
und in dem wir kaum etwas bewirken können.
Wieso haben wir da keinen Einfluss auf den Krieg in Nost?
Deutschland ist der zweitgrößte Waffenlieferant. Dann kommt schon bald Italien, USA.
Wieso sind da keine Einflüsse zu nehmen? Das wäre ja durchaus möglich.
Ich glaube nur, dass ein Appelbaum sich in diesem Kontext jetzt gerade nicht
traut zu sagen, was sie sonst sagen würde.
Nämlich, dass sie ja die Unterstützung jetzt für die israelische Regierung absolut richtig findet.
Sie ist ja keineswegs da auf dem Trip, dass sie sagt, ja, das darf so eigentlich
nicht weitergehen, sondern sie findet ja genau diese Haltung,
die da gerade angelegt wird, gut.
Also ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich finde mich in diesem Denken nicht zurecht.
Wir hören diesen Clip nochmal.
Heute stehen wir vor der größten Herausforderung für unsere Werte und Interessen
zu unseren Lebzeiten und die Demokraten.
Das ist doch eine interessante Sache. Sie spricht von den Werten und Interessen.
Und wir haben ja eigentlich immer, wenn man realistisch auf die Politik blickt,
festgestellt, es sind die Interessen, die das Handeln leiten.
Aber sie macht etwas ganz Wunderbares.
Sie sagt, die Werte und die Interessen sind eins.
Also in dem die Werte und die Interessen eins sind, ist eigentlich alles,
was wir tun, immer in unserem Interesse und es ist immer wertebasiert,
egal was wir tun. Denn Werte und Interessen sind eins.
Und diesen Zusammenschluss, den sie hier vornimmt,
der findet sich eigentlich in dieser ganzen Publizistik von Anne Applebaum,
dass sie immer sagt, ja wir sind die Verteidiger der Werte und zugleich aus Werte.
Glücklichem Zufall heraus, sind das auch immer genau unsere Interessen.
Also wir handeln moralisch und sind dabei auch noch die, die davon profitieren,
weil es auch noch unsere Interessen sind.
Also ich gratuliere sehr zu diesem Denken. Das macht vieles sehr viel einfacher.
Und schön, dass das hier in Frankfurt so abgefeiert wurde.
Die politische Welt schwankt. Viele wünschen sich, der Krieg möge auf magische Weise zu Ende gehen.
Andere sprechen lieber über den Nahen Osten, einen weiteren schrecklichen und
tragischen Konflikt, auf den wir Europäer jedoch weit weniger Einfluss haben
und in dem wir kaum etwas bewirken können.
Das bleibt sie einfach schuldig, warum wir da nichts bewirken können.
Wir können da ganz klar was bewirken, gerade weil wir so stark unterstützen.
Und zugleich frage ich mich, wer glaubt oder hofft, dass der Krieg auf magische Weise zu Ende geht?
Alle hoffen oder viele hoffen, dass der Krieg zu Ende geht.
Da gibt es unterschiedliche Ansätze, wie das gehen kann.
Und da sind manche auch für Gebietsabtritte. Und da gibt es im Übrigen ja jetzt
auch aus dem NATO-Lager Leute, die das so ähnlich formulieren.
Jemand wie Heusken hat das ja auch so formuliert, dass es wahrscheinlich wieder
auf so etwas Ähnliches wie Minsk herauslaufen soll, kann.
Jedenfalls ist doch hier nicht davon zu reden, dass das irgendwie auf magische Weise geschieht.
Also, da es im Rahmen der Buchmesse stattfand.
Und Fantasy wichtig ist.
Das auch. Hauptsache, das Buch hat ein schönes Relief draufgeteilt.
Muss man, glaube ich, deutlich sagen, diese Worte bedeuten hier nichts.
Werte, Interessen. Bei ihr ist doch wirklich klar, aus meiner Perspektive jedenfalls,
da gibt es klare politische Ziele und denen wird alles untergeordnet.
Geordnet, auch die Sprache.
Man kann sich nicht festnageln auf Werte.
Und dass hier Werte und Interessen einfach zusammenfallen, ist einfach dem Umstand
geschuldet, dass sie das Synonym verwendet, weil ihr das einfach egal ist.
Dass man das in der Buchmesse so duldet, finde ich nicht akzeptabel.
Eigentlich müsste man ja hier eine Sprachkritik vornehmen.
Ich habe mich dann nochmal erinnert an diese ganzen Debatten um den Friedenspreis,
zum Beispiel als Martin Walser für seine Paulskirchenrede da sehr gescholten wurde.
Er hat ja da von der Moralkeule Auschwitz gesprochen, viele weitere Formulierungen gemacht, wie er sagte,
ich beobachte mich dabei, wie ich wegblicke, wenn im Fernsehen noch einmal die
Bilder kommen vom Hologaust und dann hat man ja dort sehr massiv argumentiert
von allen Seiten, ja und wir wollen das hier nicht aufrollen nochmal,
worum es aber geht ist, man hat sich mit der Sprache beschäftigt.
Was macht Walser damit der Sprache?
Was will er damit eigentlich sagen oder so? Und hier hätte man ja zumindest
nach einer solchen Rede mal eine Sprachkritik vornehmen müssen.
Walser wollte seine Worte ja immer so aufladen, dass sie quasi ihn überdauern.
Also dass er einfach sterben kann und die Worte bleiben.
Ich glaube, das ist ein Beispiel dafür. Kann man jetzt inhaltlich ablehnen,
aber die Worte haben einfach einen Unterschied gemacht. Er hat sich die Worte ausgesucht.
Und dann kann man auch darüber diskutieren und dann kann man sagen,
was wird damit gemacht und worauf bezieht er sich hier und das kann man ja mit
einer solchen Rede natürlich auch machen, das wird aber nicht geleistet.
Und jetzt haben wir schon gesehen, sie bringt Werte und Interessen in eins und sagt jetzt folgendes.
Eine hobbsische Welt fordert unsere ganze Solidarität.
Wir haben hier über Mörschheimer gesprochen. Der sagte, ja, das ist eine hobbsische Welt.
Da stehen sich die Staaten als Gegner gegenüber.
Die mächtigsten Staaten sind die mächtigsten Staaten.
Und da gibt es auch keine übergeordnete Institution, die eine wirkliche Macht hat.
Anne Appelbaum sagt jetzt nicht dasselbe wie Mörschheimer.
Sie sagt, die anderen produzieren eine Hobbsche Welt.
Die Autokraten produzieren eine Hobbsche Welt. Wir nicht.
Wir folgen ja Moral und Interessen.
Wir haben einfach nur pro Nase
50 Sklaven auf der Welt und sagen Lieferkettengesetz, also das muss weg.
Ja, wir sind auf der Werteseite und produzieren keine Hobbsche Welt.
Aber da die anderen da sind und diese Welt produzieren, müssen wir jetzt doch
auch diese hopsche Logik anerkennen und kämpfen.
Aber mit Solidarität, ja.
Die Verleihung des Friedenspreises ist vielleicht ein guter Moment,
um darauf hinzuweisen, dass der Ruf nach Frieden nicht immer ein moralisches Argument ist.
Es ist auch ein guter Moment, um zu betonen, dass die Lektion der deutschen
Geschichte nicht sein kann, dass die deutschen Pazifisten sein müssen.
Ich meine, sie leitet das wirklich ein mit dem Friedenspreis.
Also, dass der Preis Frieden im Namen hat, ist ja ein guter Anlass,
darauf hinzuweisen, dass Frieden nun echt nicht der richtige ist.
Im Gegenteil, seit fast einem Jahrhundert wissen wir, dass der Ruf nach Pazifismus
angesichts einer aggressiven Diktatur oft nichts anderes ist als Beschwichtigungspolitik,
Appeasement und Hinnahme dieser Diktatur.
Das wissen wir jetzt, langer, langer Applaus, das wissen wir jetzt seit über
einem Jahrhundert und man fragt sich, was meint sie jetzt genau und wir ahnen
natürlich, was sie meint.
Sie meint den Zweiten Weltkrieg, meint die Appeasement-Politik,
meint den Vernichtungskrieg von Hitler gegen andere Bevölkerungen und gegen
die eigene Bevölkerung, meint den Holocaust. haust.
Sie bezieht sich interessanterweise nicht auf andere Kriege,
denn dann hätte sie ihre Schwierigkeiten.
Würde sie das jetzt über den Ersten Weltkrieg sagen oder über den Vietnamkrieg,
dann wird man wohl nicht sagen, naja und da hat man gesehen,
Pazifismus hilft nicht weiter, sondern sie kann nur diesen Krieg auswählen als das Beispiel dafür,
dass jetzt auch dieser Krieg der aktuellen in der Ukraine sein muss,
wie auch natürlich der Irakkrieg unbedingt sein muss.
Denn es war damals, du erinnerst dich glaube ich auch noch, eine ähnliche Argumentation,
dass man wirklich Leute in Talkshows sitzen hatte, die sagten,
ich weiß noch, wie die Amerikaner uns damals befreit haben und wie glücklich
wir waren, als wir Strumpfhosen bekamen.
Das muss jetzt auch im Irak stattfinden.
Wir hören jetzt eine Preisträgerin, die auch mal einen Literaten zitiert.
Ich bin nicht die Erste, die das sagt.
1938, Thomas Mann, entsetzt über die Situation in Deutschland und die Selbstgefeierlichkeit
der freiheitlichen Demokratien, prangerte aus dem Exil einen Pazifismus an,
der den Krieg herbeiführt, statt ihn zu verbannen.
Und George Orwell geißelte 1942 seine Landsleute, die von Großbritannien verlangten,
den Krieg zu beenden. Er sagte, Pazifismus ist objektiv pro-faschistisch.
Das ist ganz weitgehend unumstritten.
Wenn du die Kriegsanstrengung der einen Seite untergräbst, dann hilfst du automatisch der anderen.
Ja, so einfach scheint das zu sein. Aber wenn das wirklich so wäre,
also wenn es wirklich so wäre, dass jetzt gerade ein Hitler verhindert werden
muss, ein Vernichtungskrieg,
ein genozidaler Krieg, dann müsste man jetzt voll rein.
Also dann müsste man wirklich sagen, okay, dann ist jetzt dritter Weltkrieg oder was.
Was will sie uns sagen? Was hier stattfindet ist und was von all denen,
die die Ukraine unterstützen, gesagt wird, ist ja, wir brauchen mehr Waffen oder so etwas.
Aber es wird immer gesagt, die sollen das kämpfen oder vielleicht mal ein paar
NATO-Truppen noch rein.
Aber sie bringt ja hier ein Szenario, bei dem man sagen muss,
wenn das hier zutreffe auf die Gegenwart, dann wären wir in einer völlig anderen
Situation. Dann sitzen wir alle hier da und machen uns nur einen schlanken Fuß.
Und da ist das Interessante, dass sie das zwar aufruft und sagt,
hier muss jetzt gerade die große Befreiung erfolgen, in der Tat scheint sie
ja selbst nicht daran zu glauben, das würde sie ja ganz anderes fordern.
Es geht eigentlich nur darum, dass diejenigen, die jetzt eher eine pazifistische
Position vertreten oder für mehr Diplomatie einstehen oder sagen,
es muss einen anderen Weg geben, aus diesem Krieg zu kommen,
dass sie die disqualifiziert als jene, die wohl damals auch die Nazis hätten laufen lassen.
Und so kommt sie zu folgender Pointe.
Viele der Menschen in Deutschland und Europa, die angesichts der russischen
Angriffe Pazifismus verlangen, sind in der Tat objektiv pro-russisch,
um es mit Orwell zu sagen.
Also hier würde es mich freuen, wenn sich noch jemand die Mühe macht,
ausführlich ein Textstudium der angesprochenen Texte und ihrer Argumentation,
wer nicht vehement auch den Atomwaffeneinsatz fordert, spielt ja Putins Spiel,
also ist eigentlich ein Kombatant Putins.
Ich glaube, es wird nicht aufgehen. Ich glaube, hier ist ein literarischer Beweis,
den sie glaubt, führen zu können, der sie sich nicht führen lässt.
Der lässt sich auch nicht führen. Das ist auch eine völlig andere Situation
und ich empfehle vielleicht mal, wenn man diese Thomas Mann Zitate sehr gut
kennt, natürlich empfehle mal diesen Film zu sehen über Stefan Zweig vor der
Morgenröte von Maria Schrader,
der ja auch exzellierter dann ist und sich aber weigert sich derart politisch
jetzt einzumischen, weil er sagt, naja, ich bin hier nicht mehr drin in dem ganzen Gewusel.
Ich bin jetzt hier draußen, der eine sehr, sehr besonnene, wirklich intellektuelle
Position einnimmt, eigentlich eine interessantere Position als die von Thomas Mann.
Also wichtiger Film und auch sehr schöner Film vor der Morgenröte nochmal an
dieser Stelle empfohlen.
Und jetzt geht sie noch weiter.
Logisch zu Ende gedacht bedeutet Ihre Forderung, dass wir die Eroberung der
Ukraine, ihre kulturelle Zerstörung, die Erichtung von Konzentrationslanger
und die Entführung von Kindern aus der Ukraine akzeptieren sollten.
Sie bedeutet, dass wir die Gleichschaltung hinnehmen sollten.
Wir befinden uns im dritten Kriegsjahr.
Was hätte es Anfang 1942 bedeutet, Frieden zu fordern?
Also sie bringt jetzt die Konzentrationslager von 1942 zusammen mit das,
was sie glaubt, was entstehen wird, wenn Teile der Ukraine an Russland fallen.
Also ich will das hier nochmal deutlich betonen, das ist schlimm und das ist
auch nichts, worüber man sich freuen kann.
Nur ich glaube, dass dieser Vergleich nicht nur nicht gerechtfertigt ist,
sondern dass er ja auch wirklich die Geschichte relativiert in einem ungeheuren Maße.
Es ist so ein interessanter Trotz da drin, dass man so...
Keine Ahnung, ich kann mich noch selber noch erinnern, bei uns im Kindergarten
wurde damals immer gesagt, für dich heute kein Nachtisch.
Und da hat man gesagt, hat je keinen Hunger, bin eh schon satt, irgendwie sowas.
Und hier wird das aber nochmal gesteigert. Allein die Ankündigung,
du kriegst keinen Nachtisch, führt zu so einer ich will nicht mal Mittag essen Reaktion.
Und deswegen, weil sie dann auch keine Grundbegriffe hat, sondern einfach nur so Semantik.
Die man halt so illustrativ mitlaufen lässt.
Genau, wirft sie einfach alles rein. Ach, ihr wollt nur Helme schicken an Russland?
Ja, dann seid ihr. Und dann kommt sofort das Konzentrationslager,
das man dann mit unterstützt. Die Kinderentführung, die man duldet.
Also das sind ja eh diese ganz großen, schwierigen Fragen.
Die Soziologie hat ja irgendwann diesen Turn gemacht und hat gesagt,
vielleicht ist es nicht der Mensch, sondern das Soziale, dass der Mensch durchaus
als Wirt dieser Sozialität mitbedingt, aber es entsteht so etwas darüber.
So, und dann kamen so diese Handlungstheoretiker, die die ganze Zeit,
aber der Mensch muss doch handeln, handeln, handeln, ja, also so wie sie auch.
Und dann war irgendwann die Frage, ja, aber was ist eine menschliche Handlung? So.
Und spätestens in dem Moment, als es dann hieß, auch ein Nicht-Handeln kann
intentional erfolgen, also ein Phänomen,
das gar keine sichtbaren sozialen Effekte hat, wird plötzlich als Handlung tituliert,
um einfach zu sagen, das ist Unterlassen Hilfeleistung.
Und man kann sich da nicht rausreden mit, ich habe das nicht gesehen,
ich habe das alles eingeschätzt, ich hatte Angst oder was auch immer.
Es gilt alles nicht, sondern man sieht nur noch eine Handlung, die unterlassen wurde.
Also man hat nichts gesehen, aber eine Unterlassung. Eine Intention war da.
Und das kriegt man, das kennen wir, juristisch nicht aufgelöst.
Wenn wir es handfest machen wollen, müssen wir es juristisch auflösen.
Das ist ihr alles egal. Sie sieht jemanden nicht handeln und sagt sofort,
du hast quasi den Nagel mit eingeschlagen ans Tor von Auschwitz.
Du hast die Gleise dort mitgelegt.
Und diese Figur funktioniert nicht, weil sie zeigt nur den Trotz des Akteuren,
der sie ausspricht, aber niemand hat irgendeinen Anlass, das an sich ranzulassen.
Das macht gar keinen Sinn.
Also es ist eigentlich dafür, dass es so ein Friedenspreis Und ein Friedenspreis,
finde ich, ist immer so ein Versöhnungspreis, denn Frieden findet da statt,
wo vorher ja zwei Parteien aufeinander einschlugen.
Astrid Lindgren hat damals den Friedenspreis bekommen, so eine ganz berühmte
Rede gehalten über Gewalt.
Zum Beispiel solche Sachen. So und hier haben wir jemanden,
der mit ganz idiosynkratischer Sprache, also der einfach die Worte für sich selber auslegt,
nur als symbolische Illustration von irgendwas, sich an keiner Grundbegriffskonvention
orientiert und dann sind Werte und Interessen dasselbe und Konzentrationslager
sind quasi mitgebaut von den Leuten, die sich einfach nur sagen,
sorry Leute, aber ich könnte es mir nochmal kurz erklären, was hier passiert.
Nein, die Nachfrage ist nicht erlaubt. Du musst jetzt sofort die Atomwaffe fordern.
Ja, und Putin will ja auch nicht einen Holocaust veranstalten.
Das muss man auch mal ganz klar unterschreiben.
Wir können nicht zum einen, und das machen wir auch zu Recht,
irgendwelche palästinensischen Aktivisten dafür rügen, wenn sie von Gaza als
einem Konzentrationslager sprechen. Dann würde man auch sagen, nein, das ist es nicht.
Und hier kann man jetzt nicht einfach das mal so alles mit aufrufen, wie man es gerne hätte.
Genau, es gibt hier keine Grundbegriffe. Es ist alles nur Semantik,
die so dahin kommt. und es ist nicht versöhnungsstiftend.
Von Frieden ganz zu schweigen, aber das ist auch nicht versöhnlich oder so.
Das ist einfach nur dieser Trotz, dass ihr habt alle Unrecht.
Ich bin gegen euch alle. Ich bin eigentlich nur hier, um die Anklage nochmal
zu formulieren. Und es wird einfach dem Friedenspreis nicht gerecht.
Was will sie überhaupt, fragt man sich auch. Wie soll denn dieser Krieg ausgehen?
Wie sieht denn das aus? Sieht das so aus, dass die Krim zurückkommt an die Ukraine,
dass dann wieder die alten Grenzen da sind und diese akzeptiert man.
Man hat dann meinetwegen noch die Ukraine in die EU aufgenommen.
Nein, das ist für Eppelbaum noch alles nicht genug.
Schon früher bedrohten aggressive Diktaturen die freiheitlichen Gesellschaften Europas.
Schon früher haben wir gegen sie gekämpft.
Und diesmal ist Deutschland eine der freiheitlichen Gesellschaften und kann den Kampf mit anführen.
Wir können es nochmal tun. Um zu verhindern, dass Russland sein autokratisches
politisches System verbreitet, müssen wir der Ukraine zum Sieg verhelfen,
und zwar nicht nur für die Ukraine.
Wenn wir die Möglichkeit haben, mit einem militärischen Sieg diesen schrecklichen
Gewaltkult in Russland zu beenden, so wie ein militärischer Sieg den Gewaltkult
in Deutschland beendet hat, dann sollten wir sie nutzen.
Soll jetzt alles auf eine totale Kapitulation Russlands hinauslaufen,
dann sag doch gleich, wir brauchen einen dritten Weltkrieg.
Ja, das ist diese Ansage hier von
Herr Trump, möchten Sie die Demokratie abschaffen und ein Diktator sein?
Und dann sagt er, nein, das ist ja völlig falsch, ich will die Demokratie schützen
und so weiter, aber dafür ist es notwendig, dass ich am Tag eins mal kurz Diktator bin.
Ja, das ist doch unglaublich, dass sie jetzt davon ausgehen kann,
dass man Russland derart in die Knie zwingt, dass die so kapitulieren,
wie Deutschland es 1945 getan hat.
Ja, was beinhaltet, dass Putin in einem Bunker sich eine Kugel durch den Kopf schießt.
Und dass man Russland dann in Sektoren aufteilt. Für einen Sektor ist Frankreich
zuständig, für den anderen USA.
Und dann kommt erstmal eine Konferenz mit der Frage...
Wollen wir denen überhaupt wieder irgendwas Metallisches dalassen oder sollen
die einfach mit Holzspaten das Feld umgraben?
Und dann entscheidet man sich vielleicht dafür, dass man denen auch noch ein
bisschen Zivilisation zugesteht.
Das ist so die Lage, die sie jetzt fordert. Das ist wirklich sehr friedensstiftend.
Und ist auch so wahnsinnig realistisch, dass das so kommen wird.
Und realistisch.
Wir alle in der demokratischen Welt, nicht nur die Deutschen,
haben gelernt, unsere Politiker und unsere Gesellschaft kritisch und skeptisch zu sehen.
Und vielleicht stutzen wir, wenn wir nun aufgefordert werden,
unsere Grundprinzipien zu verteidigen. Aber bitte, hören Sie mich an.
Lassen Sie nicht zu, dass Skepsis zu Nihilismus wird. Der Rest der demokratischen Welt braucht sie.
In einer liberalen Demokratie darf man schon skeptisch gegenüber den Regierenden
sein, aber bitte nicht zu skeptisch.
Und wo das zu skeptisch beginnt, das wird dann von N. Applebaum und weiß ich nicht wem festgelegt.
Auch interessant.
Sie willst dir nicht diktieren, aber bitte, bitte, bitte.
Ja, aber das Liberale ist toll, hat aber ganz, ganz harte Grenzen. Der Schluss.
Im Kampf gegen die hässliche, aggressive Diktatur auf unserem Kontinent sind
unsere stärksten Waffen unsere Grundsätze, unsere Ideale und die Bündnisse,
die wir um sie herum aufgebaut haben.
Gegen das Wiedererstarken des Autoritarismus sind wir in der demokratischen
Welt natürliche Verbündete.
Daher müssen wir heute für unsere gemeinsame Überzeugung einstehen,
dass die Zukunft besser sein kann, dass wir diesen Krieg gewinnen können und
dass wir die Diktatur einmal mehr überwinden können.
Unsere gemeinsame Überzeugung, dass Freiheit möglich ist und dass wahrer Frieden möglich ist.
Auf diesem Kontinent und überall auf der Welt.
Ich danke Ihnen für diesen Preis und für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit.
Und überall auf der Welt. Also es wäre ja schön, das kann ich jetzt auch sagen,
ich hätte gerne überall auf der Welt Frieden und ich hätte gerne überall auf
der Welt Demokratien, vielleicht sogar liberale Demokratien.
Die Tatsache ist ja, dass,
Weniger als 30 Prozent der Weltbevölkerung in einer Demokratie lebt.
Und wenn man jetzt noch den Maßstab von Applebaum einer liberalen Demokratie
anlegt, dann werden es noch weniger sein.
Das heißt, die, die in nicht demokratischen Regierungen leben,
sind ganz klar in der Überzahl.
Wie soll das jetzt, jetzt kann man sagen, oh, das finde ich aber schade und
ich finde das auch schade. Aber wie soll das jetzt aussehen?
Sollte ich jetzt hinausgehen und versuchen gegen 70 Prozent der Weltbevölkerung
und deren Regierungen einen Krieg zu führen, bis ich die alle in die Demokratie
überführt habe und dann wird das, was sie da ausmalt am Ende ewiger Frieden sein?
Also wir brauchen erst noch einen ewigen Krieg, um dann zum ewigen Frieden zu
gelangen. Das ist doch absurd.
Ja.
Wir belasten es dabei. Man findet dafür keine Worte. Großer Applaus, Standing Ovations.
Ja, Standing Ovations.
Wer war nicht da? Frank-Walter Steinmeier war nicht da.
Der wollte sich wahrscheinlich nicht noch eine Stelle mitgeben oder wollte auch
nicht vielleicht mit dem polnischen Außenminister zusammentreffen,
der auch dort in Reihe 1 saß.
Und naja, sonst waren so die üblichen Kulturfunktionäre da, die man sich vorstellen kann.
Das ist nicht gut, sowas. Also von mir aus kann man sowas veranstalten,
aber dann bitte in Stuttgart.
Du willst es nicht vor der Haustür haben.
Wir haben die Automesse nach München abgegeben, Buchmesse kann nach Stuttgart, finde ich.
Das würde hier keiner vermissen. Gut, wir haben ein Thema und zwar eine Wahl in Amerika.
Ja.
Die wird typischerweise in Podcasts manchmal schon so als, ja es ist 50-50,
man muss es jetzt abwarten, keine Ahnung, lass uns nicht drüber reden oder so.
Aber du würdest jetzt doch noch gerne eine Prognose loswerden oder?
Nö, hast du eine?
Nein, ich habe keine Prognose, ich sehe jeden Tag neue Umfragen und mal ist
es so, mal anders. Was ich ganz interessant fand, war dieser Essay von Ezra
Klein, den hast du dir wahrscheinlich auch angehört.
Was ist falsch mit Trump? What's wrong with Trump?
Und das fand ich eine ganz interessante Beobachtung, weil ich mir erst dachte,
wie Ezra Klein kommt jetzt nach all den Jahren mit Trump auf die Idee nochmal
zu fragen, was stimmt eigentlich mit dem Kerl nicht? Das ist doch eine Million
Mal beantwortet worden.
Und der hat aber dann nochmal so einen interessanten Kniff dabei.
Er sagt, ja, wir wissen ja, Trump ist ein Narzisst und all das.
Aber wie ist das eigentlich mit dem Alter? Wir haben ja bei Biden über den quasi
senilen Biden so viel gesprochen, aber bei Trump ist das ja irgendwas anderes.
Also der ist ja nicht so alt, wie Biden alt ist. Ja. Und das könne man jetzt
bei Trump sehr gut sehen.
Und er hat sich dann bezogen zum Beispiel auf diesen Auftritt in Pennsylvania.
Er war dort eigentlich eingeladen, bei einer Rallye Fragen zu beantworten.
Dann gab es einen Notfall im Publikum, noch einen Notfall. Und dann hat Trump
gesagt, spielt mal Musik.
Und dann stand Trump 40 Minuten auf der Bühne und hat einfach seine Spotify-Karte.
Playlist abgespielt mit Time to Say Goodbye, Memories aus Cats, alles mögliche.
Er stand da, YMCA hat sich dazu dann ein bisschen bewegt und das war für Eswar Klein Grund zu sagen.
Es gibt so einen Kontrollverlust, also das, was er immer schon macht,
also dass er Dinge tat, die andere Leute in dem Zusammenhang nicht tun würden,
hat er ja immer schon getan und dafür wurde er auch gemocht.
Und inzwischen aber kennt er da gar keine Grenzen mehr und das zeige sich vor
allem daran, dass seine Rallye-Auftritte immer länger dauern.
Die waren bei seinem ersten Wahlkampf 45 Minuten durchschnittlich lang,
inzwischen ist er bei über 80 Minuten.
Das heißt, er redet immer weiter, immer weiter, steht da, geht nicht mehr von
der Bühne runter, er kennt da keine Grenzen mehr und dann werden andere Dinge
vorgespielt und dann dachte ich, ja, das ist es, das heißt aber noch nicht,
dass das völlig unerfolgreich ist.
Und als ich diesen Auftritt in Pennsylvania sah, musste ich an etwas denken,
das muss ich kurz sagen, wir hatten doch Auftritte, Ole und ich zusammen mit
Jean-Philipp Kindler und haben ja am Ende immer ein bisschen Spaß muss sein gesungen.
Und kurz nach diesen auftritten hatten ole
und ich die einladung nach salzburg zu einer pädagogischen fachtagung
zum thema social media und influenza und wir waren dann dort in salzburg und
ole zeigte mir kurz vor dem vortrag dann nochmal die präsentation welche statistiken
wir zeigen welche clips und dann schaute ich ihn an sagt ja aber da fehlt ja
das karaoke und für zwei sekunden,
Ole mich angeblickt und hat gedacht, meint er das jetzt wirklich ernst?
Also meint er jetzt, wir sehen ein bisschen Spaß zu sein. Es hätte natürlich
überhaupt nicht gepasst und es wäre vollkommen verrückt gewesen,
wenn wir sowas gemacht hätten, bei einer akademischen Tagung sowas zu liefern.
Und genau das ist es aber, was Trump macht, zu sagen, ich habe da jetzt Lust
drauf, ich mache das jetzt.
Und ich glaube, dass das so etwas ist, was für alle normalen Leute,
die sich das nicht trauen können, aufgrund von eigener Moral,
aufgrund von Konventionen aller Arten, aufgrund von wirtschaftlicher Abhängigkeit
zum Beispiel, dass man sich in einem Unternehmen nicht benehmen kann, wie man will.
Die haben aber in Trump jemand, der macht das für die.
Der ist für die anderen Leute enthemmt. Ich kann nicht aus meiner Haut raus,
wenn Udo Jürgens singt, einmal verrückt sein und aus allen Zwängen fliehen.
Das können wir fast alle nicht. Wir sind da gebunden, wir müssen uns benehmen,
können nicht anfangen zu singen, zu machen, zu tanzen.
Trump sagt, ich habe jetzt Lust zu tanzen, spiel noch mal YMCA und dann wird es gemacht.
Und ich glaube, dieser Effekt ist bei allem, was man jetzt über diese sehr desaströsen
Auftritte zum Teil sagen kann von Trump, immer noch da und funktioniert so wahnsinnig gut.
Während er sich ja sonst auch gar keine große Mühe mehr gibt.
Weder rhetorisch, noch sind die Jokes so wahnsinnig gut vorbereitet.
Er liefert nicht mehr die Megashow eigentlich ab, er gefällt sich auch zu sehr
einfach nur auf der Bühne zu stehen, ist zu langsam,
aber dieser Effekt hier macht einfach jemand was er will und das würde ich auch
mal gerne machen, kann ich aber nicht, das scheint immer noch da zu sein und
scheint zu funktionieren.
Ja, das ist vor allem eine sehr schöne Klammer für das, was wir jetzt besprechen,
denn ich finde schon aus diesen Gründen, die du jetzt genannt hast,
man muss genau sagen, warum man jetzt über die amerikanische Wahl spricht.
Denn einfach nur so mitlaufen zu lassen, dass da eventuell so Phänomene greifen
wie, jemand sieht einfach gerne jemanden auf der Bühne und dann ist es halt
jemanden, den man einfach so mag und wir wissen genau, wie Comedy funktioniert.
Es gibt ja nur einen, der noch langsamer ist auf der Bühne als Donald Trump
und das ist, finde ich, Felix Lobrecht.
Ach ja?
Der sich ewig lange Zeit lässt, irgendetwas, weil er nämlich schon weiß,
was damals diesen Fernsehleuten da gesagt wurde. Inhalte?
Es geht nicht um Inhalte. Man will auf der Bühne jemanden sehen,
den man wiedererkennt, mit dem man sympathisiert und der einen vielleicht so
ein bisschen repräsentiert.
Ist aber nicht so zwingend. Also du hast es jetzt sehr betont,
ich würde sagen, es muss jetzt nicht so zwingend der eigene Wunsch sein,
aber dass mal jemand sich das traut, wäre so schön, damit ich mich zurücklegen kann, so ungefähr.
Jeder wird mal irgendwo bei einem langweiligen Vortrag, bei einem Konzert,
irgendwo wo es still war, gesessen haben
und gedacht haben, was wäre jetzt eigentlich, wenn ich laut loslache.
Und Trump ist derjenige, der einfach dann laut loslacht.
Genau. Und dann gibt es aber ein großes Problem, denn diese kleinen,
man nennt sie Krisenexperimente, also jemand legt sich einfach mal so auf die
Straße und dann laufen so Leute hin und fragen dann, alles okay und so.
Und dann ist die Antwort, nee, ich studiere Psychologie, ich wollte nur gucken,
wie lange es dauert, bis jemand fragt, ist alles okay.
Und in Japan kannst du halt unendlich lange liegen, da interessiert es niemanden, das gucken alle weg.
Und in Deutschland würde ich sagen so zwei Minuten, sagen wir mal so 17 Leute
laufen vorbei, der 18. sagt dann was.
Nun ist es so, für das eine, ich habe es ja vorhin schon aufgemacht,
die unmittelbare Lebensfeld, wo der Körperbezug und die Raumgebundenheit eine
Rolle spielt, wo man sich ohne Medienvermitteln einfach durch Zurufen hört und so.
Sagen wir mal so, im Größenordnung Opernsaal. Ja.
Einer singt für tausend Leute, aber nicht für 20.000 Leute. Also irgendwann
hört es auf, irgendwann kommt eine Medienvermittlung dazu.
Was auch bedeutet, irgendwann kommen grundsätzlich Medien dazu.
Es muss nicht das elektronische Medium sein, sondern es kann auch das Geld, die Macht und so weiter.
Da sind wir in der politischen Sphäre. Was bedeutet, wir treffen eine Wahlentscheidung vor Ort.
Auch in Amerika werden 98% der Stimmen auf Papier abgegeben.
Die Leute müssen zu diesem Papier hingehen. Sie können das auch als Brief schreiben, okay.
Aber Politik ist extrem raumgebunden. Also eine Rallye mit 29.000 Leuten ist schon viel.
Der Madison Square Garden hat 19.000 Sitzplätze, das ist schon viel.
So ein Stadion, Kamala Harris macht das auch nur so alle zwei Wochen mal,
so richtig im Stadion. Also wo man schon so eine Leinwand braucht, um diejenigen zu sehen.
Und wir haben jetzt eine Übertragungsleistung zu machen, wenn jemand in diesem
Raum gebunden, also man sieht ihn einfach und ist so fasziniert,
aus welchen Gründen auch immer, kann man das einfach politisch übertragen.
Also nur weil der eine so gut da funktioniert, am Tisch Witze macht,
kann man ihm gleichzeitig, ja dann regier doch Amerika.
Also dieser Kurzschluss, der gerade so selbstverständlich mitläuft,
der ist ja eigentlich völlig bescheuert.
Ja, völlig.
Denn nicht nur wollen wir nicht diese ganze Verantwortung einer Person übertragen
und dann auch noch der Falschen oder der Richtigen. Also alle diskutieren gerade,
ist es die Falsche, ist es die Richtige?
Und gestern in der New York Times wurde ein kurzer Hinweis gegeben im Podcast
von dem Typ, der jetzt The Run-Up macht, dem Podcast, den Michael Barbaro vor
acht Jahren gemacht hat, aus dem dann jetzt The Daily entstanden ist.
Und meinte kurz, das Problem ist, die Demokraten reden ganz viel über das demokratische
System, aber nur über, wie Donald Trump es auslegt.
Und nicht, wie man es eigentlich mal auslegen müsste, mit Verstand,
Vernunft. Sie sagen immer, der ist unvernünftig, der hat keinen Verstand, der ist irre.
Kamala Harris wurde ja gefragt, was wäre mit Ihnen anders und sie konnte nur
sagen, dass sie nicht Trump ist.
Sie war ja in Late Night Shows unterwegs und wurde immer wieder das gefragt.
Genau, diesen Clip spielt ja Trump sogar auf der Bühne. Ich habe die Aurora-Rede
heute Morgen nochmal gehört, wo er dann wirklich den Clip spielt,
wie sie gefragt wird, wie unterscheiden sie sich von Biden und dann sagt sie,
da kommt ihr gerade nichts in den Kopf. Nothing comes to mind.
Das ist ihr Zitat dazu. Und das breiten die natürlich aus, so im Sinne von,
seht ihr, wir sind der Kandidat für Change, Hope and Change ist jetzt Trump
und damit haben wir auch was im Angebot und die andere Seite aber nichts,
außer es geht weiter wie bisher und wie ihr es bisher findet, ist ja blöd.
Also es gibt gar kein Angebot, es anders zu machen, sondern man unterscheidet
sich einfach nur so von Trump.
Und wir werden aber jetzt….
Lass mich noch eine Frage davor stellen, bevor wir zu deinen Clips kommen.
Wie haben dir diese Bilder, die Ausschnitte gefallen von Trump bei McDonald's?
Das ist genau der Punkt. Also diese Klammer wollte ich gerade machen.
Jetzt nicht am McDonald's Beispiel, aber das ist auch genau richtig.
Für mich sind die wahlentscheidenden Clips vor ungefähr zwei Monaten entstanden, als J.D.
Vance und Tim Walz die Bühne betraten und jeder für sich einfach zum Bäcker
ging, um dort Donuts oder halt Zeug zu kaufen.
Und ich glaube, das haben alle vor Augen. Also J.D. Vance fällt nichts ein,
außer den Leuten da immer nur zu fragen, wie lange arbeiten Sie schon hier?
Wie lange arbeiten Sie schon hier?
Ah, zwei Jahre, ja. Wie lange arbeiten Sie schon hier? Ah, sieben Monate,
okay. Also es war sozusagen kein Gesprächsanlass und es war einfach nur so,
ich muss jetzt irgendwas fragen und die total eingeschüchtert, sieben Monate.
Und sein Bestellvorgang war ja dann einfach, ich hätte gerne diesen Donut,
diesen Donut, diesen Donut.
Naja, und dann was halt so Sinn ergibt. So, what makes sense?
Einfach, gib mir ein Donut zu. Ich bin hier, um Donuts zu kaufen.
So wie halt so ein Billionär, ja, einfach sagt, George, ich brauche Donuts.
Und dann kommt aber nicht die Frage, Schoko oder Dings, sondern es werden ihm
alle hingelegt und er greift dann einfach dazu.
Also, Donuts. Während ja Waltz einfach in diesen Laden ging und meinte,
ja, wir sind hier gerade vorbei, wir haben heute Abend hier einen Auftritt,
ihr könnt ja alle kommen und so, wir haben Hunger.
Und dann ist die Frage, ja, was wollt ihr denn essen? Das sieht gut aus. Was ist das?
Ah, mit dieser Butter hier aus dem Ort und so weiter und so fort.
Also wird so eine Connection hergestellt. Und die Leute treffen eine politische Wahlentscheidung.
Und ich nenne jetzt ein Wort, von dem ich weiß, es werden die Hörer nicht akzeptieren.
Aber es ist absolut, ich sage es vorab, absolut richtig. Es muss so beobachtet werden.
Niklas Luhmann hat gesagt, die Wahlentscheidung ist motivlos. Sie folgt keinem Motiv.
Ein Wahlkämpfer, der sich mit Inhalten beschäftigt,
Also Motive anbietet, wähl mich doch aus diesem oder jenem Grund, begeht einen Fehler.
Man wählt jemanden, dem man dieses elterliche Urvertrauen.
Es gibt einen sehr berühmten, lass mich das noch kurz sagen,
Clip, der gerade auch gelöscht wurde von Elon Musk auf Twitter.
Ich habe ihn heute Morgen retweetet, kann jeder nochmal nachschauen.
Des Szenarios wie folgt. Ein dunkles Flugzeug wackelt.
Es sieht irgendwie gefährlich aus, bedrohlich. Und von hinten wird so gefilmt
und man hört immer so Leute aufschreien.
Und die Cockpit-Ansage ist Donald Trump, der einfach sagt, ja,
wir versuchen jetzt hier mal zu landen.
Hier sind ganz wunderbare Lichter. Das sind die schönsten Lichter im Cockpit,
die ich je gesehen habe. Es blinkt überall bunt.
Beautiful lights.
Genau. Ich werde mal versuchen, was passiert, wenn ich hier drücke und so.
Und das ist die Wahlentscheidung.
Es ist nicht, ach ja, das ist aber wunderschön im Programm, da freue ich mich
sehr, wenn sie dann in zwei Jahren das Kindergeld in Amerika einführen,
sondern egal was passiert,
Xi könnte ausrasten oder Netanyahu, wenn er sieht, warte mal,
ich kriege jetzt nicht meinen Trump, ja dann lege ich jetzt alles in Schutt und Asche und so weiter.
Egal was passiert, wir wissen noch, wie das in Deutschland war,
Koalitionsvertrag, Fortschrittskoalition, Selfie, alle drei wollen irgendwas
und dann Mist, Putin hat eigentlich die Agenda bestimmt, ja,
konnte ja keiner wissen, es ist ein Krieg passiert.
So, ich werde es auch im Buch ausführlich argumentieren, es ist dieses elterliche Urvertrauen.
Ja, es ist ja sogar wissenschaftlich in der Form belegt, dass man Amerikaner
fragt nach ihrer wirtschaftlichen Situation vor der Wahl und wenn dann ihr Kandidat gewonnen hat,
dann ist ihre wirtschaftliche Situation natürlich kein Deut besser geworden,
wir haben kein Geld mehr.
Aber sie sagen, am Tag nach der Wahl, dass es ihnen wirtschaftlich jetzt besser
geht, obwohl sich auf ihrem Konto nichts verändert hat.
Und das ist da ganz deutlich zu sehen und deswegen ist dieser Trump-Auftritt
bei McDonalds so genial, denn da funktioniert das.
Und ich muss sagen, ich habe jetzt diesen sehr guten Film The Apprentice gesehen,
den ich empfehle über Donald Trump und habe danach dann wieder Trump bei McDonalds
gesehen und muss wirklich sagen, es hat mir derart gefallen,
dass ich dachte, verdammt nochmal, wenn das kein rechter Idiot wäre,
wenn das jetzt wirklich ein Linker wäre, wie genial wäre das. Ja.
Absolut. Also die Wahlentscheidung der Amerikaner wird danach auslaufen,
von wem würden sie gerne bei McDonalds,
da wo sie täglich hingehen oder wöchentlich, wer soll da stehen?
Das übersteigt aber diesen Horizont nicht. Es übersteigt diese unmittelbare Lebenswelt nicht.
Man will jemanden wählen, mit dem man sich wohl fühlt. Jetzt haben die einen
total Angst vor Trump im Cockpit und die anderen sagen,
ja klar Trump, hast du gesehen, wie der bei McDonalds so, ja, also ich will doch,
dass er am Fenster steht und mir noch einmal erklärt, das ist ganz toll,
die Pommes wurden nicht von einer Hand berührt, die kommen aus der Maschine und so, ja,
und dann machen sich alle lustig und sagen, ja, natürlich kommt das aus der
Maschine und niemand berührt, das soll jetzt jeder jede Pommes erstmal anfassen
oder was, also so völlig sinnlose Fragen, aber die politische Wahl erfolgt motivlos,
nur sie hat halt trotzdem Resultate.
Es passt ja auch dazu, so gut, was du jetzt sagst mit dem Motivlosen,
dass es war klein, mit seiner Kollegin Habermann sprach.
Maggie Habermann, ja.
Ja, und Maggie Habermann sagt, dann angesprochen auf die Lügen von Trump,
naja, also es gibt einmal die offensichtlichen Lügen von Trump,
er belügt, um weiterzukommen.
Dann gibt es die Lügen, die er glaubt und dann gibt es noch die Lügen,
bei denen man nicht so genau sagen kann, glaubt er sie, ist das nur strategisch,
irgendein Mischmasch. Und dann gibt es aber noch die Trump-Lügen.
Er sagt einfach etwas, weil er es gerne sagt. Er war der Beste in der Klasse.
Das ist die schlimmste Inflation, die wir jemals hatten. Sie ist die wichtigste Sportlerin.
Sie hat damals das beste Zeugnis bekommen, wenn er irgendwas über seine Mutter oder so erzählt.
Es stimmt alles nicht, aber er sagt gerne der Beste, der Größte oder der Erste in der Klasse.
Und deswegen sagt er es. Er sagt es, weil er es gerne sagt.
Und das zeigt das nochmal so
deutlich, dass da auch bei ihm ein motivloses Sprechen eigentlich da ist.
Danny hat mir jetzt bei der Subscribe seinen GPT-Hack erklärt.
Er macht GPT für sich extrem effizient, indem er GPT einfach verbietet, Adjektive zu benutzen.
Bewerte mir nichts, stell mir nichts dar, verkaufe mir nichts.
Erklär mir einfach nur in Substantiven, was hier Sache ist.
Und das ist ja bei Trump auch. Also dieses Gespräch mit Joe Rogan,
in das wir gleich auch so ein bisschen reinhören, das geht drei Stunden.
Aber das hättest du alleine auf eine Stunde runterkürzen können durch,
Donald Trump nennt einfach den Namen seines Onkel.
Nein, das reicht ihm nicht. Er muss nochmal sagen, er war Professor,
er war Professor am MIT, er war dort der am längsten mit Professur,
Lehrstuhl ausgestattete Professor und so weiter.
Und nichts davon stimmt halt so, ich weiß nicht, ob er als MIT-Professor war.
MIT stimmt dann noch, aber dass er der allerbeste war oder die meisten Preise
bekommen hat, sagt das einfach gerne. Noch ein Punkt zu diesem motivlosen Sprechen.
Wir können das übrigens bei beiden Kandidaten sehen, sowohl bei Trump als auch bei Kamala Harris.
Sie wiederholen das, was sie sagen laufend. Sie sagen Sätze nicht nur zweimal, sondern dreimal.
Sie sagen es dreimal. He is weird. Und sie sagen, dass bei diesen Auftritten,
das ist interessant, also die meisten reden, glaube ich, von denen kann man
wirklich auf ein DIN A4 Blatt pressen, wenn man die Wiederholungen rausnimmt.
Es ist ein ganz interessantes Phänomen, dass umso größer das Publikum ist,
umso kleiner ist die Bandbreite.
Also du musst, auch bei Taylor Swift, Taylor Swift kann nur drei Stunden in
einem jubelnden Stadion spielen, wenn sie keine unerwartete Note spielt.
Der Text muss komplett vorher bekannt sein, nur noch die Reihenfolge der Lieder, nicht so abgewandelt.
Ansonsten geht das nicht. Irgendwie so Jazz, der so aus dem Ärmel geschüttelt
wird, kannst du vor 20 Leuten spielen.
Aber dann kriegst du kein Stadion gefüllt. Und so ist das in der Politik auch.
Du hast eine Sehgewohnheit und dann gehst du da hin und dann willst du es haben.
Und wenn dann halt acht Stunden Madison Square Garden gefüllt werden muss mit
sechs Stunden Programm, das vorher begutachtet, aber nicht bekannt ist,
passieren die größten Wahlkampffehler.
Wie die Familienmitglieder von 400.000 Wählern in Pennsylvania,
die gerade umkämpft werden, als Garbage dargestellt werden.
Die gehen auf Nummer sicher. Die machen ihre Rede.
Trump braucht halt länger, aber da kommt ja nicht mehr bei rum,
sondern es geht am Ende um fünf, sechs Sätze, die halt wiederholt werden.
Aber, und das müssen wir jetzt klar markieren, es gibt die Kandidaten und dann
unterstellt sich ja jedes Lager gegenseitig, dass hinter dem Kandidaten eine Maschine arbeitet.
Und die nennen das auch richtig Machine.
Die Dämm-Machine und die republikanische Maschine. Wir gucken uns jetzt die
republikanische Maschine an, denn wir haben ja schon eine besondere Eigenschaft
von Milliardären und Superreichen benannt.
Sie verfügen über unendliche Kohle und Cashflow aus Entitäten,
von denen sie nicht abgewählt werden können.
Es ist also egal, wer nächste Woche gewinnt.
Elon Musk bleibt Elon Musk.
Er bleibt der reichste Mann der Welt.
Mit genau dem Vermögen, mit genau der Apparatur, die ihm zur Verfügung steht,
mit den gleichen Verträgen mit der Regierung, mit dem gleichen Anspruch,
ich versorge hier Taiwan mit Internet, wenn es hart auf hart kommt oder nicht.
Das wird alles nicht nächste Woche entschieden. Nächste Woche wird einfach nur
entschieden, ist es jetzt, also welche Wahlkampftaktik hat sich durchgesetzt.
Aber der Hintergrund ist ja doch nicht so richtig bekannt und den schauen wir
uns aber mal an. Also wir gucken jetzt auf die Konstante, die je nach Wahlausgang
etwas mehr Oberwasser hat oder nicht.
Es kommt ja dann auch darauf an, wie jetzt der Senat und das Repräsentantenhaus
bestellt ist, ob dann das sozusagen sofort Traktion bekommt oder nicht.
Aber was da geplant ist und was sich zur Not nochmal die nächsten zehn Jahre
neuen Kandidaten sucht, aber was sozusagen immer droht, das schauen wir uns
jetzt an und zwar in drei Aspekten.
Zum einen Konstitution Amerika selbst, Bürokratie, Regulierung, was auch immer.
Dann Zölle und Krieg, also jenseits Amerikas Verhältnis zum Ausland.
Und dann Umgang mit der Hälfte der Bevölkerung, nämlich denjenigen,
die für Nachschub sorgen können.
Das ist ja ein großes Problem in Amerika, wir wundern uns auch,
warum ist Abtreibung da so ein Riesenthema?
Die sachliche Grundlage dieser Fragestellung ist einfach, noch ist das Silicon
Valley nicht so weit, noch müssen Kinder von Frauen geboren werden,
Männer schaffen es nicht alleine.
Sie konnten sich die ganze Welt unterwerfen, aber für das Aufstellen einer Armee,
für das Aufstellen von Industriearbeitern brauchen sie Frauen.
Und jetzt gibt es überall zu wenig Kinder, sagen selbst die Amerikaner,
also gibt es da einen politischen Ansatz, der dann verfolgt wird.
Naja, wir haben das ja eigentlich, das zieht sich ja durch diesen Podcast hindurch,
dieser Kampf um Menschenmaterial.
Wir haben zu weinen, Hightech und all das, aber der Mensch.
Nur eine Zahl noch, bevor du zu deinen Clips kommst. dpa, die ukrainischen Streitkräfte
planen, die Mobilisierung von 160.000 Soldaten,
das gab der Sekretär des Nationalen Sicherheits Verteidigungsrates am Dienstag
im Parlament in Kiew bekannt.
Aus Sicherheitskreisen ließe ergänzen, dass diese Mobilisierung innerhalb von
drei Monaten stattfinden sollte.
Also wieder ein Kampf um Männer, 160.000 sollen jetzt motiviert werden,
in Anführungszeichen, sondern also immer mehr mit Druck dazu gebracht werden.
Das ist ein halbes Prozent der Bevölkerung. Was bedeutet, ein Straßenzug mit
40 Hausnummern sind 200 Leute?
Davon wird jetzt einer mitgenommen in den nächsten drei Monaten,
um das zu machen, was er wirklich nicht machen will, jemanden anders töten oder selber getötet werden.
Gut, also fangen wir mit dem, finde ich, wirkmächtigsten, also da wo die Amerikaner
selbst, wenn die Republikaner dieses Weiße Haus übernehmen, am wirkmächtigen
sein können und das ist der Umgang mit Bürokratie.
Denn wir wissen ja, die Superreichen, ist ja in Deutschland auch die Schuldenbremsendiskussion,
Schuldenbremse lockern heißt mehr Staat, mehr öffentliche Investitionen als
Konkurrenz zu privaten Investitionen.
Was bedeutet, wenn jemand anders, außer private Investoren Häuser bauen zum
Beispiel, zum Verkaufen und Vermieten, dann kriegt auch jemand anders diese Rendite.
Und die Renditen sind aber hoch und umso höher, je knapper der Markt ist.
Also haben sozusagen, sagen wir mal, 75 Millionen Menschen ein Problem damit,
wenn nur 180.000 statt 400.000 Wohnungen gebaut werden, aber so 5 Millionen
Leute haben halt gar kein Problem damit. Nein. Sondern die macht das superreich.
Also die werden von reich zu superreich dadurch.
Und jetzt ist ja Elon Musk sozusagen der CEO der Superreichen.
Ich habe jetzt schon vernommen, dass irgendwelche anderen Superreichen sagen,
ja ich bin superreich, aber ich bin anders als Elon Musk und ich sage, nein.
Also ihr seid alle wie Elon Musk. Es ist nur eine Performance,
die da nochmal hervorsteht, aber ansonsten ihr seid alle wie Elon Musk.
Also niemand, der ein Milliardenvermögen hat, soll hier mir irgendwie erklären,
dass er anders ist als Elon Musk. Das stimmt nämlich einfach nicht.
Elon Musk traut sich nur ein bisschen mehr Konfetti zu auf der Bühne.
Die These aufstellen, man ist vielleicht sogar effektiver, wenn man nicht wie
Elon Musk auftritt als Milliardär.
Ja, genau.
Wir haben ja erfahren, wie schafft man es, dass Betriebsvermögen nicht verfeuert werden.
Naja, man trifft sich klandestin und das lese ich dann acht Jahre später in
einem Buch. Und man läuft nicht auf Bühnen rum mit Konfetti und sagt,
ich will keine Steuer zahlen.
Also in Deutschland muss man sagen, es findet gerade keine Milliardärsshow statt, stimmt.
Aber dafür sehen wir halt, dass jetzt plötzlich das Management gegen die Mitarbeiter kämpft bei VW.
Was ist eigentlich mit dem Milliardär im Hintergrund so?
Wird einfach ausgeblendet. Gut, also, Elon Musk ist bei Tucker Carlson zu Gast.
In einer Sendung, in der sie wie in der Matrix, wenn Neo plötzlich...
Ins Jenseitige geht.
Die Wüste des Realen.
Naja, du kennst doch die Situation, dass sie in dieser Matrix sind.
Und dann ist alles ganz weiß.
Genau, erstmal alles nur ganz weiß.
Das ist die Wüste des Realen.
Die Wüste des Realen, genau. Da befinden sie sich und sie reden über die Milliardärselite der anderen.
Naja, es gibt ja die Cathedral und sowas.
Genau, es gibt auch das Glashaus und die Steine.
Und den Elfenbeinturm, ja.
Also wir hören hier mal, Elon Musk, der reichste Mensch der Welt.
Und das ist ja jetzt auch gleichzeitig Ulf Poschert, der ja das einfach überträgt ins Deutsche.
Also ich meine, über Ulf Poschert könnte man nochmal ein richtiges Literaturstudium machen.
Die Texte, die zuletzt liefen, wem er zu Avantgarde erklärt und so,
sind ja wirklich Hanebüchen. Also man glaubt es ja einfach nicht mehr.
Ich finde aber toll, wenn diese Weltjournalisten oder hauptsächlich die Springer-Journalisten
dieses Unternehmertum immer so feiern und ich denke immer, aber ihr wart noch
nie selbstständig, ihr seid einfach seit Jahrzehnten angestellt und hofft,
dass Friede Springer euch gewogen bleibt.
Ja, genau, das ist das Einzige, was euer Schicksal entscheidet.
Ihr seid wie verbeamtet seid ihr da.
Genau, abgefeiert wird die ganze Zeit die große Freiheit. Also, rein ins Gespräch.
Die Dem Party elite just decides who is in charge.
That's a tiny oligarchy, basically.
Comprised of the richest people in the country. That's kind of the interesting
part to me, is that the richest people in the country are on board with this.
I mean, that's what it is. It's a collection of billionaires.
Well, most of them are, yeah. But you're not. Not me.
Not everyone is. Ich denke, es ist ein Schocken, dass die Billionärer in den Dem camp sind.
Mehr als in den Republican camp. Oh, für sicher. Das ist wild.
Ja. Wer hat die meisten Milliardäre?
Aber ich meine, wenn wir uns jetzt über Milliardäre aufregen,
okay, wir wissen, es führt eh zu nichts.
Ja.
Es ist so ein bisschen...
Aber der reichste Mensch der Welt kommt jetzt mit den gleichen Argumenten wie
wir und sagt, nee, da bestimmen einfach reiche Milliardäre in so einem oligarchischen
Club-System, was passiert.
Also ich verstehe das nicht so ganz.
Wie es passieren kann.
Dass es so geschieht als Gespräch.
Um so viel Eigenwerbung zu machen, ich empfehle meine Filmanalyse zu The Apprentice,
aber genauso sehr empfehle ich wirklich den Film sich anzusehen.
Das spielt ja in den 70er, 80er Jahren.
Trump ist dort, muss sich von seinem Vater absetzen, will diese großen Hotelkomplexe
errichten, findet dann mit Ray Cohn diesen Anwalt, der ihn dort aus allem freiboxet.
Und vor allem sieht Trump, wie er nicht akzeptiert wird von der New Yorker Society,
denn das ist eine Elite wiederum für sich und er gehört nicht dazu,
er ist quasi der Outlaw, aber er will es denen allen zeigen.
Und wir haben bei Elon Musk auch dieses Bedürfnis zu sagen, ja,
ich bin aber trotzdem noch der Outlaw.
Und mir ist das aufgefallen, wenn ich solche Lifestyle-Podcasts höre mit irgendwelchen
Millionären, die eine Modemark oder so gelauncht haben, dass die ganz häufig
diese Idee haben, dass sie eigentlich die Underdogs sind.
Und das stimmt insofern, als vorher auch schon Leute da waren,
die Geld waren und vielleicht immer gesagt haben, wer bist denn du,
interessiert mich nicht, was du machst.
Und das sind natürlich Erlebnisse, die Donald Trump zuhauf hatte.
Der gehörte nicht dazu, der hat auch nicht das Dings Distinguierte,
das man braucht wie den New Yorker Society, der kann sich nicht über Opern mit denen unterhalten.
Die Elite hat aber ein MET-Abo und deshalb erfährt er sich als derjenige,
der der große Rebell ist und der sich eigentlich nicht vom Working Class Man unterscheidet,
der draußen auch mit der Mistgabel steht und sagt, lasst mich hier rein, ihr Superreichen.
Also es ist ganz skurril, das zu sehen. Aber der reichste Mann in der Welt ist
ein Underdog und er fühlt sich fremden Kräften ausgesetzt.
Zum einen dann, sagen wir mal, diese New Yorker Elite, also die demokratische
Elite, der sich Donald Trump auch gegenüber sieht. Also hier werden die reingeschlossen.
Aber auch, und das ist jetzt hier der Punkt, wir haben uns warm gehört,
dem Staat. Wir haben ja schon die Deep State Diskussion gehört.
Donald Trump hätte ja gerne das Land entfesselt, aber dann kam der Deep State,
hat ihn zurückgerissen.
Für jemanden wie Elon Musk ist das natürlich noch viel einfacher zu formulieren.
Im Wege zum großen Erfolge für das ganze Land, nicht nur für sich selber,
stehen einfach diese Regulierungen.
Ich denke, wir müssen sensibleren Deregulationen, wo wir die Regulations-Deregulationen,
wie wir nicht wollen, die wichtigsten Habitats zu verändern.
Ich kann es nicht nur sagen, ob es oil spills oder so. Aber es gibt so viele
Regulatory-Agencies mit dem Überlappenden Verantwortlichen, dass wir die Progresse schlussieren.
So, für den Fortschritt sollte bitte das Land zum Ausverkauf freigegeben werden.
Es heißt ja nicht gleich, dass wir überall hier Öl vergießen und so,
aber die eine oder andere Regulierung steht doch allem im Weg.
Und damit sind vor allem natürlich diese Umweltregulierung, also welche Ressourcen
darf ich nutzen und was darf ich beschmutzen im Weg.
Und während man das hört, denkt man sich so, sorry, aber du startest gerade
jeden Tag eine, vielleicht sogar mehrere und dann kommt nochmal eine Testrakete
für ein neues Modell und was auch immer.
Also hindert dich wirklich gerade etwas daran, Raketen ins All zu schießen,
sieht irgendwie nicht so aus, aber ist aus seiner Richtung natürlich anders beobachtet.
Und das ist jetzt Joe Rogan im Gespräch mit Donald Trump, aber es ist das selbe Thema.
Ja, es ist nun mal sehr unwahrscheinlich, eine Rakete erfolgreich ins Weltall
zu schießen, aber ob jetzt diese Regulierung, also ich würde sagen,
sie haben ganz schön viele Probleme gehabt und gelöst und jetzt fliegen halt Raketen ins All so.
Was ist denn jetzt das Ziel, jeden Tag zehn oder was?
Das ist ja das Absurde bei Elon Musk.
Er könnte ja eigentlich, wenn er sich auf diesen Kulturkampf nicht eingelassen
hätte, der Held der Demokraten sein. Das ist ja das Verrückte.
Die Demokraten wollen die grüne Transformation mit großen Investitionen,
wollen die chinesische E-Mobilität klein halten, mit Zöllen noch und nöcher belegen.
Sie wollen, dass auch bei der Weltraumtechnik Privatisierung stattfindet.
Die NASA profitiert sehr von Elon Musk und anderen, dass das so günstig geworden
ist, zum Beispiel Raketen nach oben zu schicken.
Es gibt niemanden, der dem im Wege stehen würde.
Also eigentlich könnte Elon Musk so eine Gallionsfigur sein,
einer solchen grünen Transformation zumindest, aber mit dem,
was die Demokraten und wahrscheinlich auch große Teile der grünen Deutschland
unter dem verstehen würden, was eigentlich grüne Transformation ist.
Und das ist ja so das Absurde, auch wenn man Tesla-Fahrer kennt,
ich kenne ein paar Tesla-Fahrer, von denen ist niemand jetzt bei den grünen
Mitglied, aber durchaus sympathisant, findet das wichtig,
mehr Ladesäulen, findet auch Habecks Ansätze da durchaus gut,
die finden vielleicht manche kulturkämpferischen Dinge eigenartig,
ja, aber das wären eigentlich Leute, die sagen, ja.
Bin ich total d'accord mit. Und da gibt es jetzt sogar ja Leute,
die sich von ihren Teslas trennen.
Da gibt es sehr viele, die bei LinkedIn jetzt darüber berichten,
die sagen, dieser Elon Musk gefällt mir nicht, damit möchte ich nichts zu tun
haben, der jetzt gegen Transrechte und so weiter schießt.
Das heißt, da sind Leute, die eigentlich genau dieses liberale vertreten,
gegen das Elon Musk jetzt ankämpft.
Das sind nämlich Leute, die sehr gut verdienen, die in gewisser Weise Wurg sind
und die Umwelt Glauben mit Zertifikaten und allem möglichen retten zu können,
das kann man jetzt belächeln.
Jedenfalls sind die nicht Trump-Leute, die sagen, bohrt mal wieder richtig, Drill, Baby, Drill.
Also Elon Musk ist nicht mehr der Elon Musk von vor zehn Jahren.
Einfach nicht dieselbe Figur. Wir hören das nachher auch.
Wir könnten uns ihn vorstellen, Hand in Hand mit Leonardo DiCaprio,
wie sie ein neues Auto vorstellen.
Genau. Er hätte mit diesen Filmen von Al Gore und damals und so,
und deswegen habe ich Tesla gegründet, die große Gründergeschichte,
dann hätte man vielleicht noch diesen Joke gemacht, naja, als Gründer,
du hast damals Geld bezahlt, damit die dich noch als Gründer da reinschreiben,
aber du hast den Laden gekauft.
Aber ich kann mich ja noch dran erinnern, dass wir auch Clips gespielt haben,
in denen Elon Musk bei Chirrogan erklärt hat, wir haben so und so viel Kohlenstoff, noch liegt es im Boden.
Wenn wir es weitermachen wie bisher, ist es in der Luft, wenn es in der Luft
ist, ist es schlecht. Deswegen habe ich Tesla und so weiter,
diese elektrische, nichts davon ist mir übrig.
Also gar nichts davon. Wir hören es nachher, es ist wirklich grotesk, wie man so überzeugt,
Milliarden Unternehmen bewirtschaftet und so weiter. Ich glaube,
heute hat er nicht mehr so diesen großen, also da sitzen ja überall Leute, die das so machen.
Damals war das aber noch anders. Vielleicht hätte er auch einfach in dieser Rolle bleiben sollen.
Statt jetzt drei Unternehmen so eins, wo man so noch mit dem Unternehmen was
zu tun hat. Statt einfach nur so drüber zu schwimmen.
Na gut. Also wir haben hier, dieser Tenor ist gesetzt. Die Regulierung steht
dem Fortschritt im Weg. Fortschritt ist aber das, was Elon Musk will.
Und er hat Donald Trump soweit bekehrt.
Jaja, das sind vor allem die Umweltauflagen. Wir brauchen hier eine andere Herangehensweise.
Ich habe mit Elon gesprochen, der würde gerne zehnmal so viele Raketen losschicken,
um dann irgendwie den Mars zu besiedeln.
Elon Musk in seinen eigenen Worten, und hier sieht man jetzt schon die ideologische
Ausprägung, die da so kommt.
Er beschreibt das aktuelle Szenario, die Welt, wie er sie sieht.
And every year we're making it harder in America for actual builders to get things done.
You know, we're in this weird Ayn Rand, Atlas Shrugged scenario.
Ja, Ayn Rand, Atlas Shrugged ist das Szenario, das er da sieht.
Erklär es mal kurz, du hast es ja mit Ole auch gelesen. Habt ihr direkt Atlas
Shrugged gelesen oder habt ihr was anderes?
Ihr habt doch kürzlich auch Ayn Rand nochmal gelesen.
Oder? Wir haben The Fountainhead und Atlas Shrugged gelesen.
Gut, aber da steht ja wohl überall so ein bisschen dasselbe drin.
Also was er jetzt beschreibt ist, in diesen Büchern, die ich nicht gelesen habe,
wird so eine Welt beschrieben, die dich institutionell einfach knechtet und
so weiter, statt dir einfach die Freiheit zuzugestehen, die dir doch eigentlich zusteht.
Genau, in Atlas Schrack geht es darum, dass die Regierung mit ihren Institutionen
so stark geworden ist, dass unternehmerischer Geist nicht mehr möglich ist,
dass immer mehr für die Arbeiter getan werden, die immer fauler werden,
dass alles, was unternehmerisch an Innovation kommen soll, da geht es um neue
Stahlproduktion und so etwas, alles aufgehalten wird.
Und deshalb beschließen die Superreichen, in einen Streik zu treten.
Also es ist genau umgekehrt, sie sagen nämlich, nee, wir sind nicht abhängig
von den Arbeitern, sondern die Arbeiter sind abhängig von uns.
Und diese ganzen Bürokraten sind abhängig von uns, die fressen unser Geld auf.
Deswegen streiken wir jetzt und dann sehen wir mal.
Und das ist diese Idee, das ist der Streik der Superreichen,
der hier aufgetan wird, also seiner Superreichen.
Wenn wir jetzt Trump unterstützen,
dann haben wir damit eigentlich, also das ist seine Form des Streiks quasi,
gegen diese liberalen Eliten, die so sehr Bürokratie aufgebaut haben,
dass unternehmerisches Handeln nicht mehr möglich ist.
Und das führt, und das ist ja die These von Ayn Rand, direkt dieses Bürokratische,
sobald man den Staat mitentscheiden lässt bei wirtschaftlichen Fragen,
in den Sozialismus und damit in die Diktatur.
Und deswegen sagt er, ich bin der Verteidiger der Demokratie.
Sehr gut, also kann man das nachlesen, warum sich Elon Musk hier als der eigentliche
Ausgebeutete, die Arbeiter beuten mich aus, die Politiker beuten mich aus,
die Bürokratie beutet mich aus.
Also diese Romane von Ayn Rand haben 1000 und 1400 Seiten.
Bei Wohlstandsfalle haben wir es ein bisschen kürzer besprochen, sage ich mal.
Ja, okay. Naja, wer weiß es, er hat ja anscheinend unendlich viel Zeit am Tag,
er schreibt ja auch 100 Tweets.
Vielleicht hat er auch diese Lesezeit.
Um dann einfach sich alles mal… Mal in dieser Rede auch ein Einlesen von John Galt.
Es gibt nämlich in diesem Roman dann eine hundertseitige Rede,
der nochmal all das gesagt wird.
Hundert Seiten von diesen?
Ja, ja. Hundert Seiten nochmal, wie die Welt eigentlich zu sein hat und wie sie gerade ist.
Und dieses Manische bei Ayn Rand, also diese unglaubliche Länge,
ist wieder und wieder zu sagen, immer dasselbe.
Es ist ja nicht nochmal ein neuer Gedanken mit drin.
Das ist etwas, was man auch bei Trump und bei Elon Musk so stark finden kann,
dass das ja wahnsinnig repetitiv ist.
So, und jetzt schlägt sich das nieder im politischen Programm,
denn er ist das Schoßhündchen für Donald Trump und Trump sagt bei Joe Rogan folgendes.
Ich frage viele der Geschäftsführer von den großen Unternehmen,
die Leute, die die großen Unternehmen erledigen, die sagen, also wenn du deine
Wahl hattest, du hast es jetzt schon lange gehabt, was ist für dich wichtiger,
die Tax-Cuts, du hast weniger Tax-Tax, oder die Regulation-Cuts?
Every one of them said the regulation cuts meant more.
Who would think that, right? Because you don't equate it to dollars but it actually is more dollars.
We had it going and then we just had to focus on something else.
These two pollsters were sitting there and they said, sir, if George Washington
came back and Abraham Lincoln was his VP as opposed to Waltz how bad is he, by the way?
Aber wenn Abraham Lincoln was seine VP, sie könnten Sie nicht.
Und ich werde nie vergessen, der folgende Tag, sie sagten, etwas ist passiert
in China, könnte wir uns treffen?
Ich sage, was passiert? People sind sterben.
Oh Gott, ich höre die Clips-Cut selber zum ersten Mal in einfacher Geschwindigkeit.
Was erzählt er da eigentlich?
Also, das Szenario ist wie folgt. Die Leute haben von ihm einen Steuernachlass
bekommen, so einen großen Million-Text-Cut und so weiter.
Daraufhin kamen die Ökonomen zu ihm, haben gesagt, hat super funktioniert,
alle sind außer sich, das Land steht so gut da wie nie.
Selbst wenn sie jetzt gegen Lincoln
und wen auch immer als das Gegenticket angestellt, sie würden gewinnen.
Ja, gegen George Washington.
Genau. Und dann weiß ich noch, am nächsten Tag haben die mir gesagt,
in China sterben Leute Corona.
Also das Schicksal brach über ihn hinein. Er hatte den Plan,
aber dann kam leider Corona.
So, nun ist aber Corona vorbei und auch die demokratische Lücke im Trumpschen
Regierungssystem, denn ab nächster Woche könnte er ja weiter regieren.
Und jetzt hat er ja schon angekündigt, dass Elon Musk die Rolle eines Commissioners
bekommt, der sich mit Regierungseffektivität auseinandersetzt.
Also wir hatten das ja hier auch mal, dass Edmund Stoiber berufen wurde zu entbürokratisieren
in der EU und er hat das digitale Büro eingeführt oder so. Also relativ harmlos.
Das ist natürlich hier ganz anders, denn Elon Musk redet mit Tucker Carlson
über die Aufgabe, die jetzt konkret da drin stecken könnte, würde,
wenn Donald Trump gewinnt und dann diese Kommission, also die dann sozusagen
auch parallel direkt dem Präsidenten unterstellt, du darfst für mich jetzt zertrümmern,
sag mir, wo ich die Axt hinschlagen soll.
Und Musk und Tucker Carlson reden so darüber.
Dass wir mehr als eine FEDERAL AGENCY auf jeden Fall haben.
That seems a lot. That's a lot. So, that seems crazy.
I think we should be able to get away with 99 agencies. I don't know,
that seems a lot like a lot of agencies. It's a lot.
Two per state, that's a lot. Yeah, exactly.
So, Amerika gibt es jetzt 250 Jahre, es gibt aber 300 Behörden.
Ist das nicht ganz schön viel? Ja, wir sollten einfach 99 machen.
Das ist jetzt wie Javier Millet einfach alles zerschlägt.
Ja, das ist so wie jetzt gerade wieder in Berlin regiert wird. 10% auf alles.
Und dann wird halt alles einfach abrasiert. Kennt man ja von Sarrazin, Erfolgsmodell.
Die ganzen Wohnungen wurden verkauft, verscherbelt und jetzt sind die 15 Mal
so viel wert und niemand hat eine Wohnung.
Also man könnte ja einfach die Hälfte der Behörden streichen.
Jetzt muss man sich überlegen, angenommen man arbeitet jetzt in so einer Behörde
und sieht sowas im Fernsehen.
Das ist ja nicht mal Fernsehen, das ist einfach so ein Twitter-Video, zwei Stunden lang.
Wo irgend so ein Superreicher, der nicht auf dem Wahlzettel steht,
der dich auch danach weiter bedroht, aber der sich einfach diesen Platz erkauft
hat, bei der nächsten Wahl einem der beiden Präsidenten direkt unterstellt zu werden. So.
Und dann weißt du, warte mal, ich arbeite hier in der Umweltbehörde? Blöd.
Also das wird, selbst wenn die Behörde nicht abgeschafft wird,
wird es einfach nur noch heißen, sparen, sparen, sparen, neue Projekte, never und so.
Es reicht erstmal deinen Chef zu kündigen und nicht neu zu besetzen.
Also diese Lähmung, für die braucht man dann auch keinen Kongress oder so,
sondern da reicht es völlig die Unterschrift des Präsidenten und Elon Musk,
der einfach sowas dann vollzieht.
Also hier droht einfach wirklich Großes.
Und hier sehen wir auch nochmal das Motivlose auch da drin wieder,
also es gibt einmal das Motiv natürlich zu entbürokratisieren,
das heißt also der Privatwirtschaft noch mehr Freiraum zu geben,
aber dann sagt man 99 ist eine schöne Zahl, 99 Behörden soll es geben.
Also er nimmt einfach die Zahl 99, weil sie ihm gefällt.
Das ist dann ähnlich wie Trump sagt, er ist der Beste, weil er gerne sagt, er ist der Beste.
Und 99 kann sich jeder merken, nehme ich das als Zahl.
Hat keine Evidenz, völlig sinnlos.
Das ist die Börsenberichterstattung zum Thema die psychologisch wichtige Marke,
dass nämlich einfach alle wissen, es gibt schon 99 Bundesbehörden,
ich kann keine weitere vorschlagen. Der Deckel ist zu.
Also es ist ein ganz perfil der Strategie. Genau, du hast Sacherwägung,
du willst noch eine Fragestellung lösen, sorry, aber das Papier ist vollgeschrieben,
hier passt nichts mehr drauf.
Flüchtlinge 100.000, das ist die Obergrenze.
So und jetzt ist ja die große Frage, wie kann man noch Zukunft gestalten und
wir haben ja in Deutschland so einen Diskurs mit,
ne VW ist jetzt auch pleite gegangen, hätten wir auf Robert Habeck 2019 bei
Maybrit Illner, wo er sagte, wir müssen den Markt gestalten,
wir müssen hier Anreize formulieren,
Stromkabel legen, damit die Leute wissen, ich kann auf der Autobahn ruhig mal
eine halbe Stunde Pause machen und da wo ich dann eine brauche steht auch eine Ladesäule oder sowas.
Nur, wenn man diese Märkte nicht gestaltet, also Regulierung nicht hat,
in welche Richtung geht dann das Wachstum und dann ist ganz klar Ausbeutung
von Natur, von Arbeitern, von allem einfach.
Also das Gegenprogramm zu einem regulierten, gestalteten Markt,
der sozusagen Win-Win für alle mitbringt, ist einfach ein Ausbeutermarkt,
der so Win-Los-Los-Los.
Also es ist einfach nicht gut. Und jetzt hören wir aber Elon Musk,
wie er da drauf schaut, wenn man so meint,
99, ja das ist doch eine gute Zahl, ich als Ingenieur kann das doch einfach
mal machen. Also er erklärt uns kurz sein Mindset.
Weil ich so viele Glauben in der Konstruktion bin. Ich bilde Dinge,
das ist das, was ich mache. Ich bilde Fahrzeuge, ich bilde Rockets,
ich bilde Satelliteinternet.
Also Elon Musk, du wirst ja bald Politiker und wirst mehr als die Hälfte der
Bundesbehörden streichen. Kannst du uns erklären wie?
Sorry, aber ich bin Ingenieur, ich baue Raketen, ich baue Autos.
Ich kann mich mit diesem politischen Mindset nicht befassen.
Ich will einfach nur Raketen bauen. Also genau die Herangehensweise,
von der man so denkt, könnte aufgehen.
Diese Ausbeutung, die dann die Alternative ist, also wenn man einfach sagt,
ja gut, okay, also dann werden wir keine Regulierung mehr haben und Wirtschaftskraft
brauchen, dann machen wir halt Fracking einfach überall und nehmen einfach Kinder
ab 14 mit auf die Baustelle oder wie auch immer.
Bei Jorgen beschreibt Trump das mal, wenn, und darauf kommen wir jetzt als nächstes,
Die Zölle erstmal da sind und das Land befreit ist von zum Beispiel Einkommenssteuer,
weil es soll ja alles das Ausland zahlen.
Also die Mauer ist schön, solange Mexiko bezahlt. Nichts davon ist ja jemals
aufgegangen. Hier wird jetzt einfach das ganze Land verscherbelt.
Alles was Amerika hat, sind ja ganz tolle Assets, auf die man nochmal zurückgreifen kann.
Ich habe nur als Asset-Value gesehen. Wir haben Öl-Underground.
Wir haben Wasser. Wir haben Mountains.
Ich meine, die Assets sind so enorm.
Aber egal ob das, wir haben 35 Trillion in Debt. Wir sollten es auf.
Und wir würden starten Paying-Off-Debt und wahrscheinlich sogar noch weiter,
um weiter zu reduzieren. Ich will es um 15 Prozent.
Wir werden mehr But when you get hit with the COVID, everything stops.
Wir fahren den Staat runter, keine Ausgaben mehr, keine Behörden.
Wir nehmen dir auch nichts weg, behältst dein Einkommen einfach.
Und den Rest regeln die Assets, die wir hier haben. Klar haben wir einen hohen
Schuldenstand, aber ich meine, wir haben die Nordsee.
Wir verkaufen einfach die Nordsee.
Das ist der Immobilien-Businessman, der sagt, da kann man doch auch noch ein Hotel bauen.
Ja, und das Einzige, was uns hindert daran, einfach jede Gasblase ab und zu
zapfen und ach, da wohnen Leute drauf.
Schade für die Leute, aber wir können jetzt nicht regulieren,
dass da irgendwas im Weg steht. Gut, das haben wir schon gehört,
es gibt dieses neue Modell.
Damit kommt er ja sehr gut an, weil wenn wir jetzt nochmal darüber nachdenken,
dass jetzt unterschieden wird zwischen verschiedenen Milliardären oder Superreichen.
Es gibt ja nun diese Small Business, die natürlich sehr, sehr groß sind.
Also was ist jetzt nicht ein Tante-Emma-Laden, die für Fracking ganz entscheidend sind.
Und da findet er natürlich ganz großen Anklang damit, das sind ja gar nicht
nur diese Großkonzerne,
sondern das sind dann Unternehmen mit vielleicht einem Umsatz von 100 Millionen
oder 200 Millionen Dollar und mit solchen Leuten kann man sich vorstellen,
kann Trump relativ gut reden.
Die haben nichts zu tun mit liberalen Eliten, die werden noch nicht nach Davos
eingeladen, dafür sind sie nicht wichtig genug.
Aber da steckt auch sehr viel Geld im Land und da gibt es natürlich viele,
die sagen, diese Bürokratie tötet uns. Trump, tu was.
Genau, das Ding ist nur, weil wir auch gleich den völkischen Suizid und so weiter hören.
Bislang war immer ein, oder es wurde problematisiert, dass Amerika den Nahen Osten ausbeutet.
Amerika braucht Energie, also wird das Ganze da in Chaos gestürzt,
sodass man besser, billiger an das Öl rankommt.
Jetzt ist Amerika aber selbst der größte Energieproduzent sozusagen,
also der größte Ausbeuter seiner selbst.
Ja, Öl und Gas, ja.
Genau, also die zerstören sich sozusagen selbst.
Ja.
Es hatte noch so eine gewisse Logik zu sagen, wir zerstören die andere Seite
der Welt und fahren es dann mit dem Schiff rüber.
Ja.
Aber jetzt eigene Städte zu opfern, um dann irgendwelche Wrecking-Blasen ranzukommen,
die Leute in Flint zu vergiften, weil man irgendwas und so weiter.
Also das ist ja wirklich neue Qualität von Ausbeutung sozusagen,
um ein Wachstum, einen Fortschritt zu forcieren.
Trump möchte jetzt das alles auf die Spitze treiben mit ganz neuen Regelungen
jetzt hören wir das, wie er das bei Joe Rogan erklärt,
Sein Verhältnis zum Ausland ist, sagen wir mal so, fragwürdig.
Und, was wir eben schon gehört haben bei Applebaum, Begriffe werden einfach neu verwendet.
Ich würde nicht mal sagen, sie sind jetzt nur Illustrationen,
weil Trump bringt ja immer so ein Impetus von, er glaubt da wirklich dran.
Also wenn er jetzt so einen Begriff umdeutet.
Kommt ja wirklich so ein….
Dann hat er einen neuen Glaubenssatz.
Genau, das ist ja nicht ein Grundbegriff, sondern ein Glaubenssatz.
Und jetzt hören wir mal, wie er über Zölle redet, also Tariffs.
To me, the most beautiful word, and I've said this for the last couple of weeks,
in the dictionary today, is the word tariff.
It's more beautiful than love. It's more beautiful than anything.
It's the most beautiful word.
This country can become rich with the proper use of tariffs.
Did you just float out the idea of getting rid of income taxes and replacing it with tariffs?
Well, okay. Were you serious about that? Yeah, sure. But why not?
So, Income Tax. Joe Rogan hat jetzt zum zweiten Mal mit Spotify so einen hunderte
Millionen Vertrag unterschrieben.
Warum kümmert ihn noch, und ich unterstelle ihm jetzt so ein intrinsisches,
noch mal Einkommenssteuer?
Ist er nicht bereit, jetzt einfach diese 15 Millionen zu zahlen auf 100 Millionen?
Nee. Und er wird sicherlich auch schon jetzt ein Konstrukt haben,
bei dem er das nicht alles als Einkommenssteuer verbuchen muss,
sondern das wird über verschiedene Holdings laufen, dass der da schon eine Optimierung
hat, von der wir gar nicht wissen wollen, wie sie läuft.
Und hier ist es nochmal interessant zu sehen, dass wir jetzt einen verliebten
Trump haben, der sagt, Tariffs, das ist mein neuer Begriff.
Das ist doch wirklich Resultat von Inception, oder?
Ja, nur die traurige Sache ist ja, Die anderen sind ja fast genauso verliebt in die Zölle.
Also die gehen natürlich nicht so weit und sagen, deswegen können wir die Einkommensteuer
streichen, was ja auch nicht funktioniert.
Diese Zölle funktionieren ja nur bis zu einem gewissen Punkt,
wo man noch irgendwo sagt, da macht Import, Export noch, sagen wir so,
diese Zölle funktionieren nur dann, wenn man ja noch jemand hat, der sie zahlt.
Weshalb sie nicht funktionieren werden.
Weshalb sie natürlich in einer Höhe, wie er sich die vorstellt,
nicht mehr funktionieren.
Ja, dann gibt es halt keine E-Autos mehr aus China dort, wie auch gewisse anderen
Dinge nicht mehr eingeführt werden.
Ja, das ist dann so. Und dann kann das das nicht finanzieren.
Und das Problem ist aber, dass wir alle jetzt sehen, in Amerika,
wie auch in der EU, ist man immer verliebter in diese Zölle.
Das ist ja eigentlich so eine neue Form von Sanktionspolitik im Prinzip.
Zölle klingt ein bisschen höflich.
Hast du diesen Clip gesehen? Die Verbandschefin der Familienunternehmer war
bei Lanz im April mit Robert Habeck.
Ich zitiere jetzt, weil ich diesen Clip, aber der ist so gut,
den kann man nochmal aussuchen.
Sie sitzt direkt neben Habeck und sagt, Herr Habeck,
Zölle sind der völlig falsche Ansatz, aber sie müssen doch, wenn jemand illegalerweise,
die WHO-Ordnung nach, wir produzieren so und so, denjenigen bestrafen,
also mit Sanktionen belegen.
Und dann sagt Habeck, aber das sind denn Zölle.
Und dann sagt sie, nee, Zölle wären ja Protektionismus, aber ich bin ja für Bestrafung.
Ach so, ja, nicht protektionistische Bestrafung.
Habe, was genau, also ich habe es nicht wortwörtlich, aber die substantive Stimme.
Man kann es sich nicht glauben, dass diese Leute, die das Schicksal Deutschlands
in ihrer Hand halten, weil sie einfach diese Unternehmensbeteiligung unter sich
aufgeteilt haben, dass sie nicht in der Lage sind, ihre Grundbegriffe richtig zu verwenden.
Also konzeptionell kein Verständnis von der Funktionsweise ihres Reichtums haben.
Und das macht mir manchmal ein bisschen Angst, weil Weil man denkt so,
okay, man hat ein partikulares Interesse, wenn man viel zu verlieren hat. Das ist völlig normal.
Ja, aber man weiß, wie der Lage läuft.
Aber man muss verstehen, was passiert.
Das ist ja genau das bei der Migrationspolitik. Viele Leute,
die gegen Migrationspolitik sind, würden wahnsinnig davon profitieren,
dann hätten sie nämlich Arbeitskräfte.
Und du kannst das da genau sehen. Und deswegen glaube ich, dass diese Handelskriege
zunehmen werden, egal wer jetzt Präsident wird.
Bei Trump wird es wahrscheinlich besonders schlimm. Mag aber auch sein,
dass der auf die Nase fällt damit und dann wieder zurückzieht.
Denn diese Idee, dass die Zölle die Einkommenssteuer ersetzen können,
kann nicht funktionieren.
Dann ist dann einfach Amerika als Handelspartner nicht mehr relevant.
Dann sagt man, gut, dann machen wir das jetzt ohne die.
Diese Idee der Zollpolitik, die jetzt ja betrieben wird von EU und USA,
ist ja die Idee, wir halten die Chinesen klein und versuchen dann unsere Wirtschaft aufzubauen.
Und dann kauft man uns die Sachen wieder ab. Ich glaube nicht,
dass das im Ganzen aufgehen wird. Ich finde es auch völlig falsch, dass es so läuft.
Aber diese Idee, die Trump jetzt hier hat und die dann auch Elon Musk und Tucker
Carlson toll finden, ist wirklich erstaunlich, weil sie doch genau diese Frage
sich stellen müssten und sie stellen sich die nicht.
Aber wir hatten doch auch diesen deutschen Börsenchef, der so eine ganz verrückte
Rede gehalten hat über die Wirtschaft.
Also ich habe schon die These, dass überhaupt die deutsche Wirtschaft nun deshalb
einigermaßen gut läuft, weil
es noch so was wie, es gibt unsichtbare Marktkräfte, die funktionieren,
es gibt Institutionen, wo Leute wissen, was sie tun, nämlich im Beamtenapparat,
und dann gibt es noch ein paar unternehmerische Talente und der Rest läuft im
Blindflug, da gehen die da durch.
Cachen ordentlich ein, haben aber eigentlich keine Ahnung, wenn du sie fragen
würdest, wie sie zu dem Geld kommen.
Wenn du sie fragen würdest, sagen sie wahrscheinlich so etwas, ich war immer mutig.
Oder sowas. Aber sie wissen überhaupt nicht, wie ihre Renditen zustande kommen.
Sie sind völlig ahnungslos.
Es gibt glaube ich auch diesen Mechanismus, den man bei Musk auf jeden Fall
sieht, dass sie wissen, wie es vor 15 Jahren funktioniert hat.
Und dann sind sie aber ins Delegieren übergegangen und erzählen heute noch,
dass sie ja Raketen bauen, obwohl sie einfach nur in einem Meeting wissen,
sie haben das letzte Wort.
Und dann geht das Meeting auseinander und dann macht trotzdem jeder,
was er für richtig hält und nicht, was Elon Musk gesagt hat.
Nur man erklärt es ihm nicht mehr.
Sondern er ist halt einfach nur der Eigner, der halt nochmal so,
den man so anrufen darf. Grün oder rot? Rot.
Dann trugen sie es trotzdem grün, aber er guckt nie wieder nach und erzählt
dann auf einer Bühne, also ich hab rot gesagt, dann haben die es rot gemacht und so.
Ich hab denen die Sicherheit gegeben sozusagen, wo es genau andersrum schon funktioniert.
Trump beschreibt es hier, es ist im Grunde alles total übersichtlich.
Also das muss man wirklich sagen.
Zölle statt Einkommenssteuer, absolut übersichtlich. Wie läuft dann Produktion ab? Naja, so.
So,
jetzt kann man natürlich, wir hatten das ja schon mal, in China,
also wir haben das weltberühmte Shenzhen, 30 Millionen Einwohner,
alles elektrifiziert und so weiter und so fort.
Und daneben aber eine Stadt, die noch niemals jemand gehört hat,
aber mit 50 Millionen Einwohnern.
Und das ist dann da, wo die Toilettenschüsseln und die Waschmaschinen hergestellt
werden. Das, was alle Leute brauchen.
Jetzt kann man natürlich den Zollkrieg die ganze Zeit über so Sachen laufen
lassen, die man gut medial in der Sehgewohnheit unterkriegt.
Und dann stellt man aber irgendwie fest, ach so, wir kriegen dann keine Waschmaschine mehr.
Und Amerika hat ja auch so eine Art Waschmaschine und das ist einfach deren
Elektronik. Die sind so stolz auf das Silicon Valley und so weiter.
Nur im Silicon Valley stehen keine Fabrikhallen.
Das sind halt nur diese kleinen Büros.
So Google, fünf Stockwerke oder so.
Werden keine iPhones zusammengeschraubt.
Genau. Und es gibt auch diesen berühmten Clip von Tim Cook, der ja nun wirklich
die Lieferketten unter Kontrolle hat. Also es ist ja einer, der wirklich weiß, was passiert.
Und der dann einfach beschreibt, also so ein Auditorium vor ihm und er erklärt
dann, sie haben ein ganz falsches Bild von China.
Sie denken, wir gehen dahin, weil es da billige Arbeitskräfte gibt.
Das stimmt nicht. Wir gehen dahin, weil es da Arbeitskräfte gibt.
Wir brauchen 200.000 Leute, denen wir erklären, das ist das neue Modell.
Lehrgang, das wird so und so zusammengebaut. Dann haben die einen Monat Zeit,
das zu lernen. Und dann wollen wir, dass die 200.000 Leute das machen.
Wenn wir in China ausrufen, Foxconn, bewerbt euch bitte und so weiter.
Dann sagen die, ja, wann ist der Termin? Übermorgen. Und dann stehen da 200.000
Leute. Und in Amerika kommt da niemand.
Also es war wirklich ganz beeindruckend zu sehen, wie er einfach sagt,
ausgeschlossen, also es ist einfach ausgeschlossen, dass iPhones jemals in Amerika
hergestellt werden, weil es einfach die Leute nicht gibt.
In der Qualität und in der Anzahl, wie man sie braucht.
Was ja auch einleuchtend ist, das ist ein Premium-Produkt. iPhones sind sehr
teuer und alle anderen Apple-Geräte auch.
Das heißt, der Mindestlohn, der in den USA zu zahlen wäre, Ingenieure würde
jetzt wahrscheinlich die Kosten für das iPhone nicht extrem erhöhen.
Das wäre nicht so, dass man sagt, jetzt kostet das iPhone ja leider das Doppelte.
Das heißt, es kann nur das sein, was Tim Cook sagt, es mangelt an Leuten.
Man braucht diese Ingenieure. Also das iPhone zusammenzubauen ist eine Ingenieursleistung.
Da muss dieser Titan behandelt werden, es muss dieses Glas richtig hergestellt werden und so.
Das geht einfach nicht mit dem, was man in Amerika hat, nämlich so ein Bildungssystem,
das so, naja, und dann halt so eine Spitzenelite, die sich auf drei Unis aufteilt.
Die schraubt natürlich nicht.
Genau, dazwischen ist einfach Brachland. Es gibt das einfach nicht.
Und jetzt wird aber genau das hier zum Thema.
By my rhetoric. Rhetorically, I said they'll never sell a car in here. I'll put tariffs.
I don't care if they're 2,000%. They're never going to build that plant.
Is it possible to apply that same thing to the electronics that we use?
One of the things that disturbs me greatly is that all of our phones are made overseas.
And then some of our phones are made in places like... And the chips.
Yes, and the chips. And some of our phones are made in places like Foxconn,
where they have nets around the building to keep people from jumping off the
roof because they have so many suicides.
Like, wouldn't Wouldn't it be better to have an American-made iPhone where you
know people are paid good wages, they have health insurance,
they're taken care of, they can live a good life, where you're not buying a
piece of electronics that's cheaper because someone has to suffer in a horrible
way that's not even legal in the United States.
It's not even legal to have them work that way in the United States so they
get these people to build them
overseas. You do it, but let me just tell you, that chip deal is so bad.
We put up billions of dollars for rich companies to come in and borrow the money
and build chip companies here.
And they're not going to give us the good companies anyway.
All you had to do is charge them tariffs. If you would have put a tariff on
the chips coming in, you would have been able to, just like the auto companies, no different.
More sophisticated, but no different. You know, Taiwan, they stole our chip business.
So, also hier biegt er wirklich in allen Richtungen falsch ab.
Er sagt einfach, ja, ja, klar, können wir ein iPhone herstellen.
Und das eigene Problem sind aber die Chips.
Und was ja wirklich stimmt, ist, dass es da so Deals gab und dann irgendwie
Snapdragon oder so gesagt hat, ja klar, wir bauen da eine Fabrik.
Und dann haben die halt ein Gebäude hingestellt.
Und The Verge hat sich einen Scherz draus gemacht, da jeden Monat mal vorbeizufahren,
um zu gucken, ob man da irgendwann mal irgendwie einen Menschen sieht.
Und nach drei Jahren haben sie das Projekt eingestellt und haben gesagt,
nö, wir haben da noch nie jemanden gesehen. Also da wird nichts hergestellt.
Das ist einfach nur, Trump hat gesagt, da muss aber eine Fabrik hin.
Also haben die da eine Fabrik hingebaut. Und da ist aber nichts passiert.
Jetzt hat er Taiwan einfach mit unter den Bus geworfen.
Ja.
Also statt jetzt zu sagen, was ja der richtige Gang ist, zu sagen,
nee, diese Chips werden in Taiwan hergestellt.
Und dieses Chip herstellen ist wirklich schwierig.
Da wird einfach eine Modellfabrik gebaut und dann noch eine und noch eine und noch eine.
Und irgendwann kriegt man es hin, diese Chips genau so herzustellen, wie man sie haben will.
Und dann gucken sich die Ingenieure an und sagen, ich weiß nicht genau,
warum es jetzt geklappt hat, aber wir bauen jetzt alle Fabriken so wie diese Modellprojekte.
Also da muss jedes Wasserrohr dann genauso gebaut werden wie vorher,
damit es dann irgendwie hinhaut. Also reine Magie.
Man ist abhängig von diesem ASLM, dieser niederländischen Firma,
die diese Fräsemaschine oder irgendwas herstellt.
Also hier gibt es kein partikulares Interesse.
Sondern Das ist Welthandel.
Genau. Das gibt es nur im Welthandel. Ansonsten, wenn Trump diese Zölle für
chinesische Güter so macht, dass die Chinesen sagen, ja gut, scheiß drauf.
Also wenn jetzt alles auf dem Tisch liegt, wir liefern euch diese Chips nicht
mehr. Die kriegen jetzt einen Ausreisezoll nach Amerika. Kann ja alles mögliche passieren.
So, oder iPhones, ne? Also hergestellte iPhones, da ist einfach ein Schiff voller
iPhones und China sagt, nö, darf nicht abfahren. Hat keine Genehmigung,
irgendwas ist hier und so.
Man kriegt es nicht in Amerika reproduziert, dass,
Mark Zuckerberg zuletzt auf diese Bühne ging und sagte, ich habe hier neue Technologie,
aber es ist nur ein Prototyp, denn die Herstellung würde 10.000 Euro kosten
und das kriegen wir niemals vermarktet, weil niemand ist bereit für so eine
Brille 10.000 Euro zu bezahlen.
Das wäre das Szenario für jedes iPhone.
Apple müsste einfach sagen, sorry, das iPhone kostet jetzt 10.000 Dollar.
Damit wäre es kein Massenprodukt mehr. Alle Synergien wären erledigt.
Also es wäre einfach ein Abriss dieses Fortschritts.
Man denkt ja dann immer, ja gut, also der menschliche Fortschritt ist ja irgendwie
ganz toll und da kann man ja immer anschließen.
Und dann gibt es diesen Joke von so einem Typen auf der Bühne,
ich habe leider seinen Namen nicht und ich glaube, ich finde es auch auf Instagram
nicht mehr und er macht es wirklich herrlich, das ist so eine Minute,
er steht auf der Bühne und sagt,
angenommen es gäbe Zeitreisen, ich würde jetzt ins Jahr 1924 zurückreisen.
Ich könnte den Leuten gar nicht beweisen, dass ich aus der Zukunft bin.
Die würden mich fragen, wer ist denn der nächste Präsident? Und ich würde sagen, keine Ahnung.
Also man weiß nicht mal, wer der nächste Präsident ist. Man hat kein Wissen
darüber. Niemand hat ein Wissen darüber.
Dieses Wissen, die Menschheit hat es geschafft, Chips herzustellen.
Wenn in Taiwan ein Krieg ist und diese Chipsfabriken werden zerstört,
dann schaffen wir das in zehn Jahren nicht, wieder aufzubauen.
Dann wird es einfach diese Chips nicht geben. Und dieses Verständnis wird,
glaube ich, die nächsten Jahre so kommen.
Wie groß die Abhängigkeit von so Lieferketten und Versöhnungs- und Verständnis
politischer Kommunikation.
Ja, aber das ist eine alte Auffassung von Industrie. Man braucht ein bisschen
Know-how und dann kann man das auch schnell errichten mit einer Fabrik.
Dass man das einfach so reproduzieren könnte.
Man diese hochfinziellen Sachen nicht bekommt.
Die EMC kann selber nicht reproduzieren, wie sie Chips herstellen.
Die wissen nur, dass es in dieser Fabrik funktioniert.
Und dann ist ja schon, ich habe mir hier ein iPad geholt, weil es gab jetzt
nach drei Jahren mal wieder die kleinen iPads.
Ich bin so froh, dass du noch ein weiteres iPad haben konntest. Toll. Gratuliere.
Ja, genau. Aber schaut euch mal die Reviews von diesem iPad an.
Keiner wird eingeladen, dieses iPad zu kaufen. Warum? Hier ist der Chip drin,
der vor einem Jahr im iPhone 15 verbaut wurde.
Kein M-Chip und auch nicht der aktuelle iPhone-Chip. Und die Legende sagt,
weil dieser iPad-Chip auch noch ein Kern weniger hat als der iPhone-Chip,
der Legende nach ist das die Ausschussware aus der iPhone-Produktion vom letzten Jahr.
Und das verkauft uns Apple gerade als das neue Ding. Und ich verkaufe es natürlich
nur wegen dem Format. Ich will jetzt hier keine Videos drauf machen,
da werbe ich an andere Seite.
Also das ist wirklich alles auf Kante genäht.
Und hier kann niemand einfach kommen wie Trump und sagen, ja klar könnten wir
iPhones in Amerika bauen.
Das kann man sich wünschen und dann kann man Interessen und Werte formulieren
und Kriege anzetteln, Zölle machen, wird nicht passieren.
Also hier steht einfach die Realität der Politik und den Wünschen im Wege.
Neu bei Trump ist auch jetzt hat er China angesprochen er ist jetzt Fan von
Atomwaffen denn wenn Zölle da sind sind wir ja immer mehr so im außenpolitischen
Felde wo die neuen Realisten kommen und sagen,
da ist Krieg dann auch manchmal nur ein kleiner Schritt,
so also neues Fantum Atomwaffen.
Ich habe ein Stück von es. Ich habe es gesagt, es ist ein kleiner Stück, believe es oder nicht.
Wir haben ein... Ich habe die Militär. Ich habe die Militär. Ich habe die Militär.
Und in einem Wissen, ich habe es zu reduzieren, aber ich habe es zu wissen,
wie powerful das Nucleer ist.
Joe, eine bomb... Israel ist weg, aber forget.
Eine bomb kann die ganze East Coast ausziehen. Es ist so bad.
Und ich habe diese Poor Fools talking about our oceans will rise one eighth
of an inch over the next 500 years.
Trump glaubt ja, er geht jetzt einfach zu Putin und Zelensky.
Er kann jetzt noch nicht sagen, was er dann sagen wird, aber er weiß schon,
was er denen dann sagt, damit der Krieg endet.
Ich weiß jetzt auch.
Was er dann sagen wird.
Sonst kriegt ihr beide einen Atombombat.
Genau. Das kann doch nicht wirklich ernsthaft Politik sein. Allerdings von Xi,
er ist weiterhin sehr beeindruckt.
Well, I also think – We're dealing – Joe, we're dealing with the smartest people.
They hate when I say – you know, when the press – when I call President Xi,
they said, he called President Xi brilliant. Well, he's a brilliant guy.
He controls 1.4 billion people with an iron fist. I mean, he's a brilliant guy
whether you like it or not. And they go crazy.
Ja, mit der Iron Fist, also der eisernen Faust, das ist eine interessante Formulierung,
auf die Maggie Haberman eingegangen ist. Und zwar ist Trump hier eigentlich
nochmal in den 70er Jahren und das macht vielleicht auch nochmal dieses Anti-Elitäre deutlich.
Trump erlebt in New York die Demokraten und die Parteibosse der Demokraten,
die fast mafiös sich aufführen,
die wirklich so eine Elite vertreten, die auch mit der, wie es dann immer damals
schon hieß, eisernen Faust handeln.
Das ist etwas, was Trump imponiert und wo er auch merkt, diese eiserne Faust
wird doch manchmal gegen ihn gerichtet.
Und er hat diese Formulierung jetzt einfach aus den 70er Jahren nochmal übernommen
in Bezug auf Xi, aber eigentlich ist das etwas, wo er nochmal….
Wo man deutlich sehen kann, woher er eigentlich kommt. Also er hat dort die
Demokraten erlebt, wie die Platzhirsche auftreten und daraus speist er auch
sein Anti-Establishment.
Und er hat aber auch zugleich großen Respekt davor, wenn Demokraten damals so
aufgetreten sind, weil Macht ihm
immer imponiert, wie ihm jetzt auch Macht imponiert, wenn Xi sie ausführt.
Und dieses Machtdenken ist also nicht eines, das einfach jetzt so entstanden
ist bei Trump oder ist auch nicht eines, das extern ist, wie das ein Applebaum uns nachlegt.
Draußen ist diese hopsche Welt und wir müssen uns dagegen jetzt leider Gottes
zur Wehr setzen, sondern man kann bei Trump eigentlich immer sehen und durch
seine Erfahrungen auch mit den Demokraten, nein, die haben auch die eiserne Faust.
Und das wird auch ziemlich klar in The Apprentice, in dem Film,
dass Trump eigentlich nicht die Ausnahme ist, in Bezug auf seine mediale Erscheinung ganz gewiss.
Aber sein eigentliches Agieren ist ziemlich typisch, auch für eine liberale Demokratie.
Wir haben es ja hier.
Röttger Brechmann.
Die offene Frage, wie kann es zu diesen psychopathischen Verhalten kommen? Wo beginnt es und so?
Ich meine, wenn man verstehen will, wie die nächste Präsidentschaft abläuft,
so wie Trump die GOP regiert.
Ja.
Da kommt er einfach hin und er freut sich ja schon, wenn die Rhetorik alleine schon ausreicht.
Wenn er gar nicht die Faust nur zeigen, statt sie auch auf den Tisch zu schlagen.
Ukraine-Krieg wird jedenfalls ziemlich schnell. Diesen Clip hören wir uns nur
mal an, weil hier sehr genaue Begriffswahl stattfindet.
So let's imagine, let's say you win in November.
What do you do differently and how do you change this course that it seems we
are on for World War III? How do you get us out of Ukraine?
How do you stop what's going on in the Middle East? How do you put a stop to this?
Well, it's a very, to me it's an easy question because I think I can do it easily,
but it's a complex question in the sense that the times change.
Every day changes change.
Wer ist, wer ist, wer ist, wer ist.
Russia is a war machine. Whether you like it or not, it just grinds along, grinds along.
You speak to people like Viktor Orban, he'll tell you.
It's just a big, fat war machine, and that's what's happening.
You look at what's happened to Ukraine.
If I were there, it would have never happened. But what could you do now?
If you get into office in January, what could you do now?
Right now, you would get both of them.
I know both very well. und again, I cannot,
I do not want to tell you for the purpose of looking smart to five people that say,
oh he was great because if I told you exactly what I do I could never make the
deal all I can tell you is that I would meet with Putin and I would meet with
him and I know exactly what I'd say to each one of them and I believe that as
president-elect I would get that war stopped and stopped fast Also als President-Elect.
Das ist diese kurze Zeitphase zwischen Wahl und Ankunft im Amt.
Da hat man also nur die Rhetorik.
Und ich habe ja das Szenario auch schon beschrieben, habe es ja einige jetzt.
Putin wird natürlich auf so einen Frieden eingehen, weil er kriegt dann irgendwelche
Ländereien, wie auch immer.
Trump wird der große Friedenspräsident. Die Antivoken stehen ja auch schon parat.
Und dann, seht ihr, so präsidial, wie er das gemacht hat, er war noch nicht
mal im Amt und schon hatte für Frieden gesorgt.
Netanyahu wird ihm dasselbe Geschenk machen. Also...
Meinst du?
Ja, klar.
Das habe ich bei Netanyahu nicht.
Doch, doch, doch. Das wird hier mit einem großen Bang beginnen.
Der Friedenspräsident würde mich nicht wundern, wenn er dann auch noch den Friedenspreis
des deutschen Buchhandels bekommt.
Das wäre eigentlich schön, oder? Nächstes Jahr Anfang von Donald Trump Friedenspreis
des Deutschen Buchhandels.
Alle wollen sich einschleimen.
Vielleicht zusammen mit Campino, Timothy Snyder und George W.
Bush vielleicht auch nochmal.
Und kein Jugendvertreter. Die sind ja alle an der Front. Gut,
kommen wir zu diesem großen Thema. Ja.
Also ich will nur kurz rekapitulieren. Die Michelle Obama hat eine Rede gehalten,
in der sie einen wichtigen Satz
sagte, nämlich, meine Rede richtet sich an die Männer, die uns lieben.
Und damit war zum einen schon mal Männer adressiert, klar, aber die Männer,
die uns lieben, sind die, die uns im Privaten, in der konkreten Lebenswelt,
ich habe es ja vorhin schon, der raumgebundene, körperliche und so weiter und so fort.
Also es geht sozusagen um eine Argumentation, wo demnächst Politik stattfindet,
wo wir sie eigentlich nicht akzeptieren und auch nur historische Beispiele haben,
wo mal bis unter die Bettdecke regiert wurde.
Und das droht aber jetzt an Amerika, denn so verständlich zum einen aus praktikularem
wirtschaftlichem BWL-Interesse Elon Musks Ideologie bis hierhin war,
der Rest ist erklärungsbedürftig, sag ich mal so,
aber deswegen nicht weniger wirkmächtig.
Also wir hören hier in dieses Gespräch weiter rein. Tucker Carlson spricht mit
Elon Musk und eine Minute lang ist es relativ irre.
Es kommt so George Soros und seine Kollegen und dann stellt Tucker Carlson eine Nachfrage.
But there is this whole system that SARS built up over many decades.
So I guess SARS and like-minded people, whatever, they believe in open borders.
They believe we shouldn't prosecute crime.
This is insane. Those seem like expressions of hatred toward the United States.
If I was pushing that on a country, I would only do that if I hated the country
and wanted to destroy it. Antizivilisational.
Antizivilisational.
Er kämpft jetzt gegen die antizivilisationalen Kräfte.
Was ist in Europa, würde ich sagen? Europa scheint ein anderes Ort zu sehen.
Well, my biggest concern for Europe is that the birth rate is half replacement rate. Yes.
So Europe is rapidly becoming, with each passing year, older and older with
fewer and fewer young people.
Also, Altenrepublik.
Genau. Wir haben jetzt hier eine Figur, die sich irgendwas zum Thema Altenrepublik äußert.
Das sind zu viele alte Leute und so. Also nur was jetzt zu verstehen ist,
das, was wir jetzt hören, ist die Ankerideologie.
Was wir vorher gehört haben, sind einfach partikularistische Ideologien,
die man so hat, um sein Unternehmen voranzutreiben, um das eine oder andere zu erreichen.
Hier, also das Denken, was wir jetzt hören in den nächsten Clips,
ist sozusagen der Anker, der auch Antrieb für diese anderen Ideologien ist.
Also warum sollen wir jetzt die Umwelt ausbeuten und der ganze Kram,
wo man noch vorher eine E-Automarke im Markt platziert hat mit,
ja, bloß das CO2 im Boden lassen und der ganze Kram.
Versteht man ja irgendwie nicht so richtig. Und jetzt wurde hier angesprochen auf Europa.
Ja, da sind die antizivilisatorischen Kräfte besonders am Werkeln.
Nur noch alte Leute, keine jungen Leute mehr und ich möchte erinnern,
wir haben auch bei Jeff Bezos schon gehört wir müssen uns ausbreiten ins Universum,
damit mehr Menschen Platz finden.
10.000 Mozarts.
Genau, damit irgendwo,
Milliarden Menschen dürfen gerne leiden, solange es normale Menschen sind,
aber die 10.000 Mozarts, die hätte ich gerne in meinem Dunstkreis,
um mit denen so Ideen zu besprechen.
So, wir werden dieses Denken hier wiederfinden, aber nochmal sozusagen triftiger
ausformuliert, was mir als Experte von diesem alten republikanischen Thema ein
bisschen Sorgen bereitet, weil hier steckt so eine gewisse Zugkraft drin,
die vor allem einen neuen Blick auf die Frau hat.
Und Elon Musk, wir hören das hier mal, wartet auf ein Buch zum völkischen Suizid so,
die reden jetzt über das Vogue, irgendwas irgendwer sagt, wir sollten mal gendern
oder so also ich finde niemanden, der sagt wir sollten jetzt mal gendern also
meine These ist, es gibt mehr so die Anti-Vogues, das gibt's,
aber so richtig Vogue ist eigentlich niemand, also die Grünen haben jetzt kein,
Gesetzespaket verabschiedet zum Thema, jetzt aber mal bitte gendern.
Was es aber gibt, ist, dass in Hessen die Gendersprache verboten wurde von Boris
Rhein und ich jetzt meiner 14-jährigen Tochter erklären muss,
warum sie es BINI nicht verwenden darf, weil das Punkt Abzüge in der Schule bedeutet.
Wirklich?
Ja, das ist Gesetzeslage in Hessen. In Prüfungsleistungen wird es nicht geduldet,
anders als du darfst Schülerinnen und Schüler schreiben, aber du darfst nicht
einfach Schüler innen schreiben.
Das ist jetzt verboten. Also während die einen bekommen wird,
die regieren in unsere Sprache rein, regieren die anderen wirklich in die Sprache rein.
Wird immer nicht so richtig gesehen, aber ich glaube, es gibt kein Vogue, es gibt nur Anti-Vogue.
Es gibt nichts, was sich gesetzlich manifestiert am Voken.
So weit sind sie nicht gegangen und wollten es vielleicht auch nicht.
Aber ich würde schon sagen, dass es gewisse Kreise gibt, die.
Das sehr stark gemacht haben und quasi über eine Hypermoralisierung dafür gesorgt
haben, dass alle Leute, die sich nicht an neue Sprachregeln oder so etwas halten,
wie zum Beispiel das Jenand, dass die desavouiert werden.
Also das, und damit meine ich aber auch wirklich nur ein paar hundert Leute in der Medienblase,
die das für sich als Ticket erkannt haben, meistens so Karriere,
Moderatorenkarriere oder so ist nicht so ganz geglückt, aber wenn man auf dem
Ticket nochmal ein paar Leute einfangen kann und auf einem Republika-Panel sitzen
kann, hat sich's gelohnt.
Und das sind eher so Leute, die glaube ich da sehr vehement vorgegangen sind,
während ich zum Beispiel sagen würde, und das ist auch sehr stark übrigens Millennials,
weil Millennials so denken, ah vielleicht habe ich doch damals über einen falschen
Witz gelacht, damals bei TV Total oder so, jetzt muss ich aber einiges nochmal gut machen.
Während zum Beispiel meine Erfahrung ist, und ich bewege mich ja in linken Kreisen,
wenn ich an Unis eingeladen werde, dass Leute, die da jetzt studieren, die 2021 sind,
viel entspannter mit all dem umgehen und gar nicht in diesen Kulturkampf hinein wollen.
Das ist eher was für Ende-30-Jährige, die in Berlin-Mitte ein schlechtes Gewissen
haben und aber noch einen Podcast-Vertrag brauchen.
Genau, was bedeutet, das findet sozusagen auf zivilem Felde statt,
es nervt, aber es ist jetzt nicht wirklich wohl.
Es gibt ja jetzt diesen Film mit Jan-Josef Liefers, Alte weiße Männer,
da wird das dann auch nochmal alles durchgekackert, aber eigentlich läuft es
dann auf so ein, also der Film ist nicht gut, aber das läuft dann auf so ein,
naja, aber am Ende haben wir uns alle lieb und ist doch auch egal und ich glaube,
das ist natürlich die eigentliche Rezeptionsweise, nur wie das dann begann,
hat natürlich die Zeit, CDU, du hast es ja mal sehr gut als Taliban-Politik beschrieben, erkannt.
Okay, wir können nichts anbieten, wir werden keine Straße mehr bauen,
wir werden auch mit der Bahn nichts, wir haben nichts, aber wir können irgendwelche
Verbote durchsetzen und sagen,
du bekommst kein Euro mehr, im Gegenteil, du wirst deinem Vermieter noch mehr
zahlen müssen, aber gendern brauchst du nicht.
Das ist das Versprechen, das die CDU bieten kann und deswegen kann natürlich,
egal was von links kommt,
auch wenn sie jetzt ständig das Gegenteil machen, die CDU hat das ja einfach
für sich als Thema erkannt.
Die CDU will ja nicht sagen, ach so, das war doch alles ein bisschen übertrieben
oder die haben davon jetzt Abstand genommen, deswegen ist das nicht mehr ein Problem für uns.
Also die Grünen können jeden Tag fünf Bratwürste essen, danach wird ja Söder
nicht sagen, ach so, die essen jetzt genauso wie ich auch Würste,
was auf Teufel komm raus, dann ist doch wieder gut.
Sondern der braucht ja dieses Feindbild, Merz braucht ja dieses Feindbild und
Elon Musk hat mal mit drei Woken Aktivisten eine schlechte Erfahrung gemacht,
wahrscheinlich auch nicht mal er selbst, sondern er hat es irgendwo gesehen
bei Twitter, dass es das gibt und er braucht das ja jetzt einfach als Feindbild,
das heißt er will ja gar nicht von einer anderen Realität überzeugt werden.
Ja, genau. Ja, also Vogue, ja, kann nerven, aber kann man auch ignorieren.
Aber Gespräche zum Gendern finden zu 99,9 Prozent von Anti-Voken statt,
die sich über Gendern aufregen.
So, das kann man leider nicht ignorieren, weil die Gesetze schreiben.
Genau.
Was ein ernsthaftes Problem ist, denn wenn meine Tochter gerne ein BIN-E verwendet,
ist mir das total egal. Wenn es ihr verboten wird, ist es mir nicht egal.
Und da sieht man ja auch wieder, dass die angeblichen Verteidiger der liberalen
Freiheit gar keine Verteidiger sind.
Sie sind ja, also wenn Free Speech ja bedeutet Free Speech, dann ist ja auch
das Binnen-I erlaubt. Im Übrigen auch, wir werden ja heute noch sehr ausführlich
über Nahost-Israel, Libanon, Gaza sprechen.
Auch da ist ja interessant, dass die, die die ganze Zeit Free Speech bei Twitter
einfordern, am liebsten jede palästina-solidarische Demonstration verbieten würden.
Das ist Elon Musk, Handwerk, Twitter kaufen als Free Speech Arena und dann jeden Scheiß da wegkloppen,
irgendwie das Publikum an die türkische Regierung auszuverkaufen und gleichzeitig
deren Hashtags plattformweit zu verbieten.
Also das geht einfach nicht. Das ist sozusagen, da ist diese Verdrehung.
Und jetzt hören wir Elon Musk, der dieses Denken gern weiter treiben möchte,
erwartet auf ein Buch und wendet sich hier gegen den Vogue-Virus,
den ich ja jetzt versucht habe, hoffentlich auch bei allen,
HörerInnen erfolgreich auszutrainieren.
Es bewegt wie ein Virus. Es infectet Menschen und macht es wahrscheinlich unmöglich,
dass sie rationales machen. Was ist das Virus?
Ich meine, der redet jetzt mit ungetretenen Vorzeichen über sein eigenes Schicksal.
Er hat da diesen einen Sohn, der eine Tochter wurde oder eine Tochter,
die ein Sohn wurde, ich weiß es selbst nicht mehr.
Und er kann das nicht verkraften. Er hält es nicht aus, dass seine Identität
von ich schmeiße meinen Samen überall hin und hoffe, dass 17 Kinder alle drei Jahre rauskommen,
dass es nicht nach seinem Gunsten ging, obwohl er null Zeit investiert hat in
diese Sozialisation dieses Nachwuchses.
Und redet jetzt so über, aber die anderen, die anderen, die anderen.
I have oh you have yes, oh I should watch that actually he's great yeah smart
super smart guy yeah and he He wrote a great book Called the parasitic mind.
Yes a very good book highly recommend it. Yes, which where he tries to understand
How do you get to this parasitic mind situation?
And he's writing a book now, which hopefully will publish soon um,
which is about suicidal empathy, where you have so much empathy,
you're actually suiciding society, uh, or so much perceived empathy.
Uh, it's not actually it's called shallow empathy, not deep empathy,
deep empathy would be you'd want the society to continue.
Uh, shallow empathy is you have like empathy.
That's essentially skin deep. And then you, and, and you don't,
it's, but it's ultimately bad for civilization and results in the destruction of civilization.
Was ist das jetzt für eine Idee?
Es gibt irgendwie so, also dass die beiden überhaupt über Empathie reden,
finde ich schon bescheuert. Also es ist wirklich bescheuert.
Jetzt gibt es diese Idee von richtiger Empathie. Du kümmerst dich um deinen
Nächsten, Nächstenlieber, wie auch immer, deine Familienangehörigen.
Und wenn jeder vor seiner eigenen Türe und so weiter, dann ist für alle gesorgt.
Dann gibt es diese falsche Empathie. Du kümmerst dich mehr um die Leute,
die offensichtlich Hilfe brauchen, weil sie Deviant sind.
Ah, der Migrant, ah, der Arme und so.
Bei J.D. Vance. J.D. Vance hat ja so ein ganz mitleidvolles Buch geschrieben.
Mit seiner Großmutter sollen wir Mitleid haben mit seiner Mutter.
Aber wir sollen jetzt bitte nicht Mitleid haben mit der sozialen Situation in den USA.
Denn das sind die Leute, die bekommen ihre Lebensmittelgutscheine und haben iPhones gleichzeitig.
Und genau darum geht es, dass das die Gesellschaft zerstört.
Dieses falsche Mitleid, das sich auf alle ausbreitet.
Er wendet sich gegen so eine Art von Ethno-Empathie, dass du deine eigenen Leute
vergisst, weil du dich zu viel für die anderen einsetzt, weil irgendwelche Leute
mit einem Vogue-Virus infiziert in den Medien sagen, die brauchen jetzt Hilfe.
Und dann kümmerst du dich plötzlich nur noch um die armen Ausländer,
die armen Kinder und verlierst deine Oma aus dem Blick.
Und das ist antizivilisatorisch.
Ein Empathieprotektionismus.
Genau, es ist im Grunde fordernd die Empathieprotektionismus.
Jetzt hat er angesprochen, mit wem du mal Interview führen solltest, ist dieser Gad Saad.
Und jetzt hat er einfach gesagt, da habe ich, ganz kluger Typ.
Ich habe dann kurz nachgeguckt, wer ist dieser Gadsad, denn ich will ja auch
wissen, wen halten die für klug?
Gadsad, also G-A-D-S-A-A-D, Gadsad, hat einen eigenen Podcast.
Der heißt The Zad Truth.
Ganz lustig. So, wir hören jetzt die vorletzte Ausgabe.
Er hat natürlich auch den Mediensturm um den Madison Square Garden Auftritt
und so weiter mitbekommen.
Wir hören jetzt den ganzen Podcast, die ganze Podcast-Ausgabe dazu.
Sie geht zwei Minuten 14. Er sitzt einfach vor seiner Kamera und redet mit YouTube.
Und ich weiß es einfach nicht glauben konnte, was für eine Argumentation uns
jetzt als, das ist ein ganz kluger Typ, der dann von sich noch meint,
ich habe jetzt was mitzuteilen, das muss ich jetzt unbedingt der Welt mitteilen.
Und diese zwei Minuten hören wir uns jetzt an.
Hi everybody, this is Gadsad. Many super smart, noble progressives,
many of whom are my colleagues.
Hier hört man schon, Professor und Doktors, die sind aber nicht wirklich Professor,
die sind auf der falschen Seite.
Das ist ein sehr guter Case, dass Donald Trump ist, literally, Hitler.
For example, yesterday's rally at Madison Square Garden, you know who else held
rallies like this? Hitler.
And so they're able to take a particular phenomenon, demonstrate that it applies
both for Hitler and Trump, and...
And then argue that this demonstrates that they're one and the same.
So I had to, being someone who's very introspective, I stopped for a minute
and I said, look, I've heard that in the past Adolf Hitler had an affinity for
German Shepherds, and there are even photos of him playing very nicely with his German Shepherds.
As some of you know, I am a big lover of Belgian Shepherds.
Und als ich erkläre auf Social Media, since Belgium ist nicht ein reales Land,
dann Belgian Shepherds können unsurped unter der Banner der German Shepherds.
So think about es für ein second.
You haben Hitler, der ist mit German Shepherds. Und dann haben wir Gad,
der mit Belgian Shepherds, die sind wirklich, wink, wink, German Shepherds,
seit Belgium ist nicht ein Land.
Coincidence? Hitler had some facial hair, he had a little mustache I have facial hair.
Hitler had a mother, I have a mother. Hitler wore pants, I wear pants.
Hitler would eat food every day. Every single day I eat food.
Now think about it, how many I just gave you.
These are all, I don't want, I don't think I'm Hitler. Maybe I'm Jewish Hitler.
But the commonalities are uncanny. And by the way, the people who are making
these types of arguments are professors.
In eight days, there's an important vote in the United States.
Vote carefully. Cheers, everybody.
Genial. Ich sag dir jetzt.
Was ich daran wirklich genial finde. Ich meine, inhaltlich ist natürlich...
Dass das geht, dass man...
Aber was wir hier gesehen haben, Elon Musk sagt auch immer, die Zivilisation,
also dieses, wie hieß nochmal, wir haben doch das Buch auch gelesen,
diese Ideologie dahinter, diese entfernte Zukunft, Long-Term-Missen.
Dieses Long-Term-Missen-artige, die ganze Zivilisation. tausend Mozarts.
Nicht ein Mozart, sondern die Einzigartigkeit von Mozart ist schon aufgehoben, tausend Mozarts.
Wenn man die ganze Zeit mit einem Milliardenvermögen nur über die Menschheit
hinwegfliegt, sich alles kommen lässt und niemals mehr an einem normalen zivilisatorischen
Prozess wie einem Einkauf, einem Sport,
irgendwo in einem Verein oder was weiß ich nachgeht.
Wenn man seine eigene Familie nicht mehr sieht, weil man einfach völlig den
Überblick verloren hat.
Ach 17 Kinder, ich hatte ja so eine Ideologie von, ich zeuge einfach überall
Kinder und dann Ich kenne die ja gar nicht, wer sind denn die,
die sind für mich gestorben und solche Sachen, ja.
Dann unterscheidet man natürlich nicht mehr zwischen Menschen und Menschen.
Dann ist einfach nur noch die Zivilisation.
Und dann kommt man zu so einem Denken, dass man einfach sagt,
ganz klug abgeleitet jetzt.
Hitler hatte zwei Beine, ich habe zwei Beine. Und der Titel dieses Podcasts lautet, Am I Hitler?
Und der reichste Mann der Welt und der reichweitenstärkste Mann Amerikas reden
darüber, dass das ein kluger Typ ist, mit dem man ja mal reden müsste und dann
sagt der andere, hab ich schon, voll der geniale Typ.
Wir werden zum Ausgang dieses Podcasts noch etwas über Superreiche hören,
sie haben ein neues Hotel bekommen und wir werden uns Das ist gut.
Was Superreiche brauchen ist ein weiteres Hotel.
Ja, mit ganz tollen Restaurants. Jedenfalls will ich schon mal diese These vorweg
nehmen, dass die, das intellektuelle Niveau der Leute, die Geld haben,
ist so rapide gesunken über die vergangenen Jahrzehnte.
Ich will jetzt die nicht glorifizieren in der Vergangenheit.
Aber wenn man sieht, was sie zum Teil unterstützt haben, wir werden da gleich
mal drauf kommen, ja, wenn man sieht, was dann durchaus auch mit Reichtum einherging,
nämlich, dass man umfassend gebildet sein konnte, nicht alle aber konnte.
Und dass man jetzt Superreiche hat, die irgendwelche dusseligen Heinis sich
da anhören, die sagen ja, Hitler hat
einen Schäferhund, wer hat noch einen Schäferhund, der ist auch Hitler.
Also wer sowas macht, wer glaubt, in Tucker Carlson einen guten Gesprächspartner zu finden.
Da muss man doch sagen, wir sind verloren. Ja, wir sind wirklich verloren.
Es gibt nichts mehr dort irgendwo an Bildung, an Geist oder so.
Was wir tun, wir können Milliardäre nicht abschaffen. Wir können aber diesen
falschen Respekt vor Milliardären abschaffen.
Und der muss einfach, wenn ihr einen Milliardär seht...
Die können auch nicht 50 iPhones für sich kaufen. Das iPhone ist so konzipiert,
wenn deins kaputt geht und du musst es auf ein neues umziehen,
das macht einfach Arbeit. Also es macht keinen Sinn, zwei iPhones zu haben.
WhatsApp, du kannst nur auf einer Nummer, also eine Nummer pro Telefon und so weiter.
Das heißt, die Möglichkeiten eines Milliardären sind wirklich limitiert.
Das Einzige, was er hat, ist Transportation. Er kann halt einfach überall so hinfliegen.
Sich Palmen in echt angucken, an diesem Strand stehen, an dem wir alle gerne
stehen würden. Aber das war's.
Alles weitere, ja, das sind halt so Delegationsbefehle. Da würde ich sagen,
wir geben dem Ganzen noch zwei Jahre, dann hat jeder, das wird jetzt mal so
von Agentik, weißt du, du kriegst ja dein AI-Companion, wir werden im Salon
ausführlich in der KS darüber reden.
Ich würde sagen, wir simulieren uns alle mal eine parallele Welt herbei,
die wir einfach delegieren können die ganze Zeit.
So Sims-Spielen, so dieses Open-World-artige, es wird einfach die ganze Zeit so generiert.
Und dieses Gefühl zu haben, Chef von hunderttausend Leuten zu sein,
die in einem Bergwerk, was auch immer, die Welt ausrauben,
es macht glaube ich keinen Unterschied, ob man das wirklich,
wie bei Enders Game, diesem Film, ob man den Krieg jetzt wirklich führt oder
im Computerspiel, dem Gehirn ist das wirklich egal. Also du kannst es physio- nicht.
Ablesen im Gehirn, ob das gerade ein Thrill ist durch echte Schicksale oder halt ein Spiel.
Von daher simuliert euch alle die Welt eines Millionärs auf Zuruf werden einfach Befehle ausgeführt,
so wie ich das höre sitzt ja so ein Milliardär sowieso nur da und sagt so machten
sie das mal und dann macht man halt irgendwas und der kommt nie wieder drauf
zurück um zu fragen haben sie es jetzt erledigt oder so es war einfach nur so
ein Impuls halt so reingepromptet in die Welt und.
Das wurde ja selbst dann von den Assistenten beschrieben von Lagerfeld,
dass Lagerfeld immer so Einkaufstouren macht.
Dann hat Lagerfeld auf Dinge gezeigt, die wurden eingepackt,
die hätte natürlich dann nie mehr auspacken können, weil was soll denn das alles
sein? Genau, es ist alles virtuell.
Dieser Reichtum führt zu nichts, aber zu Verderben.
Diesen Film Cosmopolis mit Robert Pattinson,
dort hatte er ja eigentlich nur die Idee mit der Limousine zum Friseur zu fahren
in New York und da gibt es einen kleinen Stau und es gibt auch dann Demonstrationen
und da verbrennt sich draußen jemand,
also zündet sich an und seine Cheftheoretikerin sitzt mit ihm im Auto und sagt,
das ist nicht die Realität.
Also das ist nur als virtuelles wahrzunehmen.
Es ist einfach, ja, es macht am Ende keinen Unterschied, ob man jetzt wirklich
eine Milliarde hat oder ein Computerspiel spielt.
Gut, bleiben wir beim roten Faden. Also, dieses ganze Nazi-artige,
die Nazis haben ja auch schon mal bis unter die Bettdecke regiert,
muss jetzt erstmal ausgeschlossen werden, das macht natürlich auch Elon Musk,
denn was, also mein neuer Chefe soll ein Nazi sein, der hat doch gar nichts damit zu tun.
Trump would never support Nazis, Nazi rally, it's absurd.
And he explicitly said in that same speech that you must condemn anyone who
has Nazi tendencies in the strongest possible terms.
And yet, despite knowing that to be false, the people who wrote the speech for
the Kamala Poppet put the fine people hoax in the presidential debate.
Deliberately lying. Again.
Best up. If she wins, I mean, how can they let X continue in its current form,
in its current role in American society?
They won't. They will try to shut it down by any means possible.
Das meandert so bescheuert rum. Ich habe jetzt diesen Klotz im Nachhinein,
wo ich das selber wieder höre.
Also, nächste Woche entscheidet sich das Schicksal Twitters,
weil wenn die Demokraten gewinnen, werden sie X-Trashen.
Ich meine, Twitter hat er für 45 Milliarden Dollar gekauft.
Ganz ohne eine demokratische Einflussnahme ist der Wert auf unter 10 Milliarden
gesunken, weil da niemand mehr irgendwas macht ökonomisch.
Es gibt keine Unternehmen mehr, die Werbung schalten.
Also wenn jemand Twitter getrashed hat, dann ja wohl Elon Musk,
Und jetzt sagt er, die werden da reingehen, weil Twitter ist ja so und so.
Aber vorher, also das hat alles nichts mit Nazis zu tun.
Da würde ich auch sagen, ja, stimmt soweit,
wenn es ist neonazistisch und das benutzt man dann auch nur als Erklärungsfolie
für, weil es gibt derzeit nicht, die Zehnjährigen sind die größte Gruppe und
die kann man organisieren, hat man eine Hitlerjugend und später eine SA oder
was auch immer. Also dieses Szenario droht nicht.
So, was auch bedeutet, ich will es ganz deutlich sagen, weil wir jetzt nochmal
einen Clip zum Wognis hören.
Und ich habe in meinem eigenen Bekanntenkreis Leute, die es nicht mehr schaffen,
Einnahmen eines Regierungsmitglieds oder irgendwen zu nennen,
ohne nochmal davor zu schreiben, dass die aber faschistoid sind.
Ah ja.
Ja, also dieser Begriff faschistoid. Kamala Harris sagt, Trump ist Nazi.
Nee, das macht sie eigentlich gar nicht. Sie wurde jetzt einmal gefragt,
nachdem John Kelly, sein eigener Stabschef, gesagt hat, Trump ist ein Faschist.
Und zwar auch erst, nachdem, als die Frage aufkam, würden sie sagen, Trump ist ein Faschist.
Hat John Kelly erstmal ausführlich erklärt, was das bedeutet, Faschist zu sein.
Auf Trump kam er erst fünf Minuten später zu sprechen. Dann wurde Harris einmal
gefragt, würden sie sagen, Trump ist ein Faschist.
Und hat sie ganz überzeugend gesagt, ja, würde ich sagen.
Das war jetzt ein Ereignis, dass ansonsten im Umfeld irgendwer mit solchen Nazi-Sachen
kommt. Okay, aber auch hier wieder.
Diejenigen, die vor allem alles für faschistoid erklären, sind die Antivoken.
Das ist der Vorwurf aus der Trump-Richtung den anderen gegenüber und nicht,
dass Trump die ganze Zeit unterstellt wird, er sei ein Faschist.
Das kam es durch John Kelly einmal auch bei Kamala Harris an. Okay, Haken dran.
Sie hat es gesagt, sie wurde konkret gefragt. Sie hat Ja gesagt statt Nein.
Ist ja auch richtig so. Und fertig.
Ja, also diese Vokeness und so weiter. So, und jetzt hier wird das mal...
Sozusagen ins Verhältnis gesetzt. Der Vogue-Virus, sagt jetzt Elon Musk, ist eine neue Religion.
Bevor wir das jetzt hören, möchte ich sagen, der Vogue-Virus ist keine neue
Religion, sondern das sind einfach Leute, die sich dafür entscheiden,
ihr Leben auf bestimmte Weise zu führen und, wie ich jetzt ausdrücklich sage,
damit nicht missionieren.
Ich erlebe keinen Vegetarier mehr, der mir erklärt, dass es ja viel besser ist,
ein Vegetarier. Das gibt es seit zehn Jahren nicht mehr, das Phänomen.
Das ist so eine Legende von früher, dass ja die Vegetarier alle rummissionieren.
Nee, die sitzen einfach im Restaurant und fragen, haben sie auch was Vegetarieres?
Dann sagt der Kellner, dann sagt er, okay, dann nehme ich das. Fertig. Das war's.
Darin steckt keine Mission, darin steckt keine Religion, darin steckt einfach
nur jemand, der für sich eine Entscheidung getroffen hat, ich will mein Vitamin
B12 von woanders her haben.
So, das war's, ja. Elon Musk macht jetzt aber plötzlich so eine Religion der anderen daraus.
Ich glaube, dass du völlig recht hast und trotzdem ist es ja so,
dass man, wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel sich ansieht,
wie Disney so sich öffentlich verkauft, wie dann so eine Agenda gelauncht wird.
Und wir erinnern uns aber auch an das Amazon Playbook, wie jetzt da Filme produziert
werden können, wo man also plötzlich festschreiben will, welche Identität,
welche Schauspieler für welche Rolle haben müssen.
Da findet ja dann schon eine solche Festsetzung statt, das hat jetzt nichts
mit Religion zu tun, sondern man setzt also plötzlich eine Norm an,
die sich jeder halten soll.
Natürlich gab es vorher auch Normen, an die man sich gehalten hat oder an die
man sich nicht gehalten hat oder die man unterminiert hat.
Hat man jetzt so eine ganz andere Richtung plötzlich.
Also früher haben Künstler versucht, eigentlich gegen offizielle Normen vorzugehen
und haben diese infrage gestellt.
Jetzt aber werden Künstler immer mehr zu den Verteidigern von Normen,
von institutionellen Regeln, wie zum Beispiel dann so ein Amazon Playbook,
nicht mehr kritisiert wird von Filmen machen, weil sie wissen,
oh Gott, ich muss ja vielleicht doch mit dem Streaming-Service-Primer zusammenzuarbeiten.
Und ich habe das ja damals, als ich das kritisiert habe, bei Twitter waren da
so Leute, die heute beim Kinderkanal eine Sendung machen oder irgendwie mit
Joko einen Podcast, die sich dann darüber geärgert haben, dass ich das kritisiert habe.
Naja, die Tatsache ist ja, die wollen ja weiterhin ihre Jobs haben.
Und wenn man ab morgen bei Amazon und auf irgendeiner Konferenz verkündet,
dass wir uns mit IA begrüßen, sagen die auch IA, weil sie Esel sind.
Und da würde ich sagen, gibt es das schon. Es gibt da eine unglaubliche Konformität.
Es gibt dort einen Anpassungsdruck und aber auch einen Anpassungswillen,
weil man irgendwie dazugehören will.
Das hat aber keinerlei Auswirkungen auf das Alltägliche.
Also Leute, die irgendwo in die Bäckerei gehen, bei Edeka einkaufen oder normal
im Büro sitzen, wenn sie jetzt nicht gerade in der Compliance-Abteilung von
Disney arbeiten, haben natürlich damit überhaupt keine Berührung.
Sie lesen es nur auf.
Hübsch dann und aufgepusht von Welt- und Bild-Zeitung und sagen,
ach Gott, man darf ja gar nichts mehr sagen. Und das ist natürlich nicht der Fall.
Genau. Es hat Auswirkungen auf diesen künstlerischen Betrieb,
weil der hängt von diesen Budgetentscheidungen ab.
Beim Theater gibt es schon sehr, sehr verrückte Bestrebungen,
auch in der freien Szene oder so.
Da würden wir in 100 Jahren keinen Auftrag bekommen. Hier zwei.
Aber relativ viel auf freiem Markt verfügbares läuft halt unter Marktforschung.
Und wenn der Zeitgeist ist, dass, und das wird halt übersehen,
wir gehen ja gleich intensiv in dieses Thema.
Wenn einfach 80 Prozent der jungen Frauen sagen, ich will keinen Film sehen,
in dem es gewalttätig zugeht, dann können das 80 Prozent der Frauen für sich sagen.
Ohne, dass sie jetzt unbedingt da vorher in den Selbsthilfekreis, wo das besprochen wird.
Aber ist das so, dass Frauen keine gewalttätigen Filme sehen wollen?
Naja, also du hast auf jeden Fall ein Phänomen, das so übersehen wird,
wie zum Beispiel Frauen nach Dunkelheit auf der Straße, wie fühlen die sich eigentlich?
Frauen in Fitnessstudios, Frauen und was wird ihnen medial sozusagen vorgesetzt,
wenn sie auch mal mit ihrem Freund ins Kino gehen wollen,
finden sie eigentlich kaum gemeinsame Filme, weil es dann doch in der,
was ist so eigentlich akzeptabel, der eine hat so die Sehgewohnheit,
ich spiele den ganzen Tag Call of Duty und die anderen kommen halt aus einer
anderen Richtung und dann gibt es da sozusagen wenig Überschneidungspunkte.
Aber das regelt doch der Markt.
Genau, das ist nämlich der Punkt. Wenn eine Angebotsseite nach einer Marktforschung
sagt, Disney-Filme sind jetzt so und so.
Dann wird immer das Publikum beschimpft, weil die ja alle so Vogue-Virus-infiziert sind.
Ja, das ist ja unsinnig.
Genau, man muss dann wirklich ganz konkret bei den Playbook zum Beispiel.
Aber Disney macht ja eine falsche Marktforschung. Also Disney glaubt ja,
man müsste die Filme, die gelernt und gemocht werden, jetzt nochmal nachdrehen
in einer Vogue-Version.
Und da haben weder die Fans Freude dran, noch die Neuen.
Also man müsste ja dann neue Geschichten erzählen. Während wir jetzt zum Beispiel
bei den Streaming-Plattformen das wunderbar sehen, was du da beschreibst,
Nämlich, dass einfach die Gesellschaft sich verändert hat, beziehungsweise,
dass sobald die technischen Möglichkeiten da sind,
nicht mehr einfach nur Komödien mit zwei weißen Leuten geguckt werden,
sondern plötzlich haben Filme aus Korea einen riesen Anklang,
in dem nicht eine einzige bekannte Schauspielerin oder Schauspieler auftaucht.
Das heißt, wir sehen da ja eine ganz, ganz radikale Veränderung in den Sehgewohnheiten,
die aber einfach durch das Angebot da ist und nicht, weil das irgendjemand aufoktroyiert hat.
Und ja, beim Kino ist es immer noch ein bisschen schwerer, weil es nur begrenzte
Säle gibt, nur begrenzte Produktionen gibt.
Und da versucht man sich immer auf so einen Minimalkonsens zu einigen und unter
dem hat man ja in vielerlei Hinsicht zu leiten,
du sprichst hier mit mir, das ist ja meine große Tragödie, dass ich laufend
diese Marvel-Filme gucken muss, die mögen zwar diverse oder sonst was sein,
sie sind aber trotzdem alle scheiße.
Es ist auf vielen Ebenen scheiße und dann soll man sich nicht einen Punkt rauspicken,
auf den man identitätspolitisch gerne besonders draufhaut, weil das angeblich
etwas über die anderen sagt, für die die Filme gemacht sind oder was auch immer.
Sieht man jetzt auch, weil du das Playbook angesprochen hast,
da steckt Amazon dahinter und hinter Amazon steht Jeff Bezos als Mehrheitseigner.
Kann man jetzt Jeff Bezos unterstellen, er hat da so eine super Vogue-Agenda,
die ja über so ein Playbook dann irgendwie, scheint irgendwie inkonsistent zu
sein mit so einer Entscheidung, die Washington Post.
Ich glaube, da gibt es so Verselbstständigungen in Etagen, wo einfach Leute,
die so sozialisiert sind, die haben gewisse Dinge studiert und gewisse New York
Times Kolumnen gelesen, dass sie das dann so übermäßig da reinklingen.
Das finden wir auch beim öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehen.
Es passiert ja nicht, dass man einfach eine Serie macht, die divers besetzt
ist und dann muss die sich als gute Serie erweisen oder sie ist eine schlechte
Serie, sondern man muss dann 41 Interviews geben.
Die Kulturzenten macht wahrscheinlich drei Sondersendungen. wir haben alle identitätspolitischen
Dinge berücksichtigt und für uns war das wichtig, dass wir auch mit Betroffenen,
weißt du, diese ganzen Interviews und dann der Fernsehpreis,
richtet dann auch nochmal ein Fest denen aus, dass sie so divers gewesen sind.
Da muss man einfach sagen, macht eine gute Serie, Punkt.
Also bei, genau, auf organisationalen Ebene, sage ich, gibt es ein Vogue-Virus.
Weil man sich dort einfach imaginiert für den Chef und dann macht man so eine,
Unterwachung, eine Beschlussverlage schon mal vorzubereiten,
in der Hoffnung das und dann überzieht man den Bogen und dann ist eine Budgetentscheidung getroffen.
Nur das hat keine gesellschaftliche Relevanz, weil es kein Phänomen darstellt.
So wie man dann auch sagen muss, liebe Antivoke, die euch darüber aufregt,
Wartet doch einfach ab, wie der Markt entscheidet und macht euch dann lustig über das Playbook.
Nur du hast, finde ich, das Recht, dich über das Playbook lustig zu machen,
weil du ja alle Filme unter so einer kritischen Beobachtung und dann natürlich
auch die Manufaktur, ist ja völlig logisch.
Nur Filme sind mir eigentlich egal, aber jetzt, wo dieses Playbook da ist,
hole ich mal meinen identitätspolitischen Antivokehammer raus und hau da auch noch drauf.
Ja, das ist diese Haltung, für mich müssen Filme unpolitisch sein.
Ja, sie gucken sich sowas wie Independence Day an und meinen,
das sei ein unpolitischer Film, aber wenn ein Konzern entscheidet,
dass die Hauptdarstellerin Südafrikanerin ist, ja jetzt geht's aber los,
jetzt muss ich mich nochmal einmischen.
Und natürlich ist kein Film unpolitisch und jede Entscheidung ist politisch.
Und jetzt hören wir diesen Clip, wie er über das Vogue-Virus als Religion spricht.
Und wir müssen es jetzt im Kopf einen Schritt weiter denken.
Er redet über sich selber, wie sehr das Anti-Vogue-Sein bei ihm religiöse Züge annimmt.
Also sozusagen Ursprünge und so mythologische Ursprünge hat die er selber nicht
mehr hinterfragt, die jetzt einfach orthodox, paradigmatisch in den Raum gestellt werden.
Ein Atheismus zur Religion wird, ja.
Also zum Beispiel, aber es gibt auch eine Clips, wo er sich auch so als religiöser
Typ darstellt, weil er kann jetzt nicht den Trump-Elan erklären,
dass er nicht religiös ist oder sowas, ne?
Gut, also bevor wir also auf die Rolle der Frau in der hypermodernen Gesellschaft
zu sprechen kommen, hier nochmal, in welchem Maße er einfach religiöses Denken
jetzt, aber den anderen unterstellen, aber wir unterstellen es ihm einfach. Ja.
Ich glaube, ein Teil davon ist, ist die Decline der Religion.
So, wie die Sagen geht, Natur abhors die Vacuum.
Wenn man eine Decline in Religion hat und eine Veränderung in der secularen Natur.
So, er unterstellt jetzt über das Vogue-Virus eine Religion,
von der wir sagen, diese integrationale Kraft gibt es gar nicht,
Denn auch publizistisch korreliert das ja sehr mit diesen neuen Büchern zum Thema das Individuum,
die granulare Gesellschaft und so weiter und so fort. Ja, also dieser ganze Kram.
So, was wir jetzt aber verstehen müssen, inwieweit sie selber Sachen zu einer Religion überhöhen.
Und Religion sind privates Konzept. Das hat in der modernen Gesellschaft nichts zu suchen.
Und deswegen ja auch, es gibt es in Deutschland schon wieder,
dass sich ein grüner Bundestagsabgeordneter darüber aufregt,
dass der Saal, in dem er tagen soll, mit seinem Ausschuss ein Kreuz in der Ecke hängen hat.
Jetzt gibt es Streit darüber, ist das ein religiöses Kreuz oder ist es ein Kunstwerk,
weil es ist ja auch aus Eisen gestaltet und wie auch immer.
Muss er es also akzeptieren oder nicht sagen, wenn es ein Kreuz ist,
dann kann er das durchaus mal sagen, dass er da nichts zu tun hat,
weil wir leben in einer säkularisierten Gesellschaft.
Bevor wir jetzt ins Gespräch weiterhören, Tucker Carlson selbst ist ja auch
problematisch. Es ist ja nicht nur Elon Musk.
Tucker Carlson bespielt ja ein Publikum.
Wir wollen jetzt also mal hören, wie Tucker Carlson einen Brückenschlag aus
den privaten, intimen Sphärenfamilie zur Politik macht.
Und das Szenario ist wie folgt, er steht auf einer Bühne, ich weiß nicht mal
wo, ich habe den Clip gesehen, habe gesagt, das kann nicht wahr sein,
habe Huhmann gesagt, schick mir den mal, Huhmann hat mir geschickt.
Ich habe nur den Anfang jetzt weggenommen, wo er so beschreibt,
wenn zu Hause die zweijährige Tochter ihre Windel an die Wand schmeißt,
dann ignorieren wir das als Eltern nicht.
Da fragen wir so, zweijährige Kinder mit einer Windel vollgeschissen.
Also irgendwann kann man ja auch mal windelfrei sein.
Oder wenn die Tochter gepierst nach Hause kommt. Also es geht ja ganz konkret
um familiäre Situationen, die er gerne lösen möchte.
Mit Mitteln, die er danach auch in der Politik verwenden möchte.
Wir hören das jetzt ausführlich. Das geht drei Minuten lang.
Taka Karlsson auf der Bühne. Das Publikum jubelt. Wir versuchen jetzt zu verstehen,
was steckt da noch dahinter.
Er hat Spaß an der Performance. Das hören wir. Aber es steckt doch auch eine
Ideologie dahinter. Ein Brückenschlag, der eigentlich unzulässig ist und so weiter.
Also, Szenario, er auf der Bühne, das Kind hat sich nicht gut verhalten und dann.
Es muss ein Punkt sein, an dem Vater kommt nach Hause.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Vater kommt nach Hause. Ja.
Und er ist Pissed. Dad ist Pissed.
Er ist nicht Vengeful. Er liebt seine Kinder.
Er liebt seine Kinder. Er liebt sie. Denn sie sind Kinder, sie leben in seinem
Haus. Aber er ist sehr disappointed in ihre Behaviour.
Und er wird sie müssen wissen. Er wird sie in deinem Raum, jetzt.
Und denken über was du getan hast.
Und wenn Dad kommt, du wisst ihr was? Und er sagt, dass du eine schlechte Frau bist.
Du bist eine schlechte Frau und du bist ein vigorous Spanker. Und jetzt.
Und es ist nicht mehr, dass es mich mehr, als es mich verletzt wird.
Nein, es ist nicht. Ich bin nicht zu lief. Es wird dir viel mehr,
als es mich verletzt wird. Und du...
Also jetzt ist er schon auf dem Trip, dass man jetzt wieder Kinder schlagen
soll und es soll auch wieder so ein Klima herrschen, oh Gott,
der Vater kommt nach Hause, das gibt Ärger.
Wie man sich das gute alte Patriarchat vorstellt.
Und ohne es Aber die Dinge zerbrechen. Die Demokratische Maschine,
und notice, ich bin nicht auf Kamala Harris, es ist nur eine hapless victim,
die da in der richtige Farbe ist, also sie holten.
Tim Walz, sie brauchten was Tim Walz ist.
Sie brauchten einen weckeren Mann, weil es die Partei von weckeren Männern und unhapplen Frauen ist.
Eine von denen führt.
Also unhappy woman, weak man, das hängt miteinander zusammen,
das eine führt zum anderen.
Kamala Harris is just a stand-in, she's a cardboard cut-out.
I mean, you know, she has a soul, God created her, I'm not attacking her for humanity.
But there's nothing there, it doesn't matter. If it wasn't Kamala Harris,
it would be, I don't know, Pete Buttigieg, or whatever, you know,
who are these people? It doesn't matter.
Wir fassen zusammen, schwache Männer sorgen dafür, dass es unglückliche Frauen gibt.
Unglückliche Frauen sorgen dafür, dass es schwache Männer gibt.
Das ist also eine Wechselseitigkeit.
Und daraus folgt natürlich der starke Mann muss zurück vor dem Frau und Kind
Angst haben, wenn er nach Hause kommt.
Weil die reine Gerechtigkeit dann die Handlung leitet.
Ja, das ist wie im Western.
Er muss seine Tochter schlagen. Wenn jetzt jemand kommt und sagt, der J.D.
Vance hat so von miserable cat ladies geredet und so, aber wollen wir Frauen
so behandeln, die haben doch auch Töchter.
Dann sagen die, ja klar haben wir Töchter und die schlagen wir ja auch.
Wegen Gerechtigkeitsfragen.
Ja, interessant.
Und es muss ein starker Mann daneben stehen, um die austauschbare Kandidatin,
also Kamala Harris wird nicht als individuelle Frau anerkannt,
völlig austauschbar, dispensable,
den muss jetzt wieder ein starker Mann zur Seite gestellt werden,
weil Tim Walz bringt es nicht. Der ist ja,
Der führt ja nur in den Strudel nach unten. So, dieser völkische Suizid,
dieses Antizivilisatorische, das ist dieses Denken.
Also er hat es jetzt als Performance auf der Bühne so gebracht,
aber J.D. Vance redet, die haben alle dieses Denken.
Er hat es nur jetzt mal so richtig expliziert, was so dahinter steckt.
So und jetzt ist so die Nazis damals hatten auch so ein Denken zum einen zur
Verschränkung von Familie und Politik und dann zur Rolle der Frau in der Familie
und in der Politik und daran schließen die an die mögen jetzt keinen Holocaust organisieren,
die werden jetzt nicht die ganze Welt mit dem Weltkrieg überziehen wobei diese
Zölle so ein bisschen aber in diesem Denken dass nun für jeden einzelnen Menschen elementar ist.
Weshalb Michelle Obama eben auch als Frau ihre herausgehobene Rolle als besondere
Frau darstellt und nutzt, um an die Männer zu appellieren, die sie lieben.
Also sie nicht verprügeln.
Unter dieser Maßgabe muss man jetzt die Michelle Obama-Rede hören.
Nicht einfach nur, die Königin der Woken hat jetzt eine Rede zum Thema Frau gehalten.
Nein, sondern hier die Antwort direkt darauf. Nur, das kann dann jeder selber machen.
Ich habe die Rede jetzt sozusagen auch nur angehört. Ich kenne sie gar nicht
im Detail, aber ich weiß in diese Richtung, also der Anlass der Rede ist dieses
Denken, was hier zugrunde liegt. Und dem gehen wir jetzt nach.
Elon Musk beschreibt also, wenn wir dieses Szenario nicht verwirklichen,
dass der starke Mann Grenzen setzt, dann führt das zu einem,
er nennt das dann einfach Volkssuizid.
So, let me just address those in order. So the first is, you say we need more,
und nicht zu verraten, zu verraten. Es scheint, die US-Gerberin,
wenn man drei Stunden zurückgeht, ist ziemlich kommentarend zu machen,
die mehr Amerikaner zu machen.
So, the American politics oder Government is committed to make fewer Americans.
Die amerikanische Regierung macht gar keinen Nachwuchs. Die Familien machen den Nachwuchs.
Und allein diese Formulierung, dass die Regierung hier zuständig ist für Nachwuchs.
Ulf Poschert hat jetzt auch nochmal kürzlich darauf hingewiesen,
dass er alles keine Kinder hat in der Regierung.
Also das scheint für ihn auch nochmal so eine wichtige Komponente jetzt zu sein,
dass er das jetzt auch überträgt.
Also ich sage mal so, ich schreibe in meinem Buch auch darüber, wer keine Kinder hat.
Und es nützt jetzt nichts, nicht darüber zu reden, wer keine Kinder hat,
sondern man muss dieses Denken aufgreifen und aktiv dagegen anarbeiten.
Man kann es jetzt nicht einfach ausblenden im Sinne von, das sind diese Natalisten,
lass uns lieber über VW reden.
Es ist ja so, dass selbst China, und da wird ja ziemlich autoritär regiert,
es nicht schafft, die Geburtenrate zu erhöhen.
Die versuchen ja alles mögliche auch mit Anreizen.
Mit Dating-Verfahren. unter die Bettdecke, wir hören das gleiche aus Russland,
die auch. Es klappt nicht.
Und das liegt ja, die schieben das zum Beispiel jetzt den Frauen da in die Schuhe,
deswegen funktioniert das alles nicht.
Die Sache ist doch, die gehen ja von einer Welt aus, die doch überhaupt nicht realistisch ist.
Also in dem Sinne, wie Trump von den Zöllen spricht, bei denen man sagt,
naja, so wird das wohl nicht kommen können, ist doch jetzt hier,
was sie machen können, ja nur Abtreibungen verbieten.
Schlimm genug für die Frauen jetzt, aber damit ist ja nicht,
die Geburtenrate lässt sich damit nicht steigen, so viele Abtreibungen gibt
es ja nicht und sonst kann man ja nichts machen.
Das heißt, diese Handmaid's Tale, die sie hier versuchen uns zu erzählen,
die funktioniert ja überhaupt nicht, weil das gar nicht mehr vorgesehen ist und…,
Diese Männer, die sie da imaginieren, die dann nach Hause kommen und Alleinversorger
offenbar sind, denn die Frauen sind mit den Kindern da zu Hause,
die kann es ja gar nicht mehr geben.
Das heißt, was die da sich vorstellen, ist ja illusorisch.
Ja genau und genau deswegen ist es ja so problematisch, dass sie das zu ihrer
Ankerideologie, zu ihrer neuen Religion machen.
Es ist ja nicht wie bei den Nazis, da war ja jetzt Kinderkriegen nicht das Problem.
Da waren ja Kinder ohne Ende da und da wurden auch immer wieder neue Kinder
gezeugt und da gab es kein Fötungsmittel und all das.
Hier sieht es anders aus und ich kenne zum Beispiel jetzt auch aus meinem erweiterten
Bekanntenkreis zum Beispiel sehr viele Frauen, die gerne Kinder hätten,
die keinen Partner dafür finden, weil die Partner dann sagen,
ich weiß nicht, jetzt schon sich binden, ich bin ja erst 36 und so.
Genau, du hast ja Clips aus. Genau, du hast ja Clips aus Kanada gespielt,
in denen gesagt wird, müssen sie noch so lange leben, wir hatten hier so Medikamente für sie.
So, jetzt stell dir mal vor, dass einfach fünf Jahre die Zukunft und die Regierung,
die ja schon in Amerika auch sozusagen ein Buch darüber führen möchte,
wer ist denn eigentlich schwanger und so,
dass sie dann einfach sagen, so wie beim Haustürwahlkampf, wir haben jemanden
identifiziert, die hätte gern ein Kind, findet aber kein Mann.
Können wir hier irgendwas machen? Gibt es politische Programme?
So, und hier wird es wirklich brenzlig, weil solche Sachen übernehmen dann ein
Eigenleben. Und ich will es jetzt mal ganz hart formulieren.
Ich sehe die Gefahr auch, ich kann es mir trotzdem nicht vorstellen.
Ich will es mal ganz hart formulieren. Die Nazis hatten Nachwuchs.
Also konnten die in die Welt hinaus wirken. Einfach Weltkrieg gegen die ganze Welt.
Wir brauchen Lebensraum, wir erobern ihn uns. Wir machen hier irgendwelche Verträge
mit Stalin, um uns Polen zu nehmen. Und nachdem wir Polen haben,
ach, diesen Stalin-Vertrag, das ist uns egal, wir nehmen uns auch Russland.
Dieses neue, wie ich auch finde, faschistische Denken hier, das besonders die
Bette regiert, ist genauso gewalttätig, nur nach innen gerichtet.
Ja, das ist ja überhaupt das Interessante bei all den rechten Strömungen,
die wir in Europa und in Amerika haben.
Diese rechten Strömungen sind nach innen gerichtet, sie sind nicht expansionistisch.
Und es ist niemand sicher.
Es ist nicht, dass die AfD, wäre sie jetzt an der Macht, den nächsten Krieg planen würde,
sondern sie führt einen Krieg dann gegen die Bevölkerung in der Form,
dass sie, also damit meine ich jetzt natürlich gegen Migranten alles,
aber sie wird auch sonst das Leben so faschistoid reglementieren,
dass befohlen wird, dass du jetzt noch weitere Kinder zu zeugen hast,
beziehungsweise weitere gebären musst.
In Südkorea gibt es ja schon diese politischen Programme, lieber Arbeitgeber, gebt mehr Freizeit.
Also der letzte Freitag im Monat ist einfach 16 Uhr Feierabend für alle,
damit zu Hause Sex gehabt werden kann.
So, was auch für die Frau bedeutet, das ist das Signal, heute Abend stehst du bitte zur Verfügung.
Ja, also das sickert sozusagen in alle Richtungen durch und hier sind dann nicht
nur, und deswegen, das von Michelle Obama ist so klug, zu sagen,
hier sind nicht nur die Frauen bedroht.
Sondern es richtet sich auch an die Männer, die diese Frauen lieben.
Ja, natürlich.
Weil der Staat kommt jetzt als Konkurrent in diese Beziehung rein und wird dann
Druck entwickeln und so weiter und so fort.
Also hier wird es jetzt sozusagen richtig brenzlig, hier muss man sich diese
neue Strömung, diese neue Art von Selbstverständnis einer Regierung genau anschauen
und welche Ideologien hier durchgebraten werden.
Denn es ist wie bei Egard Saad, der einfach sagt, Hitler, ich bin doch auch
Hitler, was das angeht. Und so sind auch alle Frauen gleich.
Frauen im gewährfähigen Alter, die brauchen wir jetzt.
Ist mir doch egal, ob das jetzt die Melanie ist, die irgendwas und so weiter.
Nein, wir brauchen dich jetzt. Du kannst jetzt nicht studieren.
Du hast noch fünf Jahre Zeit, das reicht für drei Kinder. Also so ungefähr. Also brenzlig.
Und wir haben ja jetzt von der Financial Times aufgeschrieben bekommen vor,
glaube ich, einer Woche, dass diese Peak-Weltbevölkerung schon früher erreicht
sein wird, dass es also doch weniger Menschen gibt.
Für Leute, die wie den Musk denken, ist jeden Tag ein Horchortag,
weil ständig solche Zahlen kommen. Nochmal weniger Kinder, nochmal nur halbe Geburten.
Und das war jetzt auch bezogen natürlich auf die Entwicklungsländer,
dass es da gar nicht mehr diese großen Menschen gibt.
Es gibt ja Länder, die sieben Kinder pro Frau haben. Die beschreiben wir an
typischerweise als kriegerisch, unruhig, unstabil.
Ich nenne dann in meinem Buch die Liste auch mal durch.
Können wir nicht einfach deren Kinder nehmen? Und jetzt müssen wir nochmal,
was Tucker Carlson jetzt hier sagt, nicht in diesem Gespräch,
sondern in einem Gespräch mit Alex Jones, muss man jetzt wirklich ernst nehmen,
wie weit er das jetzt hier treibt.
Also genau zuhören, was Tucker Carlson jetzt hier sagt und es ernst nehmen.
Lieber verkaufe ich mein eigenes Haus, bevor hier jemand aus Nigeria kommt und
die Geburtenrate hochhält?
Also Migration völlig ausgeschlossen. Die Zuwanderung kommt bitte aus der Gebärmutter
der Frauen hier, der guten Amerikanerinnen.
Das ist wirklich, das ist völlig bescheuert. Und es führt nur zu Leid,
das wird keins dieser gesetzten Ziele erreichen.
Du hast ja selbst die roten Kmäher irgendwie, die dann wirklich hart,
hart, hart und so, die konnten diese Kinder nicht, die haben einfach Familien
aufgelöst und gesagt, jedes Kind gehört Abgeburt uns und wir erziehen das und so weiter.
Also das ist eine Ideologie, die jetzt hier trag, also wirklich das Fundament
dieses neuen republikanischen Denkens, die einfach nur in Verderben und Leid führt.
Aber mit Vehemenz von ihren Männern durchgeführt.
Das ist ja etwas, was der Faschismus immer wieder bewiesen hat.
Also es war ja bei all der Menschenfeindlichkeit des Faschismus,
könnte man ja fragen, aber hat es funktioniert?
Und auch da kann man ja immer sagen, es hat nicht funktioniert,
es war wirtschaftlich desaströs.
Und man hat jetzt auch hier eine Ideologie, die überhaupt nicht tragfähig ist,
genauso wenig wie die Ideologie der Zölle tragfähig ist, aber dennoch,
wenn genügend Leute dran glauben,
funktioniert es als Ideologie eine Zeit zumindest und hält diese Leute da an der Macht.
Aber zugleich ist es auch, wir leben jetzt im Jahr 2024, als wir den Podcast begonnen haben.
Haben wir da gedacht, wir werden über Rechtsruck reden natürlich,
aber haben wir da gedacht, dass wir über eine solche Idee der Bevölkerungspolitik
sprechen werden? Niemals.
Und jetzt erinnern wir uns nochmal, okay, Tucker Carlson und so weiter,
Elon Musk ist der reichste Mensch der Welt, der jetzt die Politiker unter sich aufteilt in Pro-Human,
also für die Menschen, für die Menschlichkeit, für die Menschheit und die anderen und er nennt Namen.
All of the humans on Earth can fit on one floor in the city of New York.
The cross-sectional area of all humans, 8 billion humans, is small.
So we have this... Ich habe die völlig wrong idea, dass die Erde ist überpopuliert,
wenn es in der Fall ist, dass es unterpopuliert ist.
Ich habe, haben Sie ever gehört ein Politiker sagen, wie das?
Wie viele Pro-Human Politikerinnen?
Wie Viktor Orban, Giorgio Meloni. Wir beginnen zu sehen, pro-Natalist-Politiker.
Orban, Meloni.
So, Orban und Meloni. Ungarn und Deutschland. Italien.
Die haben nun wirklich diesen ganz unteren Rand, was Familien angeht.
Und gleichzeitig Grenzen zu.
Also die fahren schon genau diese Ideologie.
Nun sind es ja nicht nur die, sondern wir hören mal kurz heute Journal vom 8.
Oktober. Da wird aus Russland berichtet. Wir hören jetzt und ich beschreibe
kurz, es geht um eine Fernsehsendung von Wladimir Putin,
Splitscreen, er redet zu Publikum, links ist er zu sehen, als der große,
wir haben es ja eben von Taka Kalsen gehört, der Mann, der mal und so,
sagt, wo es lang geht und rechts im Bild sind Frauen im Publikum abgebildet, nach und nach.
Die Kamera geht so durch das Publikum und zeigt einfach junge Frauen,
die sich anhören, um was es geht.
Lasst uns mal daran erinnern, dass unsere russischen Großmütter und Urgroßmütter
oft sieben, acht und noch mehr Kinder hatten.
Lasst uns diese wunderbare Tradition doch bewahren und wiederbelegen.
So, also hier wird einfach konkreter Druck gemacht.
Ja, das ist so wie früher Papst Johannes Paul II., das dann sagte,
das sei doch toll, wenn da acht, neun Kinder haben.
Nur hier ist es halt der Regierungschef, der auch diese Frauen einfach zeigt
in dem Moment, die er meint.
Und wir wissen ja, die gucken nicht begeistert.
Diese Frauen.
Nein, nein. Elon Musk und Putin sind gute Freunde.
Es gab jetzt diesen Bericht, dass sie da mehrfach miteinander telefonieren,
im konstanten Gespräch sind und so weiter und so fort.
Um Taiwan auszunocken.
Zum Beispiel.
Also das muss man sich mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen. Putin hat gesehen,
dass die Ukraine gerettet wurde.
Putin ruft Elon Musk an, ob er ein bisschen was gegen Taiwan da machen kann.
Könntest du Starlink ausschalten, damit die nicht den Vorteil haben,
wie die Ukraine, als du Starling eingelassen hast.
Und Putin macht das im Auftrag der Chinesen. Das ist ja das Interessante.
Ungarn selbst, auch im September Thema gewesen, weil Ungarn ist ja gerade Ratspräsidentschaft,
also die haben eine Tagesordnung.
Es wurde nach Ungarn eingeladen, also ein Ministertreffen in Ungarn.
Tagesordnung wurde mal kurz abgeändert.
In Budapest war heute ein inoffizielles Treffen der EU-Finanzministerinnen und
Minister angesetzt, wobei allerdings nur ein Drittel der Ressortchefs angereist
ist aus Protest gegen die Alleingänge der ungarischen Regierung.
Und auch die Themensetzung war eher ungewöhnlich, berichtet Sabrina Fritz.
Der ungarische Finanzminister Varga hat die Überalterung der EU zu einem Top-Thema des Treffens erklärt.
Die Tatsache, dass die Europäerinnen und Europäer zu wenig Kinder bekommen,
würde auch der Wirtschaft der Gemeinschaft schaden, sagt er in Budapest.
Als Lösung schlägt er eine stärkere Unterstützung der Familie vor,
die für Ungarn aus dem klassischen Vater-Mutter-Kind-Modell besteht.
Ausdrücklich lehnte der Finanzminister Einwanderung als Unterstützung auf dem Arbeitsmarkt ab.
Masseneinwanderung würde den Ländern mehr schaden als nutzen.
Ja, also sensibilisiert euch schon mal, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer,
wenn das Thema Familie aufkommt.
Es ist nicht mehr gedöts, sondern da sind jetzt Leute, die eine Ideologie haben,
die sie durchgearbeitet haben,
die dann irgendwas von bloß keine Migranten, wir brauchen hier Familienpolitik
und die ihrerseits irgendwelche Ministertreffen auf europäischer Ebene einfach
abändern in der Tagesordnung.
Wie so ein AfD-Alterspräsident, der sich einfach sagt, ach sie sind jetzt alle
hier? Ja dann halte ich mal kurz eine politische Rede.
Und die handelt dann von Familie und Nachwuchs und so weiter und so fort.
Wir hören hier Musk nochmal, die pronationale Politik, die muss natürlich überall stattfinden.
Das reicht ja nicht, wenn einfach nur ein Washington-Präsident mal eine Rede hält.
First of all, I changed the education system so that people understand that,
Stop being taught that We're overpopulated.
This is completely false A lot of it comes from this insane misanthropic book
that Paul Ehrlich wrote the population bomb like 60 years ago Yeah,
I hope he burns in hell that guy seriously,
Terrible human being total absolute misanthrope,
Und sagen, dass die Erde absoluten kann, diese Bevölkerung. Wir können die Orte
geben, die die Bevölkerung.
Da ist ein Professor, ich bin an Oxford, der Maths sagt, dass wir 10x die Bevölkerung,
ohne die Amazon-Rainforeste oder nichts zu tun.
Ich denke, wir sollten die Bevölkerung und die Schöne und die Schöne und die
Consciousness so wir können besser verstehen Und die Natur dieses Universums ist wundervoll.
Das haben wir so schon bei Jeff Bezos gehört. Wir hören es in den kleinen Abschnitt nochmal.
Er sagt, wir müssen die Anzahl der Menschen erhöhen, um den Scope an Bewusstsein
zu vergrößern, damit wir besser
verstehen, was die Welt im Innersten zusammenhält und so ein Scheiß.
Also mehr Menschen als Verfügungsmasse geht gar nicht.
Völlig vergessen, dass ja ganz viele Menschen da sind, deren Potenzial niemals
ausgeschöpft werden kann, beziehungsweise können die nie ihr Potenzial ausschöpfen,
weil sie irgendwo verarmt leben und früh sterben müssen.
In Südafrika, und das meine ich jetzt kontinental, also nicht das Land Südafrika,
sondern der Steffen Urban da im Deutschlandfunk nennt wirklich mehrere Länder namentlich,
ist die Hungersnot so groß, dass dort jetzt Giraffen und Elefanten wieder zum
Abschluss freigegeben werden.
Ja.
Mit Menschen, die essen. Das ist der Zustand der Welt. Und er möchte,
nee, wir können das zehnfach vergrößern, die Weltbevölkerung.
Wir brauchen mehr Gehirne, die ja was sind und so. Also es ist völlig absurd.
Stört ihn ja auch nicht, dass 45.000 Pakistanenser erschossen wurden.
Ist ja nur ein kleiner Teil der Zivilisation, es ist ja nicht Menschen.
There's a professor I was talking to at Oxford, der ist, dass wir 10x die population,
ohne die Amazon rainforest oder anything terrible.
So, I think we should expand the human population and increase the scope and
scale of consciousness so we can better understand the nature of this universe,
this wonderful universe,
and all the amazing things that exist.
So, that's one of the things I would like we need to stop teaching people false
propaganda dass die Erde überpopuliert werden. Ich denke, wir müssen,
mit der Bildung der Frauen und Männer, wir müssen uns zu scannen,
dass es eine Frau, dass es ihr Leben ist. Das ist falsch.
Wir fangen an zu sagen, dass wenn ihr pregnant seid, ihr Leben ist über. Das ist was die Schule.
Ich glaube, wir sollten keine Teenage-Pregnanzierung. Aber eigentlich ein Kind
ist eine der most delightful happiness inducing Dinge you could possibly do. Of course. Of course.
Dabei sind es ja die ganze Zeit die Rechten gewesen, die den Frauen das Leben
dadurch zerstört hat, die schwanger wurden, dass sie keine Chancen mehr am Arbeitsmarkt hatten.
Also Tucker Carlson hat gerade auf der Bühne erzählt, wie er mit seinen Töchtern umgeht.
Ja.
Wir wissen von Elon Musk mit seinem Nachwuchs, was ihm da nicht gefällt und
dass er sie für tot erklärt.
Der Vogue-Virus hat mir meinen Sohn genommen, Sohn, Scheiß, dass die beiden
hier so über Familie reden, das ist doch das Schönste überhaupt.
Jetzt müssen wir nur den jungen Frauen verklickern. Und man denkt sich so,
nee, du verklickerst ja niemanden was, sondern du befiehlst einfach,
du kaufst halt Twitter und schickst jedem Björn Höcke Dinger auf den Screen,
egal ob ihr den abonniert oder nicht.
Du gehst zu Trump all in und sagst, klar bin ich deine rechte Hand, Vielen Dank.
Das ist ja nicht Verführung, sondern das ist Führung. Hier wird einfach das nächste Kind befohlen.
Also das finde ich wirklich alles sehr, sehr, sehr grenzwertig.
Es ist im Grunde Putins Politik, die er hier macht.
Ich frage mich, ob Ulf Posch hat diesen Turn auch noch komplett nachvollzieht.
Ja, die werden das machen. Also er macht ja momentan… Und er wird es aber selber
nicht durchdenken, er wird es so nachplappen.
Ja genau, davon gehe ich jetzt aus, dass er das nicht selbst durchdenkt,
aber wird er es noch machen, also wird er diesen Schritt noch mitgehen,
denn es ist ja so, dass damals, als diese Leaks von Döpfner kamen mit diesen SMS,
da gab es ja so eine sehr vulgäre Bezeichnung, dass er dann sagt,
ja, also es ist ja völlig klar,
unsere Agenda Israel über alles,
glaube ich, war seine Formulierung und ficken und so jeder wie er will.
Also das war noch so, da bleiben wir liberal, da werden wir uns nicht einmischen
und das ist jetzt was Neues hier und da bin ich gespannt, ob die Springerpresse
diesen Turn auch mitmachen wird, wenn Trump gewählt wird, dass man sagt, naja,
aber vielleicht doch mal das nochmal anders betrachten mit der Abtreibung und der Glammsten.
Glaube ich im Podcast auch diese Clips von Kevin Roos und Casey Newton gehört,
wie sie mit Julia Black über das Silicon Valley und das neue Baby ringen.
Und dieser eine Meta-Ingenieur sagte ja da, also in Zukunft wird niemand mehr
auf natürlichem Wege Kinder gebären.
Ich frage mich tatsächlich, was passiert, wenn man technisch Kinder einfach züchten kann.
Und Elon Musk gesagt wird, du musst nur so ein Schiff machen,
weil das muss dann so im extraterritorialen Bereich, wo jetzt keine Politik
und keine Polizei und so, da kannst du Kinder züchten. Ich glaube,
der würde das echt machen.
Ja, genau.
Der würde einfach dreistöckig in so einem Ja.
Und Jeff Bezos sagt, bitte produzier mir tausend Mozarts.
Also das ist alles so gruselig.
Aber davon sind wir noch sehr weit entfernt. Bei Nick Land und so,
das ist ja bei diesen also es gibt ja diese rechten Transhumanisten,
weil es gab jetzt vor einer Weile in der deutschen Presse wieder schlecht rezipiert
alles, dass Leute, die Transhumanismus kritisieren,
alle Rechte seien.
Also die Kritiker des Transhumanismus seien Rechte. Dann denke ich,
nee, es gibt einen rechten Transhumanismus, der genau auf solche Bevölkerungspolitiken,
hinaus ist und der auch durchaus sagt,
naja, also so ein arisches Programm könnten wir schon mal machen.
Ja, ja, ja, ja. Also wir sensibilisieren euch für diese Sachen.
Letzter Clip zu diesem Thema, die Shell-Jugendstudie, diagnostiziert für die
deutschen jungen Menschen.
Höheres politisches Interesse, aber weniger Glaube an die Demokratie.
Was ich für sehr gefährlich halte.
Bemerkenswert auch, vor allem männliche Jugendliche ordnen sich immer häufiger
als politisch eher rechts ein.
Allerdings bleibt es bei einer deutlichen Mehrheit derer, die sich eher links einordnen.
Eine Schule in Hamburg, Themen hier, Wirtschaft, aber auch Armut.
Auf dem Weg in den Beruf sind Ehrgeiz und Fleiß unter Jugendlichen wieder gefragt.
Außerdem, bundesweit sagt inzwischen jeder Zweite, er sei politisch interessiert.
So, lass mich mal noch zwei Clips spielen.
Brauchen wir die große Depolitisierung eher? Oder was das ist?
Nee, die Demokratisierung. Und damit meine ich tatsächlich, wir müssen politische
Inhalte wieder Verfahren übergeben, statt sie schicksalhaft an einzelne Personen zu knüpfen.
Kamala Harris muss gewinnen, Trump darf nicht gewinnen oder wie auch immer.
Ich habe es ja gesagt.
Sondern man muss, hier muss einfach wieder demokratisiert werden.
Ganz kurz noch, ich will das nur der Vollständigkeit halber sagen oder dich
eher dazu fragen. Ich habe mir einen Podcast angehört mit Melania Trump.
Sie hat ja jetzt ein Buch veröffentlicht.
In diesem Podcast klingt sie in etwa so menschlich wie Siri.
Die versucht was vorzulesen. Aber es gibt eine Stelle, in der sie darauf angesprochen
wird, dass die in Bezug auf Abtreibung für Pro-Choice ist.
Und sie spricht darüber, wird mehrmals dazu befragt und sagt,
ja, für sie ist Freiheit das Wichtigste und das kennt sie noch aus ihrer Model-Zeit,
dass Freiheit immer wichtig war.
Ich will ihr nichts unterstellen, aber es liegt so ein bisschen nahe,
als hätte sie da so eine eigene Geschichte mit.
Also sie war damals, wird nachträglich erklärt, als eine, die sich ihre Rechte
als Model auch in jungen Jahren sehr erarbeitet hat.
Und es schwingt da so ein bisschen, also ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass vielleicht oder in ihrem Umfeld, dass es Abtreibungen gegeben hat und dass
dann in den 80er Jahren sich plötzlich ein Tor öffnete.
Und ich hielt jetzt das, auch wenn sie sehr roboterhaft spricht,
durchaus für authentisch, dass sie sich für pro-choice jetzt ausspricht und
dass das nicht einfach nur so eine Strategie ist, naja, die einen versuchen
die anzufangen, die Rechten,
die Anti-Abtreibungsleute und ich mache ein bisschen für die liberaleren Republikaner.
Ich hatte den Eindruck, es war ein Anliegen von ihr.
Ich weiß es nicht, ich habe es nicht gehört. Ich glaube in dieser Welt,
in der Markus Söder sogar sagt, wir haben das hier im Gespräch geklärt,
Merz wird's und Melania Trump ja auch mit aufgetreten ist in diesem Madison
Square Garden und sich da so Küsse von Trump hat geben lassen müssen und die
Lippenleser aber meinten,
dass sie sagte, so jetzt genug, dass hier ernsthafte Erpressungen stattfinden.
Und dieses, was wir hier Röttger Brechmann aus dem Buch von ihm herausgelesen
haben, mit der Fragestellung, was ist mit diesen Politikern los?
Es scheinen sich diejenigen auf großer Bühne durchzusetzen, die auf kleiner
Bühne besonders rücksichtslos, besonders psychopathisch und eben nicht taktvoll
vorgegangen sind, sondern sich einfach radikal durchgesetzt haben,
dass sie sich natürlich auch in ihrer Familie so verhalten.
Also für Trump und Merz, Der übrigens ein sehr interessantes Familienbild hat,
das zitiere ich dann im Buch.
Er erfordert jetzt bei mir keine große kognitive Leistung, um mir vorzustellen,
dass sie sich auch ihr nahes Umfeld erkaufen, erpressen und was auch immer wie gestalten.
Es ist leider ein ganz düsteres Bild.
Also man muss sich nur den Film The Apprentice ansehen.
Ja. Wenn man das von dem Elternhaus nicht lernt, dann wendet man diese Taktiken,
dass ein gemeinsamer Weltentwurf entwerfen, dem anderen einen Raum bieten,
dessen Schritte mitgehen, zu unterstützen.
Jetzt wo wir dabei sind, es gab ein, also es gibt ja ganz viele Endorsements gerade.
Ich habe mir diesen einen Clip gemacht, ich werde ihn irgendwann mal spielen.
Scott Calloway. hat betont, warum er Kamala Harris unterstützt.
Und die Botschaft ist, weil junge Männer dann mehr Sex kriegen.
Er leidet ja sehr unter dieser neuen Maskulinität, also dass die Jungen da nicht
zugekommen. Das allerdings ist auch ein Thema für sich.
Das musst du aber irgendwann nochmal genauer ausführen. Das klingt jetzt sehr aufs Kurs.
Also die New York Times hat diese Woche ein The Daily gemacht zur Frage,
warum wählen die Jungen alle rechts und warum die jungen Mädels alle links?
Also jetzt mal links im Sinne von für Kamala Harris.
Und sie haben mit diesen jungen Leuten gesprochen. Bei den jungen Frauen ist der Tenor ungefähr so.
Ja, ich habe gehört, es findet eine Wahl statt, interessiere ich mich natürlich
für. Ich habe mich eingelesen, ich bin für Kamala Harris, weil die anderen scheinen
mir irgendwie zu wir zu sein, so ungefähr.
Und dann ist die Frage, und wie geht es dir sonst so? Alles gut,
ich bin jetzt umgezogen, ich studiere, was ich will und ein Jobangebot habe ich auch schon.
Und dann fragen die die Jungs. Nee, ich war in der Schule nicht sehr gut.
Ich wollte studieren, aber bevor ich mir ausgesucht habe, was ich studieren
wollte, haben die schon gesagt, das wird eh nichts.
Jetzt mache ich so einen Hilfsjob. Leider daten Frauen ja nicht nach unten sozioökonomisch,
aber die sind alle über mir.
Also ich finde auch niemanden. Ich bin auf verlorenen Posten.
Ja und das ist ja in den Statistiken jetzt nochmal für zig Länder bewiesen.
In allen Statistiken.
Ist studieren wesentlich mehr Frauen als Männer.
Ja. Und das führt zu Turbulenzen.
Ja, ja.
Sagen wir es mal so. Und die müssen auch politisch gestaltet werden.
Ich habe jetzt sehr dafür geworben, dass sich die Politik da nicht einmischt.
Politische Gestaltung meint ja, dass man zum Beispiel nicht so viele durchs Raster fallen lässt.
Wen fördert man in der Schule? Auf wen hat man besondere und so weiter?
Auch das deutsche Bildungssystem ist immer noch darauf ausgelegt,
es wäre doch schön, wenn auch Frauen mal MINT-Fächer studieren.
Dieses Problem, es wäre doch schön, wenn Männer, also junge Männer überhaupt
nochmal die Chance bekommen, auch mal eine Uni von innen zu sehen.
Das wird noch nicht gesehen.
Aber die Unis haben das schon als Nachwuchssorgen.
Wir haben von den Niets gesprochen, 630.000 Leute, die einfach,
keine Ahnung, was die machen.
Dieses Geschlechtergewältnis muss man sich anschauen. Wir haben in Deutschland
drei Millionen Menschen im Alter bis 25 Jahre ohne Berufsausbildung.
Hat schon mal jemand drauf geschaut, wie das gendermäßig verteilt ist? Wurde noch nicht?
Ja, da ist einfach nur.
Genau. Also man muss sich das genau anschauen. Frauen brauchen hier Schutz vor
der Politik, vor dieser Art von Politik.
Männer brauchen aber Unterstützung von der Politik. Und das ist natürlich blöd,
wenn Männer ansonsten immer als das starke Geschlecht gelten und so weiter und so fort.
Aber die Fähigkeiten, die Männer mitbringen, werden nicht mehr gebraucht.
Also die werden einfach nicht mehr gebraucht.
Wir leben nicht mehr in dieser Welt, in der irgendein männlicher Vorzug gegenüber
einer Frau gebraucht wird.
Sondern eher sind es Nachteile. Ist ungeduldig, will zu viel,
kann sein Impulskontrolle und so.
Die versuchen das ja jetzt anders
zu regeln, indem sie einmal den Männern sagen, schlag mal wieder zu.
Und den Frauen sagen sie, bring doch mal sieben Kinder oder acht Kinder wie
eure Großmütter auf die Welt.
Denn dann seid ihr auch nicht hier und nehmt die Arbeitsplätze der Männer weg.
Das ist ja das Angebot, das die Rechten jetzt machen. Genau.
Wir bleiben diesem Thema E-Treu, weil wir ja auf mein Buch da noch warten.
Ja, natürlich.
Ich will aber noch zwei Clips hier von Elon Musk spielen. Zum einen Joshua Topolsky,
er hat seinen Tomorrow-Podcast wieder aufgegriffen, leider nicht mehr mit seinem
alten Kompagnon, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie er hieß, mit einer neuen,
aber das finde ich auch witzig.
Er wirft hier eine Frage in den Raum, die wir danach mit einem zweiten Clip
von Musk selbst versuchen zu beantworten.
Also Joshua Topolsky stellt eine Frage zu Elon Musk.
Geniuses in technology ever and perhaps in business ever he's like a steve jobs
level character but to a lot of people is he is he stupid,
like is he dumb eine.
Sehr gute frage.
Ja eine.
Sehr sehr gute frage.
Ist er einfach dumm ja er wird ja nicht mehr er hat ja niemanden über sich der ihn,
keine irgendeine Information, die mal vielleicht ein bisschen konträr ist oder
sowas, sondern, ja, wenn diese langen Bücher und so weiter, der fragt ja einfach,
lebt Ayn Rand noch, kann ich mich mit der treffen,
bevor er ein Buch liest, ja, dieser Cat sagt, er wartet auf das Buch von dem,
nee, er wartet, dass das Buch so weit geschrieben ist, dass er sich halt mit
dem treffen kann oder was auch immer, ja, also, so, jetzt hören wir Elon Musk
noch einmal aus diesem Gespräch.
Ich sag euch nicht thematisch, worum es geht. Wolfgang hat es vielleicht schon
gelesen, du hast ja Zugriff auf die Zeile da.
Wir hören uns das einfach an, es geht eine Minute fünf und fragen uns dann, ist er einfach doof?
Und it ist die KI, also sie reden über KI.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, wir sagen, dass du sichergestellt wird,
dass es alle zahlen würde.
Jetzt kannst du zurück in Zeit zurück. Ich glaube, ich würde gerne nach dem
Ende meiner Leben sein, bevor das passiert.
Aber am Ende der Zeit, wenn es passiert wird, und es gibt nichts zu tun,
hypothetisch, würde ich es lieber sehen oder nicht sehen?
Ich glaube, es wird Ich würde gerne sehen, dass ich es nicht sehen kann.
Aber als ein Mann...
Bevor wir jetzt Taka Carlsen Nachfrage dazu hören.
Der hat jetzt erst eine ganze Stunde darum herumgeredet, wie man noch ein paar Kinder mehr bekommt.
Aber wenn die KI uns alle tötet. Will man da dabei sein? Will man das erleben? Ja, vielleicht schon.
Jetzt kommt Tucker Carlson Nachfrage. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher,
ob Carlson ihn jetzt ernst nimmt oder nicht. Aber er stellt ihm eine Nachfrage dazu.
Warum nicht Trump nicht zufrieden, dass sich die Sekretär der Defense und dann nur UKI machen?
Ich denke, ich würde sicherlich ein bisschen ein Regulatoren haben,
das zumindest einen Sinn hat, was diese Unternehmen tun.
Gut.
Also der reichste Mann der Welt und der reichweitenstärkste Mann im amerikanischen
Politikgeschehen. Klären die Frage.
Könntest du dich, wenn die KI ankündigt, uns alle zu töten, Trump dich befördern
lassen zum Verteidigungsminister, damit du dann mit Atomwaffen gegen die KI kämpfst?
Und dann muss er erst überlegen, dann schmunzeln und dann sagen,
wir könnten sie regulieren.
Ja.
Ich glaube, die sind wirklich einfach dumm.
Die sind dumm, ja. Und sie sehen mittlerweile komisch aus, also Elon Musk sieht
komisch aus, aber sehr viele weitere Leute auch.
Du hast ja hier Osampic uns damals groß vorgestellt.
Was ist, wenn Osampic ins Gehirn geht?
Nee, ich glaube, dass diese Gesichter sehen, also die Osempic Gesichter erkennt man.
Das ist meine These. Es gibt sehr viele Leute jetzt aus Hollywood,
aber auch aus Deutschland, die Osempic nehmen, die in der Öffentlichkeit stehen
und die sind nicht einfach schlanker geworden,
sondern die sehen irgendwie anders aus.
Ich würde ja meine Finger davon lassen, aber gut. Ich gehe auch zweimal die
Woche ins Fitnessstudio jetzt.
Das ist der richtige Weg. Männer folgt Wolfgang ins Fitnessstudio.
Frauen auch. Es sind viele Frauen, die da trainieren. Ich bin ja vormittags
dort, erlebe dann auch viele Senioren, die trainieren.
Das ist das Wichtigste. 90 Prozent der Bettlägerigkeit im Rentenalter,
dann im Pfleger, ist durch mangelnde Muskeln zu erklären.
90 Prozent, jeder neunte von zehn bettlägerigen Menschen könnte noch seinem
Alltag nach gehen, wenn man nicht die ganze Zeit im Dienstwagen gesessen hätte.
Gut, wir bleiben an der Sache dran. Ich werde dich auf dem Laufenden halten.
Wir weisen noch auf den Salon hin.
Was werden wir lesen? Verlust, ein Grundproblem der Moderne von Andreas Reckwitz
erschienen bei Surkamp.
Andreas Reckwitz ist der Soziologe, den alle lesen.
Habeck, Merz, Schäuble hat auch Reckwitz rezipiert und zitiert.
Wir müssen uns also mit einem Denker auseinandersetzen, der in den Köpfen der
Politiker vorkommt und der zugleich auch ein wichtiger Mann seiner Zunft ist.
Du bist wahrscheinlich ein bisschen grundskeptischer als ich.
Ich mochte die Gesellschaft der Singularitäten, konnte damit viel anfangen,
bin gespannt, was er uns jetzt in diesem umfangreichen Buch zum Verlust zu sagen
hat. Das machen wir im Salon.
So wie ich es verstehe in seinem...
Dieses Gespräch, das er bei der Zeit hatte, ich habe hier auch einen kurzen
Clip, den können wir mal kurz, er hat durchaus Fragestellungen,
die mich auch interessieren hier drin.
Es gibt eigentlich sehr stark auch mittlerweile in öffentlichen Diskursen wird
also die Verlustfrage zu einer, ich nenne das ja hier dreiwertige Logik.
Also es gibt nicht nur das, was man verliert und diejenigen,
die verlieren, sondern es gibt auch dritte Personen, dritte Kategorien,
zum Beispiel Gewinner oder Verantwortliche oder Täter sogar,
die eben in einem Zusammenhang mit diesem Verlieren und mit den Verlusten stehen.
Und die Suche nach Verantwortlichen spielt hier eine ganz wichtige Rolle,
Denn wenn man nach Verantwortlichen sucht, dann konstatiert man nicht einfach,
da ist ein Verlust, sondern fragt auch, wer hat diesen Verlust verursacht.
Das ist sehr gut.
Täter. Profiteure. Spezifiziert. Aufs Ökonomische verlieren.
Ich hoffe, dass er das tut.
Superreiche. Also ich erwarte jetzt, weil er sagt, das ist sehr wichtiger.
Er muss das schon tun. Auf dem Buch steht nur ein Satz von ihm.
Kann der Fortschrittsanspruch der westlichen Moderne noch aufrechterhalten werden,
wenn die Erfahrungen, Erinnerungen und Antizipationen von Verlusten so mächtig
werden, wie wir es gegenwärtig erleben?
Also haben wir hier wieder eine Kritik am Fortschritt beziehungsweise eine Fortschrittsskepsis.
Ist das eine Weiterführung von Autoren, die wir jetzt schon gelesen haben?
Wir sind da sehr gespannt.
Wir werden das diskutieren und zwar machen wir das im Salon.
Für alle, die hier zum ersten Mal zuhören oder noch nicht so häufig zugehört haben.
Der Salon ist der Zusatzcontent für unseren Podcast und es ist zugleich die
einzige Möglichkeit, uns finanziell zu unterstützen.
Dieser Podcast ist ja kostenfrei und überall verfügbar und das heißt,
man kann den Zusatzcontent dazu buchen.
Das geht ab drei Euro im Monat und zwar ist das,
Am allereinfachsten und am allerbesten, weil dort alle alten Folgen verfügbar
sind und das wunderbar sortiert ist,
über Steady, man geht einfach auf neue20er.de, findet dort einen goldenen Button,
da steht Salon, man klickt darauf und dann wird gleich das Steady Abo angeboten,
das ist ganz simpel abzuschließen, das geht mit EC-Karte, mit Kreditkarte,
es ist wirklich kinderleicht.
Google Pay, Garmin Pay, Dingsabons Pay.
Was es da alles gibt. Wenn jetzt jemand schon bei Patreon ist und sagt,
mir ist das eigentlich lieber, das über Patreon abzuschließen,
ich will nicht noch einen weiteren Dienst, dann geht das auch über Patreon.
Auch das findet man auf der Neu20er.de Seite.
Und für die Leute, die bei Apple sind und bereit sind, ein bisschen mehr zu
zahlen, weil Apple ja noch eine eigene Gebühr verlangt, geht das auch über Apple.
Da bekommt man ja den Salon schon mit angezeigt.
Und muss dann nur auf Bestellen klicken oder auf Bezahlen klicken und dann bekommt man sofort den Salon.
Man kann den Salon dann überall hören.
Es ist also nicht so, dass man vor Steady sitzen muss. Man muss auch nicht auf
den Desktop den ganzen Tag blicken oder sowas.
Man kann es so hören, wie man sonst auch die Podcasts hört.
Es ist nur der RSS-Feed, der einem dann zur Verfügung gestellt wird.
Das habe ich jetzt richtig gesagt.
Genau richtig. Und lasst euch nicht lumpen, hört Podcasts, wie man Podcasts hört.
Und wir sind ja quasi Avantgarde, weil wir haben das mit der Paywall angefangen.
Jetzt geht auch die New York Times, hast du das mitbekommen?
Zur Paywall über beim Podcast, beim Archiv auch.
Ich glaube, dass das wahrscheinlich viele Medienhäuser noch machen werden.
Aber wir sind ja unabhängig von den großen Akteuren.
Also wer einen unabhängigen Podcast unterstützen will, kann das auf diese Weise tun.
Und es gibt ja immer was, nämlich wir reden dann etwa drei Stunden lang,
meistens so anderthalb Stunden über das Buch, das wir ausgewählt haben und dann
empfehlen wir uns und natürlich allen, die zuhören.
Texte und haben dann immer so auch textlich den Monat Revue passieren lassen,
beziehungsweise blicken auf das, was wichtig ist.
Genau. Ich will noch Termine verkünden.
Ich nehme wieder einen Termin teil, wo ich fast fertig bin mit Schreiben.
Das eine ist am 20. November in Dortmund.
Da gibt es ein ganzes Tag, einen ganzen Tag Demografie-Forum.
Und zwar mit spezifischem Einschlag, Nämlich Migration und Familie.
Also das, wo wir die ganze Zeit Bundesliga hören im Fernsehen und wir aber feststellen,
die Migrationspolitik und Familienpolitik wird eigentlich kommunal organisiert.
Das ist eine Veranstaltung, bei der auch Jens Südekum einen Vortrag hält und
auch Aladin El Mafalani, der ja nun auch zum Thema Kinder demnächst publiziert.
Ich eröffne dann den Nachmittag mit einer Dreiviertelstunde plus Diskussion
mit dem Bürgermeister, der dort einlädt.
Also es ist tatsächlich, deswegen habe ich es auch nur angenommen,
weil das so hoch aufgehangen ist.
Also kommunalpolitisch, wo es hingehört und dann aber an der obersten Stelle.
Demografie. Dortmund ist ja eine Stadt, die so wie Frankfurt eine Bevölkerungsprognose
hat, die mit einem ganz großen Plus, wo man nicht so genau weiß,
wie viele Schulen brauchen wir zusätzlich.
17 neue Grundschulen und so. Also da gibt es Sachen zu regeln.
Außerdem am 29. November in Taufkirchen, da war ich letztes Jahr schon.
Und diesmal habe ich gesagt, ich komme aber mit neuem Buch, das aber bis dahin
noch keiner gelesen hat.
Es wird also eine experimentelle Veranstaltung, bei der ich,
vielleicht lese ich auch was, aber es wird auf jeden Fall zum Thema Familie gehen.
Ihr habt ja eben gehört, wie wichtig das Thema Familie ist.
Da gibt es Taufkirchen, das ist also kurz unter südlich von München,
eigentlich ist das München ähm,
Ein Abend zum Thema Familie.
Graue Literatur. Ich habe die Termine nicht im Kopf, aber man findet sie fast
alle schon auf der Homepage oder sie werden jetzt aufgefüllt.
Ich bin in Heidelberg zu Gast, in Düsseldorf, in Frankfurt, im Filmmuseum auch
für eine Podiumsdiskussion, in Emden, in Köln.
Überall also.
Und in Koblenz. Ich glaube, das waren jetzt die Termine für November.
Ja, kann man ja mal machen.
Außerdem will ich euch. Und wir werden auch noch Termine ankündigen,
dann im Salon, genau das ist noch möglich zu sagen.
Im Salon werden wir also alle vier Case-Termine ankündigen, die dann wieder
stattfinden, März, Juni, September, Dezember 2025.
Das heißt, ab dann ist es möglich, wenn die Termine draußen sind und die E-Mail-Adresse
publik ist, ab dann ist es möglich, Tickets zu bestellen. Das ist in der Regel
sehr schnell ausverkauft.
Das heißt, wer kein Salonist ist, wird kaum Chancen haben, da zu einem Live-Event
zu kommen, weil ja auch nur 200 Leute in die Case jeweils passen.
Ich will Podcasts empfehlen und zwar habe ich mir vorgenommen sowieso jetzt
mal häufiger, was höre ich selber.
Es war ja die Subscribe, eine Podcast-Konferenz, über die wir auch nochmal sprechen
können demnächst, wenn nicht so der Weltendruck über Trump und so weiter auf
diesem Podcast liegt. Und dort war Sabrina, die einen politischen Podcast hat.
Ich dachte, ich kenne alle politischen Podcasts in Deutschland.
Nichts dergleichen, sondern einer war mir tatsächlich durchgerutscht und ich
kann es bis heute immer noch nicht glauben.
Dieser Podcast heißt Parlamentsrevue und er macht genau das.
Einmal im Monat setzt sich Sabrina hin und guckt Bundestag. Und zwar die Debatten,
wie sie in der Mediathek vom Bundestag hochgeladen werden.
Und dann nimmt sie sich da Clips raus und begleitet Gesetze.
Es gibt eine parallele Webseite dazu, wo sie mithilfe von diesen ganzen neuen
KI-Sachen und so weiter den Stand von Gesetzen übersichtlich aufschlüsselt.
Wo man dann sieht, ah, ist schon die zweite Lesung durch oder wie auch immer und so.
Ganz verrückt. und in dieser Parlamentsrevue geht sie einfach im Monolog diese
Parlamente, also die Tagesordnung mit durch und hört sich dann an, was gesagt wird.
Und zwar mit Absicht ohne die Nachrichtenlage darüber hinaus,
nochmal korrespondierend so wie im Fernsehpodcast, ich mache mich ja mit Mick
quasi nur noch darüber lustig, was Ingo Zambaroni sagt, aber so richtig zur
inhaltlichen Ebene dringen wir ja gar nicht durch.
Und sie schaut aber nur diese inhaltliche Ebene, also sie schaut sich nur Wort
für Wort was wird im Bundestag gesagt an und geht das dann einfach durch.
Und das ist natürlich genau das, was fehlt.
Also alle Parlamentsreview hören, würde ich sagen.
Und ich will Studio Rot empfehlen.
Ja, natürlich.
Sehr witzig. Gerade auch, weil, das habe ich ja mir lange gewünscht,
dass es von Jean-Philippe und allen Leuten, mit denen er jetzt Klassentreffen
auf der Bühne macht, auch Bühnensituationen zum Nachhören gibt.
So wie wir ja auch die Case-Sachen einfach und so.
Und das kann man jetzt nachhören. Was natürlich sehr wichtig und witzig ist,
weil es zum einen inhaltlich sozusagen auf den Punkt kommentiert,
sage ich mal, ist, aber halt auch witzig.
Und das fehlt ja noch so ein bisschen, dass die deutsche Podcast-Landschaft,
wir auch witziger werden.
Nur wir sind halt nicht sehr witzig, aber Jean-Philippe ist witzig und seine Leute.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, es gibt jetzt auch einen Podcast dort mit Lensi und Ole.
Über Auto und über Prostitution, das ist doch genau die Themen.
Auto ist doch mein Thema. Ich muss es unbedingt hören, da bin ich noch nicht zugekommen.
Wir machen das, es ist ja Zeit im nächsten Monat, jetzt aber zu Nahost.
Was ist da eigentlich los? Und ich habe mir gedacht, will ich jetzt deutsche
Nachrichten konsumieren dazu?
Nein, beziehungsweise ich kriege
einiges mit und habe mich dann dazu entschieden, es eher nicht zu tun.
Das geht jetzt nicht gegen alle Journalisten, aber doch gegen sehr,
sehr viele, dass ich eher entsetzt bin darüber, wie in Deutschland man berichtet.
Dann lass mich gleich framen. Ich habe Clips mit von deutschen Journalisten,
die nicht so sind, wie man glaubt, dass deutsche Journalisten darüber reden.
Also so langsam lichtet sich der Schleier der Verblendung, sag ich mal ganz ausdrücklich.
Den Eindruck habe ich auch.
Man schaut es sich jetzt an.
Ja, ich wollte jetzt nicht mehr, mir war jetzt ein bisschen leid,
in so deutsche Podcasts und andere Sachen reinzuhören, weil ich immer 30 Minuten
Präambel bekomme darüber, wie man eigentlich nochmal Antisemitismus definiert,
bevor man aber eigentlich nur darüber reden will, dass jetzt gerade ein Krankenhaus
weggebombt wurde und ich würde gerne mal was über das Krankenhaus wissen.
Und deshalb habe ich mich entschieden, hier nur Clips rauszusuchen von großen
Medienhäusern, die noch dazu,
wir haben gleich eine Ausnahme, die noch dazu alle so aus dem liberal-konservativ-bis
links-liberalen Spektrum sind.
Also BBC, Wall Street Journal ist dabei, Foreign Affairs, die sind eher konservativ.
Aber ich wollte Englischsprachiges haben, weil ich doch den Eindruck hatte und
der hat sich bestätigt, dass man da ein bisschen differenzierter auf die Lage
blickt. Selbst da, wo der Mainstream zu Hause ist.
Und wir hören jetzt erst mal vom Wall Street Journal etwas über das Leiden der Zivilbevölkerung.
Wir haben ja jetzt mitbekommen, dass also nicht nur Gaza in Schutt und Asche
gelegt wurde, sondern jetzt gibt es auch den Krieg um den Libanon und Israel und Israel.
Hat natürlich diese Angriffe der Hezbollah,
diese Raketenangriffe, es gibt sowieso immer wieder diese Scharmützel da an
der Grenze, aber wir haben es ja jetzt mit einer unglaublichen Kriegsmaschinerie
seitens Israel zu tun, die dafür gesorgt hat.
Dass jetzt über eine Million Menschen in einem Land, das glaube ich 5,5 Millionen
Einwohner hat, dass eine Million Menschen auf der Flucht sind.
Und wir haben die Situation, dass schon bevor dieser Krieg begann im Libanon,
man sagte, dass mehr als 30 Prozent,
vorsichtig geschätzt, unterhalb der Armutsgrenze im Libanon leben.
Das heißt, wir haben es mit einem armen, zerrütteten Land zu tun.
Mit einem Land zu tun, das auch ganz stark von der Inflation betroffen ist, von Misswirtschaft.
Wir hatten Berichte 2019 vielfach darüber, dass aus der Mittelschicht Leute
in die Bank einbrechen, Bankräuber werden, um ihr Geld irgendwie zu retten.
Also das heißt, wir haben ein desolates Land, das jetzt durch diese Angriffe
in eine Katastrophe geführt wird.
Man muss sich vorstellen, über eine Million Menschen auf der Flucht,
ein Großteil davon total arm, schläft irgendwo auf der Straße.
Plus natürlich schon sehr, sehr viele zivile Opfer, die bei diesen Angriffen zu Tode gekommen sind.
Wir hören jetzt mal ein bisschen, ich möchte fast sagen wahllos,
in verschiedene Podcasts und Radiosendungen rein, um einen Einblick mal zu bekommen,
was eigentlich los ist mit den Menschen.
This is an apartment building in southern Lebanon, after it was hit in an Israeli
airstrike, causing it to collapse.
At least 45 people were killed and 70 were wounded, according to Lebanon's Ministry
of Health, making it one of the deadliest incidents since Israel stepped up its air campaign there.
The Israeli military said the building served as a Hezbollah headquarters,
and that the strike killed one of the group's commanders and several operatives.
But Wall Street Journal interviews with survivors, victims' families,
rescue workers and health officials identified more than a dozen women and children among the dead.
Das ist jetzt einfach eine Sache rausgegriffen.
Man könnte jetzt unendlich weitermachen. Wir machen auch noch ein bisschen weiter,
aber ich will nur sagen, das ist jetzt so ein kurzes Schlaglicht mal auf eine
permanente Ausnahmesituation.
Und er sagte er die erste Explosion und dann, wenn der zweite hit war,
die Power war, und das ist dann, dass er sich unter den Ruhm des Gebäudes befestigte.
Rescue workers were still pulling bodies from the collapsed building two days after the strike.
At least 16 of the dead were women and children, according to Wall Street Journal reporting.
Was wir an der deutschen Presse häufig finden, zum Beispiel auch bei tagesschau.de,
ist, wenn über sowas berichtet wird, wird gar nicht mehr gesagt,
woher eigentlich die Angriffe kamen, also von wem die sind.
Also du hast jetzt gerade die Fragen nach dem Täter gestellt in Bezug auf Reckwitz.
Zum Teil hat man den Eindruck, die Berichterstattung hat sich darauf geeinigt,
dass man so tut, als sei das eine Naturkatastrophe, da sind Leute tot geblieben,
aber dass das befehlt wurde und dass das auch ein Angriff der israelischen Armee
ist, wird fast unter den Teppich gekehrt.
Wurden zerstört, wurden getötet.
Wurden getötet, weiß man nicht warum. Und dann gibt es schon mal so die Aussage,
ja, hat man Hamas-Kämpfer oder Hisbollah-Kämpfer vermutet oder man geht davon aus.
Aber der Kollateralschaden, der kann ein Vielfaches höher sein.
Das ist alles dann in Ordnung.
Wir haben wirklich da eine unglaubliche Verrohung in der deutschen Presse,
aber nicht nur in der deutschen Presse.
Wenn man jetzt sich zum Beispiel BBC anhört, dann wird schon auch mal ein bisschen
infrage gestellt, Was bedeutet das denn eigentlich, wenn immer gesagt wird,
die Unternehmen ja gezielte Angriffe, also die israelische Armee?
And we start in Lebanon, which has been hit by multiple Israeli airstrikes across
the country, after Israel vowed to target branches of a bank its accusers of
helping to finance Hezbollah.
This here is the scene live over the skyline of Beirut, where we have been observing
large plumes of smoke rising in the past few hours.
Israel had issued the urgent evacuation orders to residents in 22 areas across
Lebanon and warned that attacks were planned on a large number of targets.
Und take a look at this video from last night, showing a multi-story building
in southern Beirut, collapsing after being hit by strikes.
These pictures here show the aftermath of some of those strikes,
with residents inspecting the rubble.
Es wird sehr viel einfach in Schutt und Asche gelegt. Und beim Wall Street Journal
sagt man auch, mit der Warnung, die es da im Vorfeld gibt, ist das so eine Sache.
Ahead of some of its recent air raids in Lebanon, the Israeli military has issued
warnings to residents of specific buildings.
Survivors of the Ein-el-der-Lube strike said they received no such notice.
BBC sagt dazu.
The first airstrikes happened here in Beirut, just 20 minutes after the Israeli
military issued those evacuation orders late last night.
And the Lebanese state news agency is reporting this morning that there were
11 airstrikes targeting Dahir, which is an area of Beirut, where Hezbollah has a strong presence.
There were three attacks in the country south and two in the Beqar Valley.
Again, areas where Hezbollah has a very strong presence.
And the targets of these attacks were branches of the Al-Qaad Al-Hassan Association.
20 Minuten vorher Bescheid gesagt, naja, was soll dann noch passieren?
Und das haben wir ja die ganze Zeit in Gaza schon beobachtet.
Dass es dann irgendwelche Vorwarnungen gibt und die Leute aber auch gar nicht
wissen, wo sollten sie denn hin.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass die sagen, dann gehen wir so lange ins Hotel und gehen
danach wieder zurück in eine Wohnung, die dann gar nicht mehr existiert.
Genau, es gab ja zum Jahrestag, 7. und 10.
Berichte, hier zum Beispiel zwei Drittel aller Häuser in Gaza sind zerstört.
Ein Jahr ist Israel nun schon im Krieg, der mit dem Überfall aus dem Gazastreifen begann.
Keines der Kriegsziele ist erreicht. Zwar ist der Gazastreifen flächendeckend
zerstört, unter anderem auch Tunnel der Hamas.
Das war dann so eingewoben, ne? Keins der Kriegsziele ist erreicht.
Ja. Aber zwei Drittel der Kriegsziele sind tot. Aber 45.000 Menschen tot.
Drittel aller Wohnhäuser in Gaza sind nicht mehr bewohnbar.
Unter den Trümmern sollen noch tausende Tote sein. Zusätzlich zu den 42.000
Toten, die das von der Hamas kontrollierte Gesundheitsministerium im Gazastreifen angibt.
Israel sagt, unter den Opfern in Gazan seien 17.000 Terroristen.
Doch der Krieg in Gaza ist noch nicht zu Ende. Die Hamas ist zwar geschwächt, aber noch da.
Das ist auch interessant, dass immer noch hinzugefügt wird, dass die Zahlen
von der Hamas bekannt gegeben worden sind.
Als sei jetzt ein Zweifel daran, dass die Zahlen extrem hoch sind,
ob es dann 44.000 oder 46.000 sind.
Das wird sich jetzt auch gar nicht verifizieren lassen, aber diese Zahlen sind extrem.
Und ich habe nochmal nachgeguckt und jeder kann das nachhören im Salon.
Vor genau einem Jahr, nämlich das war der, ich glaube, 5.
November 2023, haben wir den Salon aufgenommen.
Und ich hatte da einen Text mitgebracht vom Editorial Board der Financial Times,
in dem sie sagten, man braucht jetzt einen Seasfire.
Es sind schon so und so viel tausend Palästinenser unschuldig gestorben.
Wir können den Zahlen, die die Hamas veröffentlicht hat, glauben.
In der Regel, wenn das geprüft wurde, variierten die nur wenig von den offiziellen
Zahlen, die dann ermittelt wurden.
Und wir brauchen das, weil es sonst eine totale Eskalation gibt. Es wird ausgelöst.
Alles in Schutt und Asche gelegt werden. Es werden die Kriegsziele auch nicht erreicht werden.
Es müssen die Geiseln freigelassen werden, aber auf diese Weise wird es nicht geschehen.
Es steht drin, wir haben diesen Artikel vor einem Jahr vorgelegt.
Ich habe damals, nicht viele, aber ich habe damals ein paar Nachrichten bekommen,
dass es unmöglich sei, für Seasfire sich auszusprechen.
Ich habe in der deutschen Medienwelt, Podcast-Landschaft und so auch immer nur
gehört, nee, das sei jetzt nicht der richtige Zeitpunkt und Existenzrecht und so weiter,
als sei das Existenzrecht dadurch verteidigt, indem man dort noch ein paar Häuser
in den Schuttel oder Asche legt. Das hat ja mit dem Existenzrecht nichts zu tun.
Da geht es ja beim Existenzrecht wirklich um was um Existenzielles und darauf
kommen wir gleich immer zu sprechen, aber ich fand es so interessant dass die
Financial Times, die auch nicht dafür bekannt ist.
Antiimperialistisch oder was weiß ich oder links, wo sonst was zu sein dass
die das in einer Klarheit damals benannt hat, als Editorial das Wort,
das sagt und dass das einfach jetzt ein Jahr später noch schlimmer gekommen
mehr als die sich das hätten ausdenken können, plus die Erweiterung auf den Libanon.
Und wir immer noch da stehen und hören deutsche Politiker sagen,
na ja, also jetzt ist das unsere Verpflichtung, Staatsräson,
und da soll man sich mal nicht zurücknehmen mit Waffendieferungen.
Am 17.10., also ein Jahr, eine Woche und noch ein paar Tage, nach dem 7.
Oktober gab es folgende Meldung.
Diese Fotos zeigen den Hamas-Chef Iriah Sinua kurz nach seiner Tötung im Gazastreifen.
Inzwischen steht zweifelsfrei fest, dass es sich bei der Leiche um den Hamas-Anführer handelt.
Die Eilmeldung am Nachmittag im israelischen Fernsehen.
Armee und Geheimdienste würden prüfen, ob es sich bei der Leiche tatsächlich
um den Hamas-Anführer Sinua handelt.
Am Abend tritt dann Regierungschef Netanyahu vor die Kamera.
Ich stehe heute vor Ihnen, um Ihnen mitzuteilen, dass Iriah Sinua eliminiert
wurde. Die Person, die das schrecklichste Massaker in der Geschichte unserer
Nation seit dem Holocaust begangen hat.
So, man würde ja jetzt sagen, das war auf jeden Fall ein Kriegsziel.
Der Hamas-Chef muss sterben, also der Hamas-Chef in Gaza.
Weil dadurch, dass der Angriff am 7. Oktober von Gaza ausging,
wird der wahrscheinlich davon gewusst haben und es mitgeplant haben.
Der wird der Fadenzieher, Strippenzieher sein.
Und es hat über ein Jahr gedauert, ihn zu töten.
Und jetzt gibt es aber eine Nachrichtenlage, wo ich wirklich dachte,
das ist ja irre. Also das war jetzt das Heute-Journal.
Und die Tagesthemen erklären jetzt nochmal kurz die Umstände.
Diese Bilder beherrschen die israelischen Medien heute. Sie sollen zeigen, Yakhir Sinwar ist tot.
Die Armee hat ihn bei einem anderen Einsatz entdeckt. Keine gezielte Tötung,
keine Geheimdienstinformationen vorab.
So, der Typ wurde einfach nebenbei. Also es war ein Ziel.
Aber dass es geschah, dass er starb, dass sie ihn getötet haben,
ist durch Zufall passiert.
Das war nicht eine Mission wie bei Osama Bin Laden oder jetzt auch bei Nasrallah.
Genau, aber Netanyahu stellt sich genauso hin und sagt, er ist tot und so weiter.
Und IDF hat ja auch so einen Tweet dazu gemacht, er ist tot.
Was natürlich jetzt zu ganz schön vielen Fragen führt, wenn die Journalisten
zum Jahrestag sagen, keins der Kriegsziele wurde erreicht und die Kriegsziele,
die passieren, also die erreicht werden, passieren so aus Versehen.
Also man hat gar nicht gezielt, sondern dann starb er halt auch.
Gleichzeitig findet aber so ein Flächenbombardement statt, bei dem man sich
denkt, aber wie konnte er denn bisher noch nicht getötet worden?
Selbst ungezielt irgendwo muss er ja gewesen sein.
Also dieses, dass Krieg auch einem Ziel folgt.
Und dass die Israelis immer die ganze Zeit sagen, ja, ja, also alle Schläge,
die passieren, wir wissen genau, wer da stirbt.
Es ist total gezielt, total geplant. Wir rufen da vorher an.
Wir sagen den Zivilisten Bescheid, aber den Hamas-Kämpfer nicht und so weiter.
Und dann wird über ein Jahr danach aus Versehen der Hamas-Chef getötet.
In so einem, wir bombardieren einfach, wir werfen mal eine Bombe drauf,
mal gucken, wer so tot ist dabei. Und dann, ah, zum Glück war es auch der Hamas-Chef.
In dem Chaos findet sich doch niemand zurecht.
Also wenn man das mal entfaltet, was das bedeutet, ist es doch wirklich schlimm.
Ja, niemand kann behaupten, dass das alles klar gezielt und strukturiert und sonst was läuft.
Man kann es ernsthaft nicht behaupten.
Es wird Chaos produziert.
Die haben den Hamas-Chef aus Versehen mitgetötet. Das wollten die gar nicht in dem konkreten Fall.
Oder man trifft aus Versehen UN-Truppen.
Israel acknowledged its forces hit a UN observation post in southern Lebanon,
saying it was firing at what it called a nearby threat.
The UN Secretary General, Antonio Guterres, described the attack as a violation
of international humanitarian law.
The US President, Joe Biden, said he'd asked Israel not to fire at UN peacekeepers.
Wie kann das sein? BBC fragt nach.
Our senior international correspondent, Orla Guerin, spoke to Andrea Tenente,
spokesperson for the UN forces.
So this is very concerning, because we have seen a lot in the last 12 months, exchanges of fire,
but this time it looks more of a deliberate attack against our troops,
who have been in the south to try to bring back stability at the moment,
and it's very, very challenging.
So this is very deliberate as far as you're concerned. This cannot be a mistake.
You know, we are looking into that, but how can this be a mistake from an army
that is well prepared, dass sie wissen, was sie tun. Ist es ein Krieg?
Es gab von einigen Begegnungen von den italienischen Regeln,
dass es ein Krieg sein könnte.
Ich weiß, dass viele Regeln sehr vokal waren, was passiert ist.
Wir schauen immer noch an das. Aber es ist definitiv ein sehr seriöses Entwicklung,
um diese Spiepers zu attacken.
Nachdem ich weiß, dass sie aus Versehen den Hamas-Typen umgebracht haben.
In dem Fall ist es noch schlimmer.
In dem Fall fragt man sich jetzt, was ist hier dann aus Versehen? Chaos, willentlich.
Das war jetzt am 10. Oktober.
Sie haben Blauhelme beschossen und dann fragt man sich, wussten die Israelis,
auf wen sie schießen? Katrin Eigendorf erklärt hier mal.
Israels UN-Botschafter hatte sich ja schon dazu geäußert und gesagt,
dass er den UN-Truppen empfiehlt, sich wegen der andauernden Kämpfe zwischen
der israelischen Armee und der Hezbollah für mindestens fünf Kilometer weit.
Also das kennen wir ja noch aus der Argumentation von Volker Beck.
Die haben doch Flugblatt gekriegt, wieso halten die sich noch in der Kampfzone
auf? War doch klar, dass die da sterben.
Also das ist dieses Handlungstheoretische, sie haben das erduldet.
Sie haben halt nicht gehandelt, zack, selber schuld.
Hier allerdings gab es Ankündigungen vorher, also sie wussten,
wir wollen die beschießen und wir wissen auch, wer die sind,
wir haben deren Telefonnummer.
In den Norden zurückzuziehen. Es gibt jetzt heute Abend nochmal eine Stellung
auch der israelischen Militärs dazu.
Die streiten diesen Vorfall nicht ab, aber ihre Version ist,
dass sie sagen, sie hätten die UN-Truppen ausdrücklich gewarnt und gebeten,
sich in Schutzräume zurückzuziehen,
weil man dort operieren müsse, weil die Hisbollah genau in dem Gebiet,
wo das UN-Hauptquartier im Libanon ist,
im Süd-Libanon, weil sie dort operieren und weil man dort eben die Hisbollah bekämpfen wolle.
Aber es habe keine Reaktion erfolgt und das ist eben die Version,
die Perspektive der Israelis auf diesen Vorfall.
Wer nicht hören will, muss fühlen. Da kommt auch Katrin Eigendorf ins Stattern.
Wir wussten, dass ihr UN-Blauhelme seid.
Wir wollten euch auch Bescheid sagen. Wir haben angerufen, ihr habt aber nicht
abgenommen. zack, bombardiert.
Und nicht nur das, sondern das ist der 10. Oktober. Am 11. Oktober war die Nachrichtenlage.
Im Libanon sind erneut zwei UN-Soldaten bei einem israelischen Angriff verletzt worden.
Sie wurden in der Nähe eines Beobachtungspostens der UN-Mission Unifil in Beirut.
Wir haben einfach am Tag drauf nochmal die UN beschossen.
Ja, aus Versehen.
Es ist wirklich das Ja.
Ich meine, wir haben Als politische Beobachter in Verantwortung.
Muss man sagen, sorry, aber das geht nicht, denn wenn das jemand anders auch
macht und wir müssen ihm die gleiche Erklärung durchgehen lassen,
sind wir in Teufelsküche.
Ja. Also man darf nie mehr irgendwas mit Menschenrechte, feministischer Außenpolitik
und so weiter verlauten lassen, wenn man das durchgehen lässt.
Also man muss dann bei anderen Tagen schweigen.
Gut, ihn hat auch in der Europäischen Union angerufen. Warum sind die denn in Kiew geblieben?
Ja.
So, selber schuld. Also das ist wirklich gruselig. Wir haben hier eine Nachrichtenlage
im Oktober gehabt und zwar am 6.
Oktober, also einen Tag vor dem 7. Oktober, in der selbst die Tagesthemen bezeichnen.
Man weiß ja nicht genau, wie die so eine Redaktionskonferenz machen,
ob sie dann sagen, das Thema machen wir besser nicht und so.
Und dann haben sie es doch gemacht.
Und man hört es auch in der Moderation schon, dass es hier einfach nichts mehr zu beschönigen gibt.
Also man muss jetzt einfach mal dem Publikum und damit auch der zuschauenden Politik etwas zumuten,
dass man lieber verschweigen würde, aber vielleicht käme raus,
dass die Tagesthemen das Thema da hatten, weil sie Berichterstattung von vor Ort bekommen haben.
Es ist jetzt so, wir kriegen auch eine Berichterstattung direkt aus Gaza.
Wir wissen aber, da sind keine deutschen Journalisten, sondern die arbeiten
da mit Leuten, die einfach sagen, also ich habe einen Bericht gemacht zu diesem
Thema und den habe ich auch nach Hamburg geschickt und dann wurde der nicht gesendet.
Also kann durchaus sein, dass da solche Kalküle eine Rolle spielten,
dass man sagt, okay, da müssen wir jetzt durch, beißen jetzt die Zähne aufeinander,
wir Bericht erstatten jetzt Folgendes.
Es ist ein Vorwurf, den Israels Armee und die Staatsführung im Kampf gegen die
Terrororganisation Hamas immer wieder formulieren.
Die Hamas benutze die palästinensische Zivilbevölkerung systematisch als Schutzschild.
Nun aber behaupten Quellen, dass einige israelische Soldaten ähnlich vorgehen.
Sie würden palästinensische Zivilisten in heiklen Situationen vorschicken,
um sich selbst weniger zu gefährden.
Ich habe das ja schon mal so beschrieben, man muss diesen ganzen Konflikt anders beobachten.
Die Hamas und die Netanyahu-Regierung ziehen am selben Strang und führen einen
Krieg gegen die Bevölkerung.
Es ist nicht Hamas gegen Netanyahu. Beide wollen den Krieg.
Und beide führen ihn gegen die Bevölkerung. Und jetzt wurde ja immer gesagt,
nee, die Hamas missbraucht ja ihre Bevölkerung. Als Schutzschilde zum Beispiel.
Die quartieren sich dann ein unter Krankenhäusern, unter Schulen,
damit es für die Israelis dann heißt, ihr habt ja schon wieder Krankenhäuser
und Schulen beschossen.
Nur machen eben die Israelis das auch. Also da ist einfach die israelische Armee im Gazastreifen.
Und ja, was soll man sagen, dreht dann den Spieß einfach um,
denn sie wollen ja in Häuser und Tunnel rein. Und da ist es gefährlich.
Mohammed Abu al-Sayed hatte nicht mehr daran geglaubt, seine Kinder nochmal
wiederzusehen. Unser Team trifft ihn im Süden des Gazastreifens.
Dort erzählt er uns eine Geschichte über den Gazakrieg, die nicht in das gängige
israelische Narrativ passt.
Die israelische Armee habe ihn gefangen genommen. 15 Tage lang habe er für sie
Häuser durchsuchen müssen.
Sie gaben mir ein Handy zum Kommunizieren und eine weiße Flagge.
Dann habe ich das Haus betreten. Eine Drohne mit Kamera war bei mir.
Man sagte mir, welche geschlossenen Tür ich öffnen muss. Und welchen Schrank.
Auch diese Aufnahmen, die der arabische Fernsehsender Al-Jazeera erhalten hat
und die wir nicht unabhängig überprüfen können, sollen zeigen,
was Mohammed Abu al-Sayed uns als Augenzeuge berichtet.
Als menschliche Schutzschilde seien Palästinenser in Häuser und Tunnel vorangeschickt worden.
Sie sollten überprüfen, dass
keine Kämpfer oder Sprengfallen auf die israelischen Soldaten warteten.
Ja, also die Berichterstatterin selbst nennt jetzt die Palästinenser dort menschliche
Schutzschilde für die Israelis.
Und jetzt denken wir uns, das hätte man ja auch anders machen können.
Gibt es da nicht so Orpada oder sowas?
Hier in Tel Aviv, in dem Büro von Breaking the Silence, einer NGO von ehemaligen
und aktiven Soldaten der israelischen Armee, berichten offenbar seit Dezember
immer mehr Soldaten von solchen Vorfällen bei ihren Einsätzen im Gazastreifen.
Keiner von ihnen traut sich vor die Kamera, noch nicht einmal anonymisiert.
Deshalb fasst der Leiter der
Organisation, Nadav Bayman, die Berichte der Soldaten für uns zusammen.
In einer Einheit hat der Offizier gesagt, du musst nicht über Kriegsverbrechen
nachdenken. Ich bin dein Offizier.
Du musst nicht nachdenken, sondern Befehle ausführen.
Woanders hat man gesagt, es gibt zu viele tote Hunde in der Armee.
Deshalb benutzen wir jetzt Palästinenser.
Und in einer anderen Einheit hieß es, willst lieber du sterben?
Wir ziehen es vor, dass die Palästinenser sterben.
Ja, also das passt zu keinem Tenor irgendeiner Sonntagsrede.
Nee.
Es sterben so viele Hunde, wir nehmen jetzt Palästinenser.
Aber ich meine, wenn du doch, ich habe nochmal so drüber nachgedacht,
das eine ist diese Geschichte um die Staatsräson und all das.
Aber wenn man mal davon mal gerade absieht,
dann ist doch interessant, dass ich glaube, dass es nicht nur aufgrund dieser
Staatsräson-Geschichte ist,
dass wir in der deutschen Medienwelt diese Wirklichkeit so stark ausgeblendet
finden. Und hier findet sie dann mal statt.
Ich glaube, es gibt schon einen so stark vertretenen strukturellen Rassismus, dass man sagt, ja,
es ist irgendwie schade, dass so viele Leute sterben, aber es sind nicht unsere Leute.
Oder vielleicht sogar im Stillen gedacht,
Es sind nur Muslime. Ich glaube, dass das echt vertreten ist,
weil anders ist es nicht zu erklären, dass es keine Empörung gibt.
Es ist ja schon interessant gewesen, als man die ukrainischen Flüchtlinge aufnahm,
dass man gleich bereit war, so eine Zwei-Klassen-Flüchtlingsgesellschaft zu
machen, wo man sagt, die sehen ja so aus wie wir.
Die sind irgendwie besser zu behandeln und bei den anderen nicht und da auch eher die Grenzen zu.
Also dass man da wirklich sagt, und das ist so ein.
Also es gibt den lauten Rassismus der AfD und all das, aber es gibt auch so ein, zumindest so ein,
ist mir egal, sind nicht meine Leute Rassismus, der sich nicht so laut als äußert,
wie jetzt bei Weidel, Gauland etc.
Aber dass man das einfach so verdrängt, das wird externalisiert,
so ist es wohl irgendwie in der Welt, schade um die vielleicht auch,
aber ich kümmere mich nicht darum, bin vor allem nicht dafür verantwortlich,
sehe jetzt nicht, dass Deutschland an sich unglaublich viele Flüchtlinge aufnehmen
müsste und auch die Waffendieferung nach Israel stoppen müsste,
dass das einfach nicht so gesehen wird.
Also ich glaube, das ist wahnsinnig vertreten, denn anders kann ich mir das
ja gar nicht vorstellen,
denn auch wenn wir jetzt sagen, dass es medial unterrepräsentiert,
es ist ja durchaus bekannt, also wir reden ja jetzt nicht hier grundsätzlich
über Sachen, die noch niemand vorher gehört hat, sondern es ist ja in der Welt
und die Leute sehen es über Social Media,
die Leute sehen es mitunter auch in den großen Nachrichtensendungen dann hier bei uns.
Das heißt, die Zahlen sind in etwa bekannt über die Opfer und trotzdem gibt
es eine enorme Gleichgültigkeit,
bis hin dann zu so einem Zynismus, wie man ihn bei der CDU finden kann oder
auch bei Springer, die dann sagen, naja,
Israel hat jedes Recht und Punkt aus.
Gilda Sahibis Buch dazu heißt ja, wie wir uns Rassismus beibringen.
Also da steckt ja so eine kulturelle Konnotation des, wir sozialisieren uns
da selber rein. So ist es auch hier.
Man denkt so ein bisschen, okay, die Tagesthemen haben sich mal zugetraut,
da gab es so Vorfälle, aber jetzt, wo sie bekannt sind, kommt es doch nicht mehr vor, oder?
Und dann stellt sich raus, nee, das ist jetzt schon in die Lehrbücher dort eingesickert.
Zwei bis drei neue Zeugenaussagen bekommen Breaking the Silence nach eigenen Angaben jede Woche.
Für Nadav Weimann belegt das, dass es nicht um Einzelfälle geht,
sondern dass die Praxis, palästinensische Zivilisten in gefährliche Situationen
voranzuschicken, in der Armee öfter vorkommt.
Die israelische Armee verwendet Palästinenser als menschliche Schutzschilde.
Und ich dachte am Anfang, dass es ein isolierter Vorfall sei.
Aber dann haben wir Zeugenaussagen aus verschiedenen Einheiten,
Zeiten, verschiedenen Orten im Gazastreifen bekommen und verstanden,
es ist weit verbreitet und ein Protokoll.
Ja, die Ansinnen sind exakt dieselben.
Die Hamas macht das aus denselben Gründen wie die israelische Regierung.
Sie will sich schützen. Sollen die doch sterben.
Erstmal eine Bombe durch drei Stockwerke, Wohnhaus fallen lassen,
damit sie im Keller nicht ankommt, so ungefähr.
Und hier wird einfach systematisch von zwei Kriegsparteien gegen eine Bevölkerung
in Krieg geführt, die zudem noch eingesperrt ist.
Also einfach ein Zaun drumherum und mehr. Da gibt es einfach gar keinen Ausweg.
Die ARD-Korrespondentin betont dann hier auch nochmal, das sind keine Einzelfälle.
Wir haben mit Palästinensern im Gaza-Streifen gesprochen, übrigens auch mit mehr Palästinensern.
Jan-Christoph Kitzler ist natürlich ein Mann.
Dem Familienvater, den wir gerade im Stück gesehen haben. Es ist gar nicht so
schwierig gewesen, dort Menschen zu finden, die uns davon erzählt haben. Das ist die eine Seite.
Und dann gibt es die Aussagen der israelischen Soldaten, die Breaking the Silence,
die israelische NGO eingesammelt hat, aber die zum Beispiel auch die israelische
Zeitung Haaretz dokumentiert hat.
Und wenn man sich das anguckt, wenn man das übereinander legt,
dann kommt man zu der Auffassung, das sind keine Einzelfälle,
das ist offenbar eine gängige Praxis, denn das Ganze ist über einen längeren
Zeitraum passiert, in unterschiedlichen Einheiten und im ganzen Gazastreifen.
Ja, während natürlich die Sonntagsrede, die in Deutschland jeden Tag berichtet
wird, während das hier Ausnahme ist.
Ich würde das Ganze jetzt aber nicht abtun und sagen, naja, die israelische
Armee reagiert mit dieser Praxis auf die Tatsache, dass die Hamas sich hinter
der eigenen Bevölkerung verschanzt.
Sondern das ist etwas, was gravierend ist, was gegen internationales Recht verstößt.
Und das ist eben jetzt die Frage, was folgt daraus, was kann daraus folgen und
das ist eben völlig ungeklärt.
Wir würden auf jeden Fall davon ausgehen, dass es keine Einzelfälle sind und
dass das auch ein schlechtes Licht wirft auf die israelische Armee,
die ja Benjamin Netanyahu, der Ministerpräsident, hier immer wieder als die
Most Moral Army, also die moralischste Armee der Welt bezeichnet.
Zu dieser moralischsten Armee der Welt, wenn du es mir erlaubst,
soll ich direkt ein bisschen Döpfner spielen.
Also diese Kriegsführung läuft so ab, dass wir zwei Drittel der Häuser zerstört
haben und die Menschen, die in diesen Häusern lebten und auch schon nicht so
lebten, wie wir uns vorstellen, dass man da leben sollte, jetzt gar keinen Ausweg
haben. Die sind weiterhin auf diesem Gebiet.
Wir haben hier Ärzte ohne Grenzen. Lara Dovifat, die uns die Situation auch
im deutschen Fernsehen am 12.
Oktober im Heute-Journal nochmal umreißt.
Es gibt also wenige Orte noch, in die die Menschen könnten in Gaza.
Lara Dovifat von Ärzte ohne Grenzen. Guten Abend. Im Norden von Gaza sitzen
auch Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter von Ihnen, von Ihrer Organisation fest.
Warum leisten die denn den Befehlen der Israelis nicht Folge und Evakuieren? Was ist das Problem?
Genau, aktuell befinden sich auch Mitarbeitende von Ärzte ohne Grenzen im Norden. Sie sitzen fest.
Wir standen gestern mit ihm nochmal im Kontakt. Sie sagen, es gibt keinen sicheren
Ort für sie zum Flüchten.
Viele von ihnen wurden ja auch schon mehrfach vertrieben. Wir sehen einfach
immer wieder auch Angriffe im Süden und jetzt auch im Norden.
Und die Menschen haben einfach keinen Ausweg und kommen gerade aus dieser Situation auch nicht raus.
Es gibt keinen sicheren Ort, sagen Sie. Wie passt denn das zusammen mit dem
israelischen Befehl, den Norden zu verlassen und nach Süden zu gehen?
Viele der Menschen, auch viele der Patienten, die Ärzte ohne Grenzen behandeln,
kommen tatsächlich aus dem Süden, haben dann im Norden Schutz gesucht.
Wir müssen uns hier eben auch Menschen vorstellen, die jetzt nach einem Jahr
des anhaltenden Krieges mit Mehrfachverletzungen zu kämpfen haben.
Viele wurden amputiert und die Menschen haben keine Kraft mehr,
haben keine Ressourcen, man haben einfach auch keine sicheren Orte,
wo sie sich eben hinbegeben können.
Und deswegen sagt er zu den Grenzen auch, diese Zwangsvertreibung von Zivilisten
müssen gestoppt werden.
Jetzt hast du mich ja angefixt, Ronsheimers Podcast zu hören.
Ja, aber sowas höre ich ja nie, Ronsheimers Podcast, wenn jetzt Matthias Döpfner
über Israel da redet. Ich bin ja nicht verrückt.
Also 7. Oktober, Jahrestag. Wir wissen alle, wie das abläuft.
Döpfner diktiert sich in diesem Podcast rein.
Er sitzt also als Gesprächspartner Paul Ronsheimer gegenüber,
der schon versucht, sein übliches Programm zu machen, aber nun auch nicht die
allerhärtesten Fragen stellt, sondern der Milliardär und Chef hat natürlich immer recht.
Weshalb Döpfner, und das kann man ja hier nochmal hervorheben,
diese Milliardäre, wenn ihnen ein Mikrofon hingehalten wird, die reden einfach.
Tucker Carlson hat ja auch kein Redeprogramm gehabt mit Musk,
sondern hier rede einfach und dann hat man halt zweieinhalb Stunden einmal alles abgenudelt.
Döpfner findet, die Kritik einer israelischen Kriegsführung ist viel zu scharf.
Und diese Bemerkung würde ich gerne noch machen, dass wir auch in der Frage,
wie wir überhaupt auf kriegerische Auseinandersetzungen blicken,
mittlerweile etwas naiv und weltfremd geworden sind.
Ich meine, Israel verteilt Flugblätter vorher, um anzukündigen,
wo sich Zivilisten besser in Sicherheit bringen sollten.
Tut alles, um zivile Opfer zu minimieren und beeindruckt teilweise mit der Zielgerichtetheit
militärischer Schläge, insbesondere auf die Führer, Anführer von Terrornetzwerken.
Und trotzdem sagen wir, das darf nicht passieren.
Ja, nochmal, jeder Krieg ist einer zu viel. Jedes Opfer, das es in einem Krieg
gibt, ist eines zu viel. Aber wir müssen doch irgendwo realistisch noch sein
in den Möglichkeiten, wie man sich in einer solchen Auseinandersetzung verteidigt.
Und ich habe manchmal das Gefühl, auch das ist sehr asymmetrisch geworden.
Ja, es werden doch noch 45.000 Menschen sterben können. Das ist doch,
wir haben ja ganz verlernt, was Krieg ist.
Israel beeindruckt durch die Zielgerichtetheit von einer Sache war besonders beeindruckt.
Also es gibt ja fast kein funktionsfähiges Krankenhaus, ich glaube es gibt kein
komplett funktionsfähiges Krankenhaus mehr in Gaza und er sagt,
diese Zielgerichtigkeit ist erstaunlich.
Ja und ihn beeindruckt vor allem eine zielgerichtete Aktion.
Ich würde sagen, beeindruckt ist das richtige Wort, aber es gibt doch verschiedene Vorzeichen.
Und auch in Deutschland habe ich mitbekommen, dass die Leute doch eher so begruselt
waren, was da vorgefallen ist. Aber Döpfner fand es geil.
Also ich muss sagen, ich war jetzt in den letzten Wochen eigentlich ziemlich
beeindruckt über den Erfolg einiger Schläge, die Sache mit den Pagern.
Also das ist für mich wirklich einer der größten, geradezu ikonografischen Triumphe,
wie man mit einem Höchstmaß an Intelligenz und Zielgerichtetheit den Schaden
auf der Seite totalitärer Terrorkommandos maximieren kann und gleichzeitig zivile
Opfer so gering wie möglich hält.
Also, zielgerichtet, 4000 Pager auf einmal zu sprengen.
Wo man nicht weiß, fährt der eine gerade mit 200 km h über die Autobahn,
ist der andere gerade im Kreise seiner Familie.
Für ihn ist das brillant, das zu machen, weshalb wir uns nochmal anhören.
Ja gut, im Gegensatz zu Flächenbombardements ist das wieder zielgerichtet.
Man muss nur die Maßstäbe klären. Ja, die Maßstäbe sind einfach verzogen.
Wir hören uns den Korrespondentenbericht der Tagesthemen dazu an.
Jeder wollte mir berichten, weil es ja so unglaublich klingt wie in einem Agenten-Thriller,
was er erlebt hat, als es die ersten Explosionen schon gab, wie man im Supermarkt
Menschen hat zusammenbrechend sehen, wie ein Kind seinem Papa den piepsenden
Pager bringen wollte und genau in dem Moment ist er explodiert.
Und als wäre dieser Schock nicht genug, dann eben heute die zweite Explosionswelle.
Kurzzeitig ist hier die komplette Telekommunikation am Nachmittag zusammengebrochen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das damit zusammenhängt, aber genau dann haben sich eben
diese Explosionen ereignet.
Dieses Mal Walkie Talkies, unter anderem auch auf Trauerfeiern von getöteten Hisbollah-Anhängern.
Offenbar waren diese Walkie Talkies neu angeschafft worden von der Hisbollah,
ebenso wie die Pager. heute auch wieder Tote, heute auch wieder Verletzte an
diesem verrückten zweiten Tag in Beirut.
Ja, also aus so einer immensen, großen Aktion noch einen Double Tap zu machen.
Am Tag danach nochmal die nächsten geredet. Also das ist einfach,
das ist nicht brillant. Das ist so grausam.
Also sowas darf einfach gar nicht geschehen. Ich will jetzt nicht sagen,
dann lieber eine Atombombe, aber es ist einfach völlig daneben.
Ein IDF-Sprecher, auch im Heute-Journal.
Nein, wir kämpfen gegen Khashoggi und gegen Hamas.
Ja, Herr Hagari, aber dabei sterben eben auch Menschen, unbeteiligte Menschen
in Gaza und Unbeteiligte im Libanon. Jetzt im Moment.
Wir tun alles, was wir können, um Schäden in der Bevölkerung zu vermeiden.
Hamas will das aber so. Sie wollen die als menschliche Schilde und sie hindern
sogar die Bevölkerung, daran wegzugehen.
Naja, im Libanon werden die nicht gehindert, im Libanon wissen sie nicht wohin,
in Gaza wissen sie nicht wohin.
Also ich meine, wir haben es da mit terroristischen Organisationen,
sowohl bei Hamas wie Jezbollah zu tun, die führen nichts Gutes im Schilde,
wie wir jetzt hier schon mehrmals betont haben.
Zugleich kann man nicht sagen, naja, wenn die halt so sind, dann ist das so,
dann ist das aber auch deren Schuld, wenn jetzt der Bevölkerung was passiert.
Sondern man hat dann auch die Verantwortung gegenüber den Zivilisten und dann
kann man nicht unaufhörlich Kriegsverbrechen begehen und sagen,
naja, die würden wir ja gar nicht begehen müssen, wenn wir nicht es mit diesen
Terroreinheiten zu tun hätten.
Ja, wenn man noch Armin Laschet spielen und dann noch zwei zum Familienthema,
also wie sehr da Familien in Mitleidenschaft gerissen werden.
Armin Laschet war hier im Gespräch klar, alle sind jetzt irgendwie im Gespräch in dem Fall am 17.10.
Keine Ahnung, Armin Laschet hat sich ja gerade wieder ein bisschen hochgekämpft,
so aus dieser Versenkung durch die vorliegende Bundestagswahl und so.
Wird irgendwie abgefeiert, auf Bahnhöfen fotografiert, das ist unser Mann, was auch immer.
Das Gespräch über Israel ist also wirklich völlig neben der Spur.
Aber wenn es so gewesen ist, dass man die einzige Demokratie im Nahen Osten,
deren Staatspräsident sich zum humanitären Völkerrecht verpflichtet,
dass man die jetzt mit Bedingungen versieht, ihnen in einer Notlage nicht Waffen
liefert, weil das Auswärtige Amt, weil Frau Baerbock da bedenken hat,
sie hat das ja gestern weggewischt.
Aber wenn das so war, dass man von Israel wirklich eine Erklärung erwartet,
wir begehen keinen Völkermord,
dann ist das nicht in Ordnung, dann ist das kein Umgang mit einem Land,
von dem man ansonsten immer die Staatsräson im Munde führt.
Dann soll man von den großen Worten Abstand nehmen.
Dann soll man sagen, wir behandeln Israel wie die Türkei, wie Katar,
wie andere, dann kann man sich solche Dinge erlauben.
Ja, wir müssen Israel wie Katar, Türkei und alle anderen behandeln,
denn Völkermord verbittet sich.
Und ich will dann auch keine Erklärung, dass wir keinen Völkermord begehen,
sondern ich will, dass kein Völkermord begangen wird.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der Begriff Völkermord...
Wir erwarten von allen Ländern kein Völkermord.
Man kann keinen Krieg gegen Zivilisten davon nicht führen, man darf keine Kriegsverbrechen
begehen. Das findet ja offenbar hier statt.
Und jetzt sind die Gerichte...
Noch nicht so weit, dass sie da alles voll geklärt haben, aber wenn so und so
viele zivile Opfer da sind, wenn man eine Million Flüchtlinge produziert,
da kann man nicht sagen, wir machen alles weiter.
Und was ja so interessant ist jetzt in der Kritik an den Grünen,
die hier von Laschet artikuliert wird, ist ja,
dass die Grünen ja vollkommen, also mit den Grünen meine ich jetzt Baerbock
mit dem Auswärtigen Namen, vollkommen hinter Israel am Ende stehen.
Sie wollten ja nur so eine kleine Versicherung haben.
Warum eigentlich, habe ich mich gefragt. Wieso wollen sie jetzt so eine Versicherung,
ihr macht aber bitte keinen Völkermord und keine Kriegsverbrechen mit unseren Waffen.
Naja, ich denke schon, dass es ja so ist, dass man da sich so eine Hintertür
offen hält, dass man sagt, also wenn da was passiert und ihr habt uns aber zugesichert,
dass ihr das mit unseren Waffen gar nicht machen wollt,
dann haben wir nichts damit zu tun, denn ihr habt uns das ja versichert,
dass ihr das nicht macht.
Also ich glaube, dass da durchaus die Überlegung war im Auswärtigen Amt,
dass man sagte, puh, wenn wir das jetzt liefern, die machen so weiter.
Nicht, dass wir am Ende in Den Haag sitzen, weil Israel wird nicht in Den Haag
sitzen. Da wird nicht Netanjahu in Den Haag sitzen.
Und da werden auch nicht andere von der israelischen Regierung in Den Haag sitzen
und auch nicht irgendwelche Militärs.
Aber dass man dann so dachte, wir laufen ja auch ständig nach Den Haag und sagen,
wir müssen da Kriegsverbrechen da und dort.
Nicht, dass wir mal da involviert werden. und ich glaube, man wollte sich so
eine kleine Rückversicherung einbauen, aber man muss ja ganz klar sagen,
also man muss ja ganz klar sagen, wenn man.
Einen Partner hat, dem man Waffen liefert und man will von dem eine Zusicherung
haben, dass er bitte keinen Völkermord und keine Kriegsverbrechen verübt,
dann ist das Misstrauen ja so groß.
Also wenn ich jetzt sage, kannst du mir ein Brotmesser leihen und du sagst,
ja, aber unterschreib mir erstmal, dass du niemanden damit abstichst,
dann solltest du mir besser gar kein Messer leihen, wenn du so wenig Vertrauen
hast, dass ich durchaus dazu fällt.
Bestechende Logik. Also das heißt doch ganz klar, dass man offenbar da keine
Waffen hinliefern sollte mehr.
Und man macht aber weiter damit und wollte sich nur selbst einen schlanken Fuß
dadurch machen, das glaube ich ist der Punkt.
Denn die Waffen führen ja vor Ort zu etwas. Jetzt habe ich ja in einem der vergangenen
Podcasts schon mal angemerkt, heute fast 100 Jahre später steht Michel Friedmann
auf der Bühne und sagt im Land der Täter,
die Nazis haben 50 meiner Familienmitglieder getötet.
Und damit hat er natürlich sozusagen ein Publikum in der Aufmerksamkeit,
um dann Punkte zu machen.
Und ich sehe zum Beispiel auf LinkedIn und wo man sich heute so rumtreibt,
dass doch sehr viele Leute sehr beeindruckt waren von der Rede,
die Michel Friedmann zum Beispiel im hessischen Parlament gehalten hat,
wo ja auch AfD-Leute anwesend sind und so.
Und dann hieß es in einigen Kommentaren mir gegenüber, das könnte man ja so
nicht vergleichen und so weiter und ich sage, nee genau, ich vergleiche das ja auch nicht.
Ich sage ja nicht, bei dem einen ist aber noch ein Holocaust im Hintergrund
und das andere, da gibt es gerade Streit darüber, Gerichte urteilen jetzt,
welche Begriffe man da wählt.
Wir können das mal ganz deutlich sagen, Israel verhübt keinen Holocaust. Punkt.
Genau. Am Ende geht es mir ja darum, die von mir ausgeflaggte und für alle Hörerinnen
jetzt sozusagen in der Sensibilität vorhandene,
Und Beobachtung von unmittelbarer Lebenswelt, Familie, Intimsphäre,
wie auch immer, da wo man die Menschen namentlich kennt und um sie trauert,
wenn sie nicht mehr da sind.
Dass es da jetzt Einzelfälle gibt, wo Leute sagen, ich habe 50 Mitglieder meiner Familie verloren.
So, und es gab jetzt zwei Anlässe oder Ereignisse, in denen das auch mal in
Zahlen ausgedrückt thematisiert wurde.
Zum einen Steffen Seibert, lange Jahre, also eigentlich der längste,
ich glaube bestimmt so sieben, acht Jahre oder so, war ja Regierungssprecher
für Angela Merkel und ist jetzt Botschafter für Deutschland in Israel.
Und er war bei Ronsheimer im Podcast zu Gast. Hast du das gehört?
Nein. Das ist wirklich gut. Also Steffen Seibert haben wir ja immer sehr kritisiert
in der Bundespressekonferenz für das etwas Unkonkrete, die Frage im Raum stehen
lassende, nicht zitierfähige Wort der Kanzlerin.
Das ist hier ein bisschen anders. Also man merkt, dass er aus der einen Welt,
in der er, ich bin Angela Merkels rechte Hand und wir verrichten hier Gottes
Werk, Zu, hier ist es nicht gut.
Ich bin hier irgendwo, wo meine alten Maßstäbe nicht gelten,
sondern hier denken und leben Leute anders.
Und das ist sehr schön nachzuhören, dass aus Steffen Seibert jetzt wieder ein Mensch geworden ist.
Der nicht einfach nur eine deutsche Regierungslinie in Tel Aviv durchpaukt sondern
der einfach vor Ort auch Freunde hat,
die auch nicht einverstanden sind damit, was ihre Regierung macht er jetzt auf
der Publikumsseite feststellt eine Bevölkerung kann ganz schön unzufrieden mit
ihrer Regierung sein und so weiter,
und in dieser Maßgabe finde ich unter Saibatscher Historie, kann man sich das
sowieso nochmal anhören und er kommt hier eben drauf zu sprechen.
Es ist ein Krieg entstanden, den Israel so nicht gesucht hat,
Und der nun ein Mehrfrontenkrieg ist. Und das zu sehen bei einem Land,
mit dem man sich stark identifiziert oder mit dessen Existenzrecht ich mich stark identifiziere,
das ist sehr schmerzlich und genauso finde ich es extrem schmerzlich zu sehen,
wie Zehntausende von palästinensischen Leben ausgelöscht werden.
Oder hier palästinensischen Israelis zu begegnen, die Familie in Gaza haben,
von denen vielleicht 26 Mitglieder nicht mehr leben.
In meiner Welt ist Steffen Seibert bis zu diesem Gespräch jemand gewesen,
der selbst wenn jemand kommt und sagt, ich habe eine Hochzeit gefeiert mit 300
Gästen und alle wurden ermordet,
der das nochmal schön biegen kann.
Der dir nochmal erklärt, ohne die Zahl in den Mund zu nehmen und das Thema zitierfähig
in seinem eigenen Satzbau unterzubringen, dir nochmal erklärt,
warum das jetzt im Großen und Ganzen und so weiter.
Also in der Hinsicht, wenn selbst Steffen Seibert jetzt einfach die Worte ernst
nimmt, die er ausspricht,
wählt und die Zahl nennt, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass irgendwer noch
durchhält mit seiner Seibert'schen Strategie. Weißt du, was ich meine?
Offenbar bei CDU schon.
Es versuchen noch einige, aber selbst Steffen Seibert.
Bei der FDP ist das stark.
Aber gut, er ist ja auch vor Ort. Auch vor Ort, wir hören hier SWR Kultur.
Seibert war am 16.10. bei Ronsheimer. Das ist jetzt 18.10.
Eine junge Palästinenserin hier in Deutschland nennt auch Zahlen.
Als Palästinenser ist es gar nicht so einfach, sich zu äußern,
ohne direkt zum Beispiel als Antisemit abgestempelt zu werden.
Und hinzu kommt noch der ganze Schmerz und die Sorge, die man hat, die man trägt.
Deswegen bleiben die lieber im Hintergrund.
Und ich kenne ganz viele Familien und ganz viele Paisenlenser,
die sich nicht trauen zu sprechen.
Sie selbst traut sich. Am 31. Oktober 2023 twittert sie.
Ich habe heute bei der Bombardierung von Jebalia in Gaza 19 Familienmitglieder
auf einen Schlag verloren.
Insgesamt sind mehr als 60 Mitglieder meiner Familie durch israelische Bomben getötet worden.
Warum wird unser Leid in Deutschland ignoriert? Ich spreche auch für die komplette
Community, würde ich sagen.
Seit Oktober fühlen wir uns sehr missverstanden und verdächtig.
Ich habe immer das Gefühl, dass ich mich zunächst beweisen muss,
dass man kein Menschenfeind ist.
Und man muss durch diese ganzen Hürden, bevor man eigentlich seinen Punkt nennen
kann. Und der Punkt ist dann einfach nur, meine Familie ist am sterben.
Meine Familie flieht gerade vor Bomben. Die leben noch in Gaza.
Mein Papa hat zehn Geschwister. Mein Papa ist nach Deutschland gekommen mit
17, 18. Nach seinem Abitur hat er hier studiert.
Und ist dann hier geblieben, um uns Kindern eine bessere Zukunft zu bieten.
Der Rest ist dort. Wo sind deine Großeltern jetzt?
Meine Oma ist in Derebelah. Die schläft da in einer Moschee, soweit ich weiß.
Und mein Opa liegt am Strand in einem Zelt.
Ja, es tut ihm natürlich auch nicht gut. Die sind alt und krank.
Warum sind die nicht zusammen? Die bleiben immer lieber verstreut,
damit es, wenn die Bombe einstieg, damit nicht eine ganze Familie ausgelöscht wird.
Also ein elementares Diaspora-Leben.
Gehst du gerade einkaufen? Okay, dann warte ich noch. Wenn wir uns da sehen
und da passiert irgendwas, sind wir Nummer 61 und 62 der Familie.
Also das sind wirklich Ausmaße, die müssen nicht nur zu anderem Reden führen,
sondern auch zu anderem politischen Handeln. Das ist nicht tolerierbar. Das geht einfach nicht.
Da kann man nicht nochmal mit Nachdruck wie Baerbock sagen, das ist aber jetzt
auch nicht so schön, sondern da muss man anders halten.
Wir hören jetzt mal gerade hier den Clip von Bibi, also Netanyahu macht mal
eine Ansage an die Libanesen.
Man denkt sich so, was sollen die tun?
As Israel expands its operations against Hezbollah in Lebanon,
the Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu has made a direct appeal to the Lebanese people.
In a televised address, he said his forces had killed the presumed successor
of the Hezbollah leader Hassan Nasrallah, who was assassinated last month.
And he urged the Lebanese people to rise up against Hezbollah in order to save their country.
Don't let these terrorists destroy your future any more than they've already done.
Stand up and take your country back.
You have an opportunity that hasn't existed in decades, an opportunity to take
care of the future of your children and grandchildren.
You have,
Die Hezbollah ist ja da eine Partei, die seit Jahrzehnten regiert.
Das ist eine Partei mit Waffen.
Deswegen sind sie auch zugleich eine Terrormiliz. Was soll,
Eine Zivilbevölkerung jetzt tun, mal schnell eine Revolution machen,
also es wird einfach so gesagt, man kann ja sich eine Welt ohne Terror wünschen
und sollte dies auch tun, nur die Tatsache ist ja einfach,
dass diese Strukturen sich da verfestigt haben und die sind auch nicht kaputt zu bomben einfach,
beziehungsweise sind sie nur zu dem Preis kaputt zu bomben, wie wir das jetzt
gerade sehen, dass die Zivilbevölkerung mit dort ausgebombt wird.
Und da kann man nicht sagen, ja warum macht ihr eigentlich keine Revolution,
warum habt ihr eigentlich keine liberale Demokratie da?
Das ist einfach nur der Taschenspielertrick, den wir ja heute schon mehrfach betont haben.
Dulde es nicht länger, ich unterstelle dir das als aktive Handlung. Du bist schuld.
Wir springen mal gerade zu Ari Schavid, der ist Autor von My Promised Land.
Er zählt eigentlich so zu den liberalen, linksliberalen Israelis.
Jemand wie Omri Böhm würde da sicherlich widersprechen. Und hier kann man so
ein bisschen sehen, naja, also es gibt zwar Protest gegen die israelische Regierung
im eigenen Lande, aber man kann jetzt auch sehen, dass auf der liberalen Seite,
also er hat lange Zeit für Haaretz geschrieben und sowas,
dass auf der liberalen Seite doch eigentlich auch ein großes Einverständnis
herrscht mit dem Krieg, den Netanyahu da führt.
Das war nur die Symptom, die erupte.
Was wir hier ist ein drei-tier war, in einem senschen.
Du hast die local-level oder sphere-of Israel-Khamas, du hast die regional-level-of-Iran,
und du hast die global-level-of-the-Chinese-Russian-North-Korean-Iran-Axis-attacking-world-order.
And Israel went down into the local level.
So in my mind, the real significance of October 7, beyond the Jewish and democratic
aspect, is that it was an attack on the free world.
It should have been perceived as Ukraine, too, at the very least,
because you have a systematic attack.
What you see now, that Iran is the source of instability, and I would even say
the source of evil in the Middle East. Iran, I'm talking about the regime, not the people.
I'm a great believer in the Iranian people.
I think there is a lot of hope and promise in the Iranian people and their culture and their nation.
But the regime in Iran proved to be much more dangerous in all forms.
Wir hören jetzt noch weiter, wir haben schon gemerkt, es geht also um das Böse,
das sieht er jetzt in der iranischen Regierung, es geht ihm nicht um die Iraner an sich,
es geht ihm darum, dass wir es mit einem Schichtenkrieg zu tun haben,
also ein Krieg in drei Schichten und eigentlich geht es hier um einen Angriff gegen die Freiheit,
er vergleicht das dann mit Putins Angriff, wo ich auch sagen würde,
naja, das ist schon ein sehr großer Unterschied, Also der Akt,
den die Hamas gemacht hat,
dass sie da innerhalb einer Aktion Pogrom gegen 1400 Juden anrichtet und das
andere ist jetzt ein großer militärischer Krieg,
der geführt wird von Putin.
Aber das ist jetzt schon mal etwas, was ja hier so zusammenbindet und man fragt sich, wohin führt es?
Aber wir haben ja den Ukraine-Krieg jetzt auch darunter, also es ist so eine
Perfidie, er da greift, dass der Angreifer ausgezehrt wird.
Materiell und ideell. Also Putin fällt es immer schwerer, den Russen zu erklären,
was da passiert und vom Finanzieren ganz zu schweigen.
Ja.
Und wenn er jetzt hier so eine Argumentation macht, ist ja schon interessant
zu sagen, der eigentliche Gegner ist doch Iran.
Warum verschießen sie ihr Pulver gegen Menschen, um die die ganze Welt trauert?
Ja.
Also Menschen in Gaza und im Libanon. Einfach nur, weil man über Hamas und Hisbollah
eine Rechtfertigung machen kann.
Im Sinne von, jetzt kämpfen wir gegen die Bösen und sie schlagen nicht zurück.
Was ja beim Iran anders wäre. Die würden das ja so nicht machen,
sondern dann wahrscheinlich anders zurückschlagen.
Ja und die Terrorbezeichnung ist wichtig. Das kommen wir gleich nochmal.
Adam Tooze wird uns das einordnen. Also mit Krieg gegen den Terror kommt man
sehr weit. Wir hören mal weiter.
A year or two, Saudi Arabia will go nuclear, Egypt will go nuclear,
Algeria will go nuclear, Turkey will go nuclear.
You will have a multi-nuclear system, something we never tried before,
in the world's most unstable region.
And that will spread to third world countries, to Africa, to Asia.
So I think that actually my prime minister was right when he talked about the
Iranian nuclear issue for many years.
His major mistake that he made it an Israeli issue. It's not an Israeli issue.
This endangers all of us. So if we take the tragedy of October 7 and understand
what was exposed and revealed on that terrible Saturday,
I think it will somehow give meaning to this fight because it will be a wake-up
call for all of us that we must unite, get over our differences, and fight evil.
We're faced with evil. And I do believe that if we do wake up now.
Er plädiert ja hier für eine völlige Ausweitung des Krieges,
also überall dort, wo das Böse ist.
Was er beschreibt, ist ja wirklich interessant.
Also Heusken hat ja damals schon gesagt, direkt nach dem 7. Oktober,
die Hamas hat eine Falle gestellt. Israel sollte da nicht reintappen.
Jetzt ist aber Israel da reingetappt. In einem Jahr verstricken sie sich und
sie schaffen es nicht mal, den Hamas zu verbringen.
Da zu finden, den Hamas-Chef im Gase, sondern der wird so aus Versehen ermordet oder getötet.
Was ja bedeutet, wenn das jetzt noch so weitergeht und die Iraner kommen nächstes
Jahr und sagen, oder es wird so aufgedeckt, sie sind jetzt kurz davor,
also Iran hat schon eine Rede fertig geschrieben, wo es heißt,
wir haben jetzt drei Atombomben gebaut, dass dann die Welt sagt,
nee, sorry Israel, aber wir können jetzt nicht auch noch gegen den Iran.
Obwohl das das eigentliche Anliegen immer war, diese letzten Sprünge des Iran
dann militärisch einfach zu bekämpfen.
Bloß keine Atomwaffe. Sondern es kann durchaus sein, dass das ganze Konstrukt,
wie es jetzt aufgebaut ist und wen es, also den globalen Süden hat es völlig
davon getrieben und man merkt ja, dass auch die Europäer,
also wir Deutsche sind ja im Grunde die letzten, die noch so an der Seite Israels stehen,
dass einfach alle Kräfte aufgebraucht sind.
Nicht nur materiell, sondern dann auch ideell zu sagen, wir führen jetzt einen Krieg gegen den Iran.
Ja, das ist gut möglich.
Sondern dann zeigt man einfach Netanyahu einen Vogel und es wird die erste Rede
sein, die er wahrscheinlich wirklich ernst meint.
Wir müssen jetzt gegen Iran vorgehen und dann würde er keine Und das ist ja eine Kritik.
Die man wirklich auf allen Seiten findet. Auch sehr stark zum Beispiel bei denen,
die sehr sogar die Netanyahu-Regierung unterstützen und die auch sehr für diese
Waffenlieferungen sind,
dass man sagt, eigentlich hat die israelische Armee und hat die israelische
Regierung keine Strategie, keine lange große Strategie.
Sie kann Ereignisse schaffen, wie auch diese Pager-Sache, aber wo führt es dann hin?
Wer kommt jetzt rein? Man hat, man produziert eine See des Vakants und fragt
sich dann, ja und nun, wer organisiert das?
Also wer macht jetzt Nation Building oder irgendwas müsste in dieser Art angeboten werden.
Das wird aber nicht gemacht und dadurch hat man natürlich wieder Vakuum und das wird gefüllt.
Dann vielleicht mit noch Schlimmeren.
Wir gehen nochmal einen Schritt zurück zu BBC.
Ben Bowen wird jetzt uns ein bisschen die Lage mal schildern noch bei Gaza.
Is pushing for a proportionate response on military targets.
At the same time, Israel is intensifying its pressure on northern Gaza.
The medical charity, MSF, and other relief agencies active there say Israel
is turning the north into an unlivable wasteland.
Israel does not allow journalists into Gaza, apart from a few highly controlled
visits with the Israeli military.
So I went to look in over their fortifications near the now closed Eres checkpoint
that used to be the main entrance to Gaza.
On the other side of the wall was massive destruction.
Heavy Israeli airstrikes and artillery attacks made it feel like the first months of the war.
Columns of smoke rose from strikes in the direction of Jabalia Refugee Camp
and the most northerly Gaza towns, Beit Hanun and Bed-Lakhir.
Israelis are angry and frustrated that their army has not achieved the Gaza
war aims of destroying Hamas and freeing the hostages taken on the 7th of October last year.
Hoping for a breakthrough to victory, the army seems to be adopting elements
of a plan made by retired generals to force the 400,000 or so civilians still
in the north to flee south.
The next phase of the so-called General's Plan then calls for a total siege,
stopping all food, water and other necessities and treating all Palestinians
left behind as legitimate military targets.
Es kann folglich noch viel schlimmer werden.
Retired General Ghiora Ireland, who conceived the plan, Said Hamas and its civilian
sympathisers would then have to surrender or starve.
Ultra-nationalists in the Israeli cabinet want to replace Palestinians in northern
Gaza with Jewish settlers.
As for Lebanon, Israel's strategy for victory over Hezbollah is not clear.
Its decision to escalate the war in Lebanon could, like its previous invasions,
turn into a long war of attrition.
That was our international editor Jeremy Bowen.
Nun sagt man, Israels Existenzrecht steht auf dem Spiel.
Aber stimmt das wirklich jetzt gerade?
Also ist die Existenz Israels bedroht?
Ist Israel bedroht nur von, also ist umzingelt nur von Feinden?
Dem widersprechen ja auch Leute aus der islamischen Welt.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass Israel dann nur Feinde vorfindet, aber viele sind gegen
das Vorgehen der jetzigen Regierung.
Da war beispielsweise bei der UN Außenminister Ayman Safadi von Jordanien,
der sich nach der Netanyahu-Rede spontan an die Öffentlichkeit,
an die Presse dort wandte und Folgendes sagte.
Ich möchte noch eine Frage. Der Präsidenten ist hier heute und sagte,
dass Israel ist mit denjenigen, die zu zerstören, ein敦werf.
Wir sind hier Mitglied der Muslime-Arab-Kommittität, mit 57 Armen Muslim countries.
And I can tell you here very unequivocally all of us are willing,
right now guarantee the security of Israel in the context of Israel ending the
occupation and allowing for the emergence of a Palestinian state.
He is creating that danger because he simply does not want the two-state solution.
And if he does not want the two-state solution, can you ask the Israeli officials,
what is their endgame other than just wars and wars and wars?
I'm telling you, all of us in the Arab world here, we want a peace in which
Israel lives in peace and security,
except normalisiert mit allen Arabischen Ländern in dem Kontext von dem Ende
der Ockupation, dem Ausdruck von Arabischen Territory, der Erdbeeren von einem
independenten palästinischen Staat auf Jun 4,
1906, mit der Ockupi-Burse als Kapital. Das ist unsere Narrative.
Und wir werden Israel Sicherheit in diesem Kontext garantieren.
Können Sie sich fragen, was ist der Narrative, außer dass ich weitergehen werde,
ich werde das und das und das und das und das.
Das ist erstaunlich. Um das zu bewerten, Müssen wir kurz kontrastieren,
was Minuten vorher Netanyahu dort im Plenum sagte.
Wir kriegen das reportiert von Stefan Detjen, also Politikchef des Deutschlandfunks,
der dort mit vor Ort war und in dessen Ton man auch hört, wie ich jetzt sagen
würde, umso erstaunlicher,
dass danach einer der Angesprochenen solche versöhnlichen Wüste dort überhaupt aussprach.
Netanyahu zeichnet das Bild einer binären Welt, einer klaren Wahl,
die nur eine richtige Entscheidung zulässt.
Von einer heiligen Mission ist die Rede und der Premierminister lässt keinen
Zweifel daran, dass Israel seinen Kampf mit aller Härte fortsetzen wird.
Die Forderungen der USA, europäischer und arabischer Staaten nach einem Waffenstillstand
im Libanon hatte er schon vor seiner Rede zurückgewiesen.
Wir werden gewinnen, ruft Netanjahu. Wie auch manche andere Redner hat der Anhänger
mitgebracht, die ihm von der Zuschauertribüne aus zujubeln.
Es sind in diesem Jahr besonders viele.
Im Saal dagegen sind die Bänke der meisten Mitgliedstaaten leer.
Die Verurteilungen seines Landes durch die Generalversammlung,
die Kritik am israelischen Feldzug in Gaza, die Verfahren vor dem Internationalen
Gerichtshof, der Haftbefehlsantrag des Chefanklägers beim Internationalen Strafgerichtshof,
Für Netanjahu nichts als Antisemitismus, der in der Generalversammlung der Vereinten
Nationen seine Heimstatt habe.
Für die Palästinenser gibt es in diesem Haus der Dunkelheit immer ein Heimspiel.
Sie wissen, dass es in diesem antisemitischen Sumpf immer eine Mehrheit dafür
gibt, den jüdischen Staat zu dämonisieren.
Das ist eine anti-israelische Gesellschaft, die glaubt, die Erde sei flach.
Auf der Tribüne jubeln bei diesen Worten die Klaköre. Wenn von Palästinensern
die Rede ist, wird laut Buh gerufen.
Ordnungskräfte des UN-Sicherheitspersonals kommen, fordern zur Ruhe auf,
drohen Anhänger Netanjahus von der Tribüne zu verweisen.
Bevor die Situation eskaliert, endet die Rede mit dem Ruf Am Israel Chai, es lebe Israel.
Am Israel Chai, the people of Israel live now, tomorrow, forever. Thank you.
Man kann den Israelis nur schnell eine neue Regierung wünschen.
Also hier ist einfach, hier muss man so ein bisschen das Wort zurückgeben.
Netanyahu hat die Palästinenser und die Limanesen aufgerufen,
ihr habt doch jetzt die einmalige Gelegenheit, was gegen eure Regierung zu machen.
Und hier kann die Welt einfach nur sagen, ich würde sagen, es ist eine gerade
sehr günstige Gelegenheit, jetzt mal das Wort zu ergreifen, denn das geht nicht.
Also jeder, der das hört, ist auf eurer Seite, wenn ihr da sagt, das geht nicht.
Wir springen jetzt zum Clip mit Adam Tooster, der die Linien ein bisschen nachzeichnet,
denn er hatte im Guardian einen Artikel geschrieben und fragte sich,
was ist da eigentlich los?
Irgendwie die USA sind doch Unterstützer und nicht und wie ist das eigentlich?
Er war dann bei Novara Media zu Gast, also ein unabhängiges Medium.
Bei YouTube kann man sich das ansehen. Und da zeichnet er jetzt,
das hören wir uns direkt an, die Linien nach.
Quasi-official mouthpiece for this is the New York Times, which has produced
a series of seemingly very well-sourced articles,
all of which long-read form, which basically are centred on leaks from within
the White House about how Biden is spitting mad at Netanyahu and swearing and
totally frustrated with their
inability to get the Israelis to do anything that they want them to do.
Und die implikation ist, dass sie die Israelis zu signieren,
straightaway zu ceasefire, mit moderativen Ja.
Du wirst es auch gesehen haben, es gibt dann so Longreads, die nochmal beschreiben,
dass eigentlich die Biden-Administration doch warnt und mahnt und dann passiert aber nichts.
Adam Toos schildert das so, dass es das gibt, ist aber da, wie wir an seiner
Stimme schon hören, skeptisch. Er geht dann auf Ezra Klein ein.
Und dann die mehr hoher Version des Podcasts ist Ezra Klein,
wo er in einer sehr expliziven Art von 6 bis 12 Monaten hat.
Ezra Klein ist die New York Times-Fraktion.
Commentator and has this huge podcast. Folks should listen if you want to get
an idea of where mainstream American opinion is on the liberal side.
You need to listen to Ezra Klein.
He's had people like Haas on, formerly of the Council of Foreign Relations,
which is the establishment think tank of foreign policy in the US,
in which they've been talking about the need for an independent US foreign policy.
The implication being that right now, basically, Washington is being yanked
around by, on the one hand, Ukraine and Zelensky und ihre Entscheidung,
die Krieg zu kämpfen, was sich in der Nähe von einem Tod aussieht.
Und auf der anderen Seite Netanyahu in Israel.
Das ist mir auch aufgefallen bei Esra Klein, dass er ja Netanyahu kritisiert,
seine Gäste sagen, die Amerikaner haben gar keinen Einfluss mehr oder keinen richtigen Einfluss.
Und da setzt Adam Tous ein großes Fragezeichen dahinter, ob diese Einschätzung wirklich stimmt.
Und so, die zwei versions, eine ist ein sort of colourful story über Tantrums
in Washington, und die andere ist ein Strategieger question über die,
wo ist amerikanische foreign policy?
Implant, dass es etwas ist, und ich glaube, die Thought Experiment der Guardian
piece, und natürlich, es ist ein bisschen mehr als das, aber es begann mit der
Frage, was, well, was wir tatsächlich view das eine andere Art?
Was wir tatsächlich sehen diese pieces als concertedly tied together?
Not in the sense that I think that, you know, the United States or Biden was
at all interested actually in the escalation in either space,
because I think the Biden administration is interested in an escalation v. China.
That idea is in fact quite well socialized and not even denied,
I think, in high places in Washington, that the United States is a revisionist
power with regard to China.
Tues folgt jetzt daraus.
But the argument, the contention would be that as things, events have unfolded,
as Russia's aggression became manifest, and then October the 7th and the Israeli reaction,
essentially the Biden administration have found ways of instrumentalizing this,
functionalizing this, and rethought, I think, their assessment of the global situation,
and have moved the US onto a front foot position of basically a more proactive,
high tension strategy in three arenas at once.
So in Eastern Europe, the Middle East and in the South China Sea.
Was hier ja gesagt wird ist, naja, vielleicht ist das gar nicht denen so unrecht,
dass das gerade da so läuft.
Ich meine, man kann ja offiziell immer sagen, das sei ja was Schlimmes und das
muss auch aufhören und bitte beschießen sie jetzt nicht UN-Truppen.
Und sicherlich ist niemand in den USA dafür, UN-Truppen zu beschießen,
aber dass man jetzt doch bereit ist zu sagen,
naja, intern, dass dieser Preis nun der Preis ist, der zu zahlen ist und das
ist uns eigentlich jetzt gerade recht, dass der Konfliktherd so verläuft und
dass man vielleicht doch gar nicht Netanjahu,
so feindlich gesonnen ist, denn es gibt ja, und das ist ja etwas,
worauf dann Esra Klein immer wieder hinweist,
diese eigenartige Konstellation, Dass man zum einen öffentlich Netanjahu bereit
ist zu schelten, dass man eigene Hilfsgüter schickt, sie zum Teil abwirft an Stränden oder so etwas.
Und dass man dann aber nicht sagt, jetzt liefern wir keine Waffen mehr,
sondern man liefert gleichzeitig Waffen.
Und diese Doppelgesichtigkeit, die das ja hier hat, die scheint vielleicht doch
eher so ein Spiel zu sein, naja, für die eigene Bevölkerung,
vor denen muss man sich noch rechtfertigen.
Aber eigentlich finden wir das geopolitisch gedacht gar nicht so falsch.
Es sind jedenfalls zwei Kriege mit jeweils sehr großen Überraschungen.
Die Leute sind glaube ich immer noch beeindruckt in Amerika,
wie wenig die Russen schaffen militärisch und wie viel es ihnen kostet.
Also jetzt nochmal zehn Jahre so ein Krieg und Russland ist ausgezehrt einfach.
Außer Atombomben ist da nichts mehr.
Die holen ja jetzt schon aus Nordkorea, die Jungs.
Genau, also wirklich dann auch keine Binnenwirtschaft mehr, die irgendwie noch
die Bevölkerung versorgt, sondern jetzt geht ja auch schon wirklich in hohen
Prozenten alles in Sachen, die man dann einfach zerstört auf fremdem Gebiet.
Ist ja bescheuert. Und in...
Israel, würde ich sagen, ist auch eine große Überraschung da,
wie wenig sich der Iran wehrt.
Und dass man jetzt einfach sich fragt, wie weit kann man es eigentlich treiben, also Brute Force.
Und die ist ja Biden dann sehr vorsichtig.
Also wenn der Iran doch mal zuckt, dann gibt es schon sehr klare Ansagen,
jetzt nicht übertreiben oder nimm den Sieg, als dann Netanyahu nochmal weiter wollte.
Aber solange das jetzt alles so verläuft, ist es doch interessant,
dass die Amerikaner gar nicht so viel dagegen haben.
Adam Toos sagte auch angesprochen darauf, wie denn die Weltöffentlichkeit dazu steht.
Das müsste doch der US-Regierung auch zu denken geben.
Mit regard to Israel you just have to discount global public opinion that just
doesn't matter doesn't feature in the decision making circles they're bewildered
that people don't get on side with that Aber sie sind nicht interessiert,
sie sind nicht antwortet.
Das ist keine Erinnerung. Es gibt wirklich eine Identifikation des Interests
des USA mit dem Zionist-Projekt,
die ist utterly explizit in der Person von Biden, der auf Rekord sagt,
dass er denkt, dass Zionismus nur etwas für die jüdische Menschen ist.
Das ist auch logisch korrekt. Zionismus ist natürlich eine Ideologie,
die sehr separat von der jüdischen Identität ist. Und er ist ein stolzer Zionist.
Das ist ja wirklich verrückt jetzt. wir sind in einer Weltlage,
in der sagen wir mal so für drei Monate lang eine Wortmeldung eines Ringvoters
in Pennsylvania weltgeschichtliche Konsequenzen haben könnte.
Einfach nur indem er sagt, ich finde das nicht gut, wie da mit den Palästinensern umgegangen wird.
Weil dann würde die Macht shiften zu Trump. Die Demokraten hätten diese Stimme
dann dort verloren und es würde sofort verrechnet in einer amerikanischen Präsidentenwahl.
Das Zeitfenster ist jetzt noch fünf Tage und dann war es das.
Danach ist ihm auch wieder egal, was in Amerika passiert. So,
dann ist Trump endgültig besiegt oder er regiert, aber dann werden sozusagen
die Karten einfach neu gedealt und dann wird halt die nächste Legislaturperiode durchgehauen.
Aber das ist schon beeindruckend, also dass die Weltöffentlichkeit da keine
Rolle spielt, ja, aber dass für eine kurze Zeit...
Zumindest in den Swing States es nicht egal war, was die Öffentlichkeit denkt,
sondern jede Minute ein Polling stattfindet.
Wie finden die das gerade, was der Biden und die Hamas und so.
Das finde ich so witzig. Also witzig im Sinne von witzig.
Wir haben den Podcast gestartet mit Anne Applebaum, eigentlich eine Neokonservative,
die jetzt mit Preisen bedacht wird.
Friedenspreisen wollen genau sein.
Ja, der amerikanische Neokonservatismus außenpolitisch gesehen wieder da.
Adam Toos sagt folgendes.
Was wirklich rung a bell for me ist, dass aside from the Iran dimension,
where I agree, you could do a kind of cost-benefit analysis.
And I think Es ist wahr, wenn man die Geschichte aus Washington hat,
dass sie eigentlich eine Backchannel zu Tehran haben, sie kommunizieren sehr
gut mit ihnen, sie manifestieren die Tit-for-Tat-Response such dass das nicht escalate.
Nevertheless, I think, and this would be the point I would add,
I think there is a strain of US Middle East policy thinking,
and it's centered on these two figures, McGurk and Hochstein,
I think that's the right way of pronouncing his name, who are really the fixers
in the Middle East space.
Because Middle East didn't have top priority in the Biden administration, right?
Sullivan is the big brain behind the China policy, and Blinken is the Atlanticist
guy running Ukraine, which is deeply, you know, very much on the president's mind.
And so Middle East was delegated. It was delegated in part because it was problematic,
because Biden had taken this strong anti-Saudi, anti-MBS position.
And his people have to walk him back from that, because they realize that if
you're going to do realpolitik in the Middle East, you need to do business with
the Israelis sorry, you need to do business with the Saudis and what Netanyahu
wants most in the world is normalisation with the Saudis.
Und dann gibt es da so einen Namen.
Und so das ist die Richtung sie haben sie in. Und all das ist ein lang,
über mehrere Jahre jetzt, einigeschter in den US-policy world von der Erfahrung
von 2003. Und dann ISIS, das ist crucial.
McGurk, ich glaube, hat sich Hamas und Hezbollah und es ist natürlich total confusion.
Aber in seinem Geist, Terror ist Terror. Und dealing mit Terror involves crushing diese zwei actors.
Und das ist, wie es geht, wo die conflation happens. Und so,
though I agree from a classic cost-benefit kind of analysis of what you might
need to do to contain Iran, this is obviously overkill.
They don't underestimate the degree of influence they have over Israel,
so the question is, do you let this dog run, right? Do you let this dog bark?
Do you let this force play out?
And I think this is why I refer to this as like a controlled demolition.
I think that's what Israel is doing for them.
Und weiter sagt er?
Ist so indignant. Es ist nicht aus, auszudränglichem concern für die Palestinians.
Es ist weil sie can see that this doesn't lead anywhere.
My answer to you is I'm not sure one can give a coherent account of that.
It resolves then into well, let's destroy and eliminate Hamas and everyone can
applaud and say well, yeah, clearly we agree about that.
But then you say well, how would you do that? And the answer is there is no way.
And so this is why this labeling of Hamas und Hezbollah als ISIS-Equivalent,
which I think is part of what's going on in the Biden administration, is so disastrous.
Because if you do that, then we all agree, of course, you can't negotiate with ISIS.
That would be impossible, even though we know perfectly well that behind the
scenes throughout that conflict, there were a variety of different contacts
from a lot of different actors, which did involve negotiation with ISIS.
But when you say it out loud, it's unspeakable. So we don't.
So I think that's the kind of impasse that we're in.
Jetzt habe ich den Namen leider rausgeschnitten, um den es da noch ging in der
Biden-Administration.
Ich bin gespannt, ob du ihn kennst. Brad McGurk.
Ich habe den noch nie vorher gehört. Adam Toos erwähnt den hier und sagt,
es gibt da in der Huffington Post einen langen Artikel über ihn.
Den habe ich dann gesucht und gefunden.
How a deeply controversial White House Advisor is running the agenda on Gaza.
Der Artikel ist von Dezember 2023.
Und dieser Brad McGurk ist schon lange in Washington tätig. Er war tätig für George W.
Bush, für Obama, für Trump. Trump für Biden jetzt.
Es gibt einen Witz, den sich Sicherheitsberater erzählen, wenn eine Atombombe
auf Washington DC abgeworfen würde, würden zwei Lebensformen überleben,
Kakerlaken und Pratt McGurk.
Fred McGurk ist jemand, der gegen den islamischen Staat vorgehen sollte,
das war so seine Arbeit hauptsächlich und Adam Too's These ist und auch die
von Huffington Post ist, dass er diese Idee,
wie der islamische Staat bekämpft werden muss, muss auch Hezbollah,
muss Hamas, muss alles eigentlich bekämpft werden,
jetzt in die beiden Administrationen tief implementiert hat.
Er unglaublich viel, ja Entscheidungsgewalt hat natürlich Biden,
aber unglaublich viel Spielraum hat, seine Agenda durchzudrücken und dass der
jetzt gerade sehr entscheidend ist,
wenn es darum geht, wie richtet sich die Biden-Administration im Nahen Osten aus.
Und für ihn könnte das also eigentlich alles gerade sehr richtig laufen,
dass er überhaupt gar keine Kritik in dem Sinne an Netanjahu hat, sondern dass….
Offenbar McGurk auch die Hilfe für Zivilisten in Gaza an Bedingungen knüpfen wollte.
Also nur wenn Geiseln freigegeben werden und so weiter, dann sollen die überhaupt Hilfe leisten.
Hier heißt es dann im Artikel, viele Quellen brachten ihren Respekt für verschiedene
Elemente von McGurks Hintergrund und Arbeit zum Ausdruck. Der Beamte des Weißen
Hauses sagte, er arbeite eng und kooperativ mit Kollegen der gesamten Regierung zusammen.
Doch die meisten äußerten noch tiefe Besorgnis über McGurks Macht und darüber,
was sie für die Zukunft der US-Nahost-Strategie bedeuten könnte.
Ein ehemaliger US-Beamter hob McGurks Social-Media-Posting eines Videos der
israelischen Regierung hervor, das den Ton einer beiden Rede über Aufnahmen der Anschläge vom 11.
September, Leichen palästinensischen Kämpfern und amerikanischen Waffen wiedergab.
Der ehemalige Beamte spekulierte, dass dies bei McGurk Anklang fand,
weil er sich zuvor auf den islamischen Staat konzentriert hatte.
Das Framing des Krieges gegen den Terror und die Beschreibung,
dass es sich um einen Kampf zwischen Gut und Böse handelt, schürt antimuslimische
und anti-arabische Bigotterie, sagte der ehemalige Beamte.
Es werden auf falsche Analogien gezogen, denn das, was hier passiert, ist nicht ISIS.
Und das ist aber etwas, was wohl McGurk sehr stark macht.
Und ja, die Spekulation ist jetzt,
ist also diese außenpolitische Ausrichtung der USA gerade eine,
die sehr stark bestimmt wird durch Brad McGurk und seinen doch etwas verengten
Blick auf diese Strukturen dort, nämlich immer nur in allem ein Äquivalent zum
islamischen Staat zu sehen.
Also wer weiß, wer weiß, ich kenne ihn nicht.
Aber man kann das mal nachlesen, bei Huffington Post ist es lesenswert.
Wahrscheinlich ist er auch sehr mächtig, aber so wie das nun mal ist,
er selber wird sich wahrscheinlich nicht sehr mächtig sehen, sondern,
Interessante Bild, was aber jetzt bei Adam Tues, ohne dass ich jetzt sage,
ich hätte jetzt Adam Tues komplett durchdrungen, was er gerade gesagt hat,
aber dieses Bild von Außenpolitik im Speziellen, aber Politik allgemein.
Wir unterstellen ja immer große Pläne.
Irgendwer muss ja sein Wahlprogramm schreiben und dann suchen wir uns da was
aus und sagen, mach das mal. Und dann stellen wir fest, naja,
hat er gar nicht gemacht.
Und das sehen wir ja auch jetzt gerade bei der Ampel. Mal gucken,
wie lange sie noch da ist.
Dass Politik einfach nur der Mut ist, Sachen anzustoßen und dann nachzusteuern.
Ohne, dass man weiß, was da genau passiert. Selbst wenn Atomkriege mit im Raum
stehen. Das ist doch hier beeindruckend.
Also in welchem Maße hier einfach so eine Potentialität.
Naja, wir sind ja Amerika, wir können ja erstmal so, ja, dann schiebt man den
Yoganauten sozusagen an und dann hofft man einfach mal, dass man es hinkriegt da.
Das ist schon bedenklich, finde ich.
Es ist sehr undurchsichtig alles, es ist furchtbar, aber ich hoffe auch,
dass jetzt eine andere Berichterstattung mehr Einzug hält darüber und hoffentlich
darauf Also was wir hier gehört haben.
War deutsches Fernsehen Ja.
Ja, immerhin, immerhin. Dass dadurch auch ein Druck entsteht,
dass man sich nicht weiter in dieser Weise schuldig macht.
Wir hören jetzt zum Schluss noch Baerbock, denn so geht es nicht.
Wie ich gerade unterstrichen habe, ist die Welt nicht schwarz und weiß.
Und jeder verantwortungsvolle Politiker, jede verantwortungsvolle Politikerin,
die nicht die Augen vor der Realität verschließt.
Sondern sich der Welt stellt, und zwar einer Welt, nicht wie sie sich gerne wünschen würde,
sondern in der sie lebt, sieht, wenn man beide Augen öffnet,
dass wir in einer Situation sind, in einem Dilemma, wo auf der einen Seite tagtäglich
Israel angegriffen wird und eine Nichtunterstützung bedeuten würde,
dass Menschen sich nicht vor diesen Angriffen und die Angriffe des Irans, die wir gesehen haben,
hatten das Ziel, sonst wären es keine militärischen schweren Angriffe gewesen,
wie es sie in der Vergangenheit noch nie gegeben hat, Das Ziel, Menschen zu töten,
das ist deutsche Verantwortung, Israel dabei zu unterstützen,
sich gegen solche Angriffe zu verteidigen.
Und ebenso ist es deutsche Verantwortung, für das humanitäre Völkerrecht einzustehen,
für humanitäre Hilfe einzustehen.
Und deswegen immer wieder deutlich zu machen, wie ich das gerade eben auch hier
getan habe. Dafür trägt die israelische Regierung eine Verantwortung,
dass sie dieses humanitäre Völkerrecht befolgt.
Und in dem Sinne haben wir mit Blick auf Waffenlieferungen für uns immer wieder
diese beiden zentralen Aspekte übereinandergelegt.
Und uns der Realität gestellt.
Ja, und dabei hat sie vergessen zu sagen, dass dabei das beim Übereinanderlegen
so war, dass das Erste dann doch das Zweite überdeckt war.
Denn das Erste ist ja so, es geht um das Existenzrecht Israels und das hat man
zugesichert und das ist auch richtig.
Aber das Andere versucht man dann und versucht die Ampelregierung zu ignorieren
und liefert einfach Waffen weiter.
Und da kann man natürlich immer noch mal mahnen und sagen und ist uns auch gar
nicht so recht, aber auch mit Bauchschmerzen geliefert sind sie geliefert und so geht es nicht.
Es ist im Grunde genau diese intellektuelle Faulheit, wie bei Armin Laschet ja auch.
Details, wer will schon über Details reden? Wir müssen den Holocaust aufarbeiten.
Israel darf machen, was es will. Geopolitische Überlegung? No.
Es ist sehr bedauerlich, das zu sehen.
Ich finde es wirklich in dieser Massivität,
in der es stattfindet, dass man so einen Unsinn permanent von den Regierenden
gesagt bekommt, wirklich einfach auch schon intellektuell beschämt und darüber hinaus dann sowieso.
Wir wollen aber noch was Lustiges zum Schluss machen.
Wir sind schon wirklich schlimm über der Zeit. Aber lass uns noch was Lustiges machen.
Und zu Halloween gehören auch lustige Sachen.
Okay, dann springen wir zum Tomorrow Podcast von Tom Junkersdorf.
Der hat immer Leute aus dem Lifestyle-Business zu Gast.
Diesmal Philipp Plein, das ist ein Modemacher, der besonders geschmacklose Mode
herstellt und jetzt auch noch ein Hotel eröffnet hat.
Tom Junkersdorf ist dort zu Gast in diesem Hotel und wir erfahren jetzt,
wo sich die Superreichen aufhalten. Und ich würde mal sagen,
wir können uns überlegen, müssen wir mit den Superreichen vielleicht schon Mitleid haben?
Oder ist das nochmal eine ganz klare Aufforderung, die Superreichen von ihrem
Geld zu befreien, damit sie sowas nicht weitermachen müssen? Wir hören mal rein.
Es geht ja nicht nur um das Hotel, es geht ja um Luxury, Hospitality und Entertainment.
Und ja, ich bin gerade dabei, etwas neu zu erfinden, was es so in dieser Welt
noch nicht gibt und das macht Spaß.
Das fand ich gerade das Überraschende, weil alle gedacht haben,
okay, jetzt macht Philipp auch ein Hotel, aber du hast gleich gesagt,
das ist Luxury Export Business, was du hier machst. Richtig.
Na, da können wir ja nur gespannt sein. Was ist das?
Man muss dazu sagen, das ist auch ein sehr spezielles Objekt.
Nicht nur, dass wir hier im Center von Mailand sind.
Im Stadtzentrum, alles ist, also der Dom, Monte Napoleone, alles kannst man
mit der Fuß ganz einfach erreichen.
In diesem Objekt hat Leonardo da Vinci gelebt. Leonardo da Vinci,
Derjenige, der die Mona Lisa unter anderem gezeichnet hat und gemalt hat.
Ich bin nochmal dazu gesagt, damit man so super weiß, wer war das nochmal der Kerl.
Leonardo da Vinci, ich sag ihn nochmal.
Man eignet es sich aber einfach so an, man hat eine abendländische Kunst,
hat null Zugang mehr dazu, wie man gerade merkt.
Mona Lisa.
Ja, Mona Lisa. Aber irgendwie cool, dass wir das jetzt besitzen.
Mega, wir haben es. auch darüber drohen können.
Restaurant. Das ist natürlich nicht irgendein Restaurant. So wie wir jetzt gleich
schon Schnitzel essen gehen.
Sukaro Bar ist ein Fein-Cousine Japaner. Das Menü habe ich designt,
zusammen mit meinem Chef.
Das hat mehrere Monate, fast ein Jahr gedauert, bis wir ein Menü hatten,
wo ich sage, das ist das jetzt.
Da sind wir konkurrenzfähig. Oder vielleicht sogar mit etwas am Start,
was es so noch nicht gibt.
Denn man braucht ja einen Anreiz für die Superreichen, dass die jetzt sagen,
ich bin gerade auf Ibiza, muss jetzt mal in den Flieger, da ist so eine Restaurant.
Er hat sich ja gerade versprochen.
Er wollte ja eigentlich, damit sind wir konkurrenzlos.
Sagen.
Und hat jetzt leider, und er hat sich nicht getraut, das zu korrigieren,
gesagt, ich habe ein Jahr gebraucht, um überhaupt von unten mich dem Status
Quo anzunähern. Das ist natürlich genau das Gegenteil von dem, was er will.
Das ist ja nicht nur das Interior. Was macht eine Marke zu einer Marke?
Die ganze Experience. Das fängt an beim Interior, bei der Musik.
Das ist ganz wichtig für mich. Das Lichtdesign, das Interior,
aber auch das Personal. Wie ist das Personal angezogen?
Das Essen, ganz klar.
Ah ja, das Essen gibt es auch noch. Aber eigentlich Interior.
Interior auch eine Rolle.
Interior.
Was gibt es dann jetzt auf dem Teller?
Was gibt es dort, was anders ist bei anderen? Apart von dem Teor, das du ja gesehen hast.
Nochmal Teor, ja.
Wir servieren unsere Special Host Rolls auf Samurai-Schwertern.
Habe ich noch nie gesehen. Also es kommt dann des Katana, Samurai-Katana.
Habe ich noch nie gesehen. Denke ich mir, ja, ergibt ja auch keinen Sinn.
Warum sollte man das machen?
Ja, also ich habe auch noch nie gesehen, dass ein Pfannkuchen auf einer falsch
rumgehaltenen Pfanne und zwar auf dem Stiel serviert wird. Könnte man ja auch mal machen.
Wird präsentiert vom Chef. Wir haben Special Rolls. Es gibt die 24 Karat Gold Roll.
Du kennst das ja vom Norset. Der hat sein goldenes Steak.
Wir haben tatsächlich goldenes Sushi, komplett in Gold.
Bisschen so Félo-Roché-Style mäßig. Noch nie gesehen, noch nie davor gegessen. Unglaublich.
Warum sollte man das auch tun?
Gold auf Essen. Ich habe diesen Monat auch Gold gegessen.
Das wird bitte als Staub auf das Dessert gestreuselt und nicht,
wir verpacken deinen Sushi, damit du nicht mehr siehst, was du isst. Es ist Gold.
Das sind einfach Leute, die haben keine Fantasie.
Sie interessieren sich für nichts, weder für ihre Mitmenschen,
noch für irgendwelche kulturellen Erzeugnisse.
Und dann denken sie, gut, was soll ich mit dem Geld machen und wie kriege ich die Zeit verbummelt?
Klaviere, Gold zu essen auf einem Samurai-Schwert.
Ja.
Das ist genial.
Gibt aber noch ein anderes Restaurant. Du weißt, Sushi ist nicht so meins,
aber Pizza. Wäre das was für mich?
Wir haben Philips, ein italienisches Restaurant und Club.
Das ist sehr speziell. Wir haben einen Michel-Ester-Chef, Roberto Conti,
der mit mir die Rezepte kreiert hat für dieses wirklich High-End-Entertainment-Hospitality-Konzept.
Du hast vorhin die Pizza gesehen. Pizza made with Champagne also sowas gibt
es nirgendwo auf der Welt auch mit dem ganzen Show-Charakter,
der dahinter steckt Du weißt.
Es muss ein bisschen Flüssigkeit in den Teig, normalerweise ist das Wasser,
die kippen jetzt einfach etwas
Champagner da rein Schlimmer kann man Champagner nicht verschwenden Ich.
Erkläre jetzt mal, was ich glaube also was ich da wirklich schlimm finde,
Wir haben dieses Essen gehabt. Acht Gänge.
Unter anderem Gold auf Schokolade gestreuselt. Alles sah super aus.
Und es wird ja so serviert, dass dir gesagt wird, was jetzt in diesem Gang dran
ist. Da kommt also jemand an den Tisch, stellt dir nicht nur das Essen hin, sondern und so.
Und wie lange hast du dann da gesessen für die Acht Gänge?
Drei Stunden und 20 Minuten saßen wir da. Und es ist ja so, dass wer mit mir
am Tisch sitzt, führt ein Gespräch.
Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo jemand kommt und dir erklärt, was du als nächstes
isst, hast du immer im Hinterkopf so ein, schon klar, es ist Heilbutt.
Ich brauche gar nicht zu wissen, aus welchem mehr das jetzt kommt.
Ich hoffe einfach, es ist gut. Es ist ja teuer. Ich habe es übrigens nicht selbst
bezahlen müssen. Also danke, Humann.
Und das Ding ist, ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass es vielen geht wie
mir, die also acht Unterbrechungen schon als Unterbrechung klassifizieren.
Aber nicht diese reichen Leute, weil die haben nichts zu sagen.
Genau. Das ist nämlich das Hospitality-Konzept. Du kommst hierher,
du hast den Leuten, mit denen du da bist, nichts zu sagen, ihr langweilt euch
ohne Ende, also sorgen wir auch für das Entertainment.
Also was für uns extrem nervig ist, dass du nämlich, ah, jetzt kommt das nächste
Essen, alle lehnen sich zurück, schweigen, es wird erklärt, was da steht.
So, und dann geht's weiter.
Das ist bei denen 1000 Euro Aufpreis, damit überhaupt was los ist am Tisch.
Am Ende reden die noch über diese Samurai-Schwerter.
Ja, natürlich, das sind ja hohle Menschen und die sagen, ach,
hier sind Samurai-Schwerter und hier ist Gold drauf. Ja, ich hab ja das goldene
Steak, letzte Woche da und dort gegessen.
Diese Leute tun mir wirklich sehr leid.
Ja, die müssen einem leidtun. Was kostet die Pizza?
Pizza für 1500 Euro. Hört sich teuer an, aber am Ende ist die Pizza umsonst,
weil du kriegst ja eine Flasche Champagner, Dom Perignon Rosé on top.
Nur mehr oder weniger.
Also wer Dom Perignon Rosé, ich habe noch keinen getrunken, aber ich habe schon
mal einen Dom Perignon Weiß getrunken in meinem Leben.
Ich kann sagen, ja, da bin ich eingeladen worden, das war, der ist sowas,
das ist ein sehr teurer Champagner.
Das scheint aber so eine Special Edition noch zu sein, also der Dom Perignon
kostet ja schon 150 Euro.
Weißt du, wie der sich unterscheidet von deinem weißen?
Pass auf.
Nur durch den Preis.
Glaubt ihr das besser? Schmeckt besser? Das kann sein, was ich nur anmerken
will ist, also es gibt Unterschiede beim Champagner, wie es auch Unterschiede beim Weine gibt.
Ich würde nicht 1000 Euro für eine Flasche ausgeben, ich bin ja nicht irre,
kann es auch nicht ausgeben.
Aber was ich sagen kann, ist, dass ich es noch für möglich halte,
dass Leute sich wirklich mit Champagner und mit Weinen auskennen und da Unterschiede
herausschmecken können.
Was aber klar ist, ist, dass man der absolute Banause ist, wenn man Champagner in den Pizzateig kippt.
Dann muss man einfach nur geschmacklos sein und will geldlos werden,
weil das so sinnlos ist, dass man das einfach nicht mehr in Worte fassen kann.
Ja, das habe ich gerade überhört. Also ich spiele den Clip nochmal,
die gießen das in den Teig. Ich dachte, das gibt es dazu.
Nein, du bekommst eine Pizza, normalerweise ist es da, wie wir eine Pizza machen,
Mehl, Hefe, bisschen Wasser.
Und da kommt aber Dom Perignon Rosé Special Edition rein.
Eine Flasche, die über 1000 Euro kostet. Und dann bekommst du die Pizza und
das, was in der Flasche noch übrig bleibt, weil die ja nicht 0,7 Liter da reinkippen,
das kannst du dann dort trinken.
Und deswegen kostet die Pizza 1500 Euro, also inklusive dieser Flasche, die da noch übrig ist.
Das musst du dir mal vorstellen, wie irre man sein muss. Aber das ist ja genau
dieser Kult, der Superreißen, den du sehen kannst bei TikTok oder Instagram.
Dann haben die guten Champagner dort, also zum Teil auch günstige,
wie jetzt Bollinger oder was, und dann machen die das ja auch so auf,
dass sie das knallen lassen oder mit dem Säbel.
Wer so ein Champagner aufmacht, der ist ja gar nicht am Geschmack interessiert.
Man macht den Korken ganz vorsichtig raus, damit nicht schon alles rausgeht an Aroma.
Also Leute, die so eine Champagnerflasche öffnen, müssten die sofort abgenommen
bekommen und verboten bekommen, jemals wieder einen Tropfen davon zu bekommen.
Danach, wie geht es weiter?
Schon das kostet. Wir servieren ja den Rest des Champagners am Tisch dann später.
Aber das ist halt einfach alles
ein Teil des Konzepts. ein bisschen Show mitbringen, Entertainment eben.
Das gibt es bei dem Italiener um die Ecke eben nicht.
Ja, Gott sei Dank.
Heute Abend wird Alec Monopoly auflegen. Gestern hatten wir Sven Veth.
Große Ikone. Ich bin großer Fan. Der ist jetzt auch mittlerweile über 60, glaube ich.
Ja, der legt dann dort auf.
Das geht nicht.
Also wirklich.
Dass dich der Typ vollquatscht, der dein Essen serviert, akzeptiere ich.
Weil der hat es ja zubereitet, er erklärt mir, was ich esse. Und Essen ist wichtig.
Nee, das ist ja danach kommt Sven Feth. Also danach ist Tanz dort in dem Lokal.
Aber heb dir das mal auf, was du da jetzt gleich sagen willst.
Kommen wir erst nochmal zu dem Hotel.
Wir haben hier das Boutique Hotel, Luxury Boutique Hotel. Jedes Zimmer hat eine
Sauna, jedes Zimmer hat ein Gym.
Jedes Zimmer ist komplett anders.
Ja, ganz toll.
Bei uns ist jedes Zimmer anders. Es gibt auch keine Zimmernummern,
es gibt nur Namen an der Tür.
Von fucking Fabolus bis hin zu Queen, Envy und so weiter. Also jedes Paradise,
jedes Zimmer hat einen anderen Namen.
Ja, geniales Konzept.
Genial.
Nummern wären ja zu einfach gewesen. Du kannst aber jetzt auch das machen,
was ich auch überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen kann. Also ich mag ja keinen Essensgeruch.
Ich lehne deshalb auch offene Küchen ab.
Hier kannst du aber noch einen Schritt weiter gehen.
Du kannst mit dem Chef in der Küche essen. Wir haben Michelin als Chef.
Du kannst also wirklich den Chef-Table haben in der Küche.
Das gibt es aber immer nur für zwei oder drei Gäste, weil wir haben nicht den Platz.
Das heißt, du bist und du isst in der Küche, wo the magic happens.
Ja, dann rieche ich dann danach nach Essen. Wie verrückt. Wer will das schon?
So, es gibt also diese Club-Sache danach, aber während des Essens gibt es natürlich
auch mitunter tolle Acts.
Jetzt halte ich fest, an diesem Abend, als wir diesen Podcast aufnehmen.
Wenn du heute Abend kommst, dann, ich hoffe du kommst,
haben wir Bonnie Tyler, die dort performen wird, auch das gehört dazu,
Special Guests zu haben, Special Performances, Bonnie Tyler ist eine Legend,
I Need a Hero oder Total Eclipse of My Heart, das sind natürlich Welthits,
die man kennt, die alle kennen.
Wie läuft das jetzt ab?
Und die wird wirklich während dem Essen performen. Du sitzt da,
du isst dort deine hausgemachten, also homemade Pasta. Wir machen auch unsere Pastas selber.
Und dann plötzlich steht der Bonnie Tyler 50 Zentimeter neben dir und singt ein Welthit.
Sowas gibt es halt auch nicht überall.
It's a hard day. Du isst da so ganz ruhig und dann brüllt dir Bonnie Tyler,
die ja auch seit etwa 20 Jahren nur noch Bedingtöne rausbringt,
einfach ins Ohr und das ist dann dein großes Entertainment-Programm.
Weltstar Bonnie Tyler.
Ich weiß, wie man noch extra kosten, damit das alles nicht passiert.
Ja.
Das wäre mein Feature. Gib mir den Champagner direkt im Glas,
ohne Umwege über den Pizzateig und was noch übrig bleibt und sowas.
Tisch bitte nicht in der Küche.
Ohne Essen.
Zahle extra dafür. Und bitte die Musik leise.
Ja, ich würde in manchen Restaurants wirklich gerne vorne hingehen und sage,
was kostet es, wenn sie die Musikleiser machen. Hier sind 30 Euro.
Das ist so schräg. Und wie stolz er das verkündet, dieser Müllhaufen an Ideen.
Das ist wirklich zu dumm, das können wir uns hier nicht leisten.
Aber das ist die Welt der Superreichen und wenn man sich doch ansieht,
welche, manchmal kriegt man auch diese Werbung angezeigt, welche Superluxushotels
irgendwie ein Wochenende einem günstig anbieten und dann liest man die Beschreibung
und denkt, oh Gott, das ist ja nur Stress,
da gehe ich ja lieber arbeiten, da gehe ich ja, ich wüsste gar nicht, was ich…,
da tun sollte, wenn ich die ganze Zeit angesprochen werde, entscheiden muss,
dann werden sie in unsere Käsekammer geführt.
Nein, ich möchte nicht in die Käsekammer geführt werden.
Du hast dich ja damals schon beklagt, als du in einem sehr guten Hotel von einem
Veranstalter untergebracht warst, dass du 25 Lichtschalter ausschalten musstest
und gar nicht mehr wusstest, wie es geht.
Ich habe dann wirklich Handtücher im Bad vor die entsprechenden Dinger gehangen,
weil ich nicht gewunden habe.
Wo es ausgeht.
Ich glaube, so war es nicht gedacht.
Das heißt, wir haben ein großes Mitleid mit den Superreichen.
Wir müssen sie von ihrem Geld befreien.
Also dass Marktforschung ergeben hat, dass das der richtige Anspruch,
also Ansprache an Superreichen ist, zeigt auch, dass es ein jämmerlicher Zustand
ist, in dem sich die Superreichen befinden.
Offenbar ist dieses ganze ich delegiere, ich delegiere nicht der richtige Weg.
Ja, es macht offenbar ein bisschen blöde.
Wir sprechen uns sehr bald im Salon, Nächste Woche nämlich.
Und dann geht es um Verlust, ein Grundproblem der Moderne von Andreas Reckwitz.
Darüber werden wir ausführlich diskutieren über das Buch.
Ich werde einen kurzen Roman mitbringen, einen sehr kurzen Roman von einer französischen
Schriftstellerin, der spielt in Russland, aber lange, lange vor dem Krieg.
Die jungen Russen werden dort in die Eisenbahn gebracht und sind gemustert,
werden jetzt zu ihrer Grundausbildung fahren und einer will nicht.
Und er lernt dort, setzt dann natürlich ganz in der Holzklasse,
zufällig eine Französin aus der ersten Klasse kennen.
Und zwischen denen entspinnt sich da etwas und es geht sehr viel um Solidarität
und wie man sich dem Zugriff des Staates entziehen kann. Ganz, ganz wunderbarer Text.
Den Rest will ich mir noch offen halten.
Sehr gut. Ich lasse es mir auch noch ein bisschen offen, denn ich muss jetzt
in der Woche mein eigenes Buch zu Ende schreiben und für uns lesen.
Aber es gibt wohl interessante Lektüren. Sowohl der OpenAI-Chef,
namentlich kennen wir ihn, als auch die Anthropic-Führung hat Briefe veröffentlicht.
Zum Teil 10.000 Worte lang.
Gucken wir dann mal, was da so drin steht, so in die Richtung.
Und es gibt interessante Bücher. Familie Aßmann hat wohl wieder was hingelegt.
Vielleicht schaue ich das auch erst im nächsten Monat mal gucken.
Prima, wir können uns also dann im Salon hören, sofern ihr ein Abo abschließt.
Das ist die Möglichkeit auch diesen Podcast finanziell zu unterstützen.
Man kann den Podcast übrigens auch anders noch unterstützen,
nämlich indem man ihn teilt.
Dazu wollen wir nochmal ganz klar aufrufen, also man kann ihn erstmal bewerten
bei den entsprechenden Plattformen, aber ganz wichtig ist auch teilen,
ist die Mundpropaganda,
ist das Posten in den sozialen Medien oder in die WhatsApp-Gruppe,
wo auch immer. Darüber würden wir uns sehr freuen.
Dann gibt es aber die Möglichkeit, den Podcast auch finanziell zu unterstützen
und dann diesen Zusatzinhalt, den Salon zu hören, nämlich über Patreon,
wenn man dort schon ist, oder Apple,
wenn man ohnehin Apple-Kunde ist und bereit ist, ein bisschen mehr zu zahlen.
Ich glaube, da kostet es 3,90 Euro oder so etwas ist der Preis.
Jedenfalls für 3 Euro im Monat ist man dabei, wenn man über Steady das abschließt.
Wie macht man das über Steady?
Ähm, man geht auf die Seite, folgt dem goldenen Button und ab dann sollte es
eigentlich selbsterklärend sein.
Man springt hinter die Zahlungshürde, indem man seine, wie möchte ich bezahlen
Frage beantwortet und taucht dann ab, direkt auf der Seite, auf der ein Button
ist, auf der steht abonnieren. Und man denkt sich, ich habe doch gerade abonniert.
Ja, damit ist dann gemeint, den
RSS-Feed in seiner Lieblings-Podcast-App abonnieren. Und dann hört man.
Man kriegt ja dann seinen Salon einfach geliefert. Das Handy sagt, neuer Salon ist da.
Willst du auf Play klicken? Ja, will ich. Und dann hört man.
Also ganz einfach, wer möchte kann so unterstützen, wir würden uns jedenfalls
sehr über die Unterstützung freuen und wir werden dann in der Salonfolge auch bekannt geben,
wann man uns in der KS in Frankfurt im nächsten Jahr live erleben kann, viermal wird das sein.
Bis dahin eine gute Zeit und wir schauen dann mal, ob wir schon zum Salon einen
neuen Präsidenten ausrufen können.
Ich will einen Verhaltenstipp geben, wichtig, weil sehr viele Leute sind ja
nun interessiert. Die Wahl findet nachts statt.
Ihr wollt am Dienstag ganz normal ins Bett gehen und dann am Mittwoch aufwachen,
weil das Interessante folgt am Mittwoch ab 8 oder 9 Uhr.
Nicht sich die Nacht durch den, und dann plötzlich, wenn es interessant wird,
oh, ich bin so müde und so.
Also es ist falsch. Die Wahl beginnt nachts, aber dieses ganze Ausgezähle und
so, das findet dann hier so Mittwoch, 9, 10, 11, 12 Uhr statt.
Also in der Hinsicht nicht den Fehler machen wie die ARD und 3 Uhr drei Frauen
hinsetzen, die jetzt erklären, warum Hillary Clinton gewonnen hat.
Sondern nein, 12 Stunden später kommt dann die Erklärung, warum es doch Trump gewonnen ist.
Also in der Hinsicht, geht schlafen am Dienstag.
Gute Nacht.